Du hast ja Precht und Welzer gelesen, nicht wahr? Und wie ist jetzt das Urteil? Lieber Brahms im heutigen Journal oder lieber Leila? Wie kommen wir darauf?
Nun, sie gehen darauf ein, dass Brahms, wenn es im Heute-Journal gespielt wird, also wenn da mal ein klassisches Stück kurz vorkommt, wenn es einen Beitrag gibt über zum Beispiel Brahms, dann sinken die Quoten.
Minus 9 Prozent.
Sobald Menschen mit klassischer Musik, mit Hochkultur konfrontiert werden, dann sind sie abgeschreckt und gehen schnell zu RTL oder sonst wohin. Und natürlich wissen wir, dass das keine neue Erkenntnis ist, aber es ist doch noch mal so ganz interessant, das so als Zahl zu lesen. Und das wird dann gekoppelt damit, dass wir zugleich eine Debatte haben über einen Mallorca-Hit, einen Ballermann-Hit, Leila. Und das geht dann so weit, dass sogar der Komponist dieses Liedes, Icke Hüftgold heißt der wohl, in der Zeit einen Leitartikel schreiben darf, zum Thema, was darf man heute noch sagen und singen. Und plötzlich generiert das die große Aufmerksamkeit. Ein Lied, das sicherlich von minderer musikalischer Qualität ist. Aber das ist was interessiert. Und Brahms wird immer weniger stattfinden, weil man aufgrund der Quoten sehen kann, dass Brahms nicht so beliebt ist wie Leila.
Genau, an der Stelle des Buches, ich habe es gerade in den Notizen gefunden, ist ein Teil, den Welzer geschrieben hat. Er kommt direkt davor, darauf zu sprechen, dass, weil man sich immer fragt, Brahms oder Leila. Es sind ja diese Schiffres, also diese Stellvertreter-Anmerkung, die man so macht, um einen eigentlichen Punkt zu finden, was dann für Melanie Ammann und so weiter bedeutet. Ne, das akzeptiere ich gar nicht, dass damit eigentlich nur ein Argument illustriert werden sollte, sondern ich rede jetzt direkt über Brahms und Leila und werfe denen vor, dass sie irgendwas nicht beachtet haben. Wo man sich so denkt, wenn man zuhört, oh Mann, das ist doch irgendwie blöd, auf dieser Sachebene. Das ist wie in so echten Beziehungen, wenn sie ausgekühlt werden sollen, weil irgendwer keine Lust mehr hat. Und dann reagiert man nur noch immer ganz sachlich und lässt alle emotionalen Sachen außen vor. Und dann muss man nur eine Woche warten und dann sind Arbeitsbehältnisse, Freundschaften, Liebesbeziehungen einfach ausgekühlt und zu Ende. Und genauso wird ja auch die Diskussion gerade geführt. Aber Brahms und Leila sind eben nur Stellvertreter, Schiffern genannt für das eigentliche Problem. Und hier würde ich sagen...
Mit allen Journalisten, die genannt werden. Also es geht nicht darum, dass die hier eine Front fahren gegen bestimmte bekannte Journalisten, an denen sie sich immer mal rechnen wollen. Das ist zumindest nicht das Thema des Buches. Es kann immer irgendwelche Absichten noch im Hintergrund geben. Aber das ist nicht das Relevante, sondern sie nehmen eigentlich nur symptomatisch irgendwelche Zitate von bekannten Journalisten und sagen, wenn Robin Alexander sagt, ich stand an der Würstchensbude und habe von rechts und links jeweils immer erfahren, was bei den Koalitionsverhandlungen oder so los ist, welches Theater da gerade gespielt wird und habe da das schnell, das alles bei Twitter reingegeben, dann ist das nicht gegen Robin Alexander persönlich. Das könnte auch irgendjemand anders sein, aber es zeigt ein mediales Verfahren, das kritikwürdig ist.
Genau, und wir verschaffen uns gleich einen Überblick. Wir haben ja die Zeit hier, bleiben aber trotzdem noch an diesem punktuellen, denn Robin Alexander reagierte dann in der Land-Sendung tatsächlich auf dieses ich nehme mich für voll und die wollen wirklich mich kritisieren und nicht mich als Illustration, als Schiffre und so weiter nutzen. Aber wir haben doch damals in der Welt von unserem Herausgeber Stefan Austen Text bekommen, der auch schon mal gesagt hat, wir sollten vielleicht nicht allzu viele Waffen in die Ukraine schicken. Und sehen Sie, es gibt also auch die Gegenmeinung. Und das ist natürlich genauso blöd, wie das Klaus Kleber damals im 250. Aufwarn-Podcast saß und meinte, wir haben das doch morgens gespielt. Da gab es doch einen Bericht im Morgenmagazin. Habt ihr den nicht gesehen? Und man denkt sich so, ja genau, es gab vor drei Monaten im Morgenmagazin mal einen kurzen Bericht. Aber das ist ja nun kein Gegenargument für das, was wir eigentlich nur illustrieren, aber darüber hinaus auch argumentieren wollten. Jedenfalls, kleine Pointe. Kurz vor Brahms gegen Layla, als Welzer das ansprach, schreibt er darüber, dass es eine Eilmeldung bei Spiegel Online gab zum Thema Regierung Scholz plant eine Wohngeldreform. Und er macht sich darüber lustig. Ja, die planen halt irgendwas. Warum machen die da eine Eilmeldung draus? Wohngeldreform. Und da muss ich aber denken, ne, eine Wohngeldreform, selbst wenn sie nur geplant ist, ist tatsächlich eine Eilmeldung wert, weil das nämlich mal ein politisches Ereignis wäre, das wirklich die meisten Menschen betrifft. Weil wir wohnen alle und es ist für alle teuer.
Ich kann es dir beweisen, ich hab genau das angestrichen im Buch und dachte exakt dasselbe, denn das wären eigentlich die Eilmeldungen, die ich lesen will und dann würde ich am liebsten noch sagen, dass mit Ernstamine verkündet wird und aufgrund dieser Ankündigung wird es heute einen Brennpunkt geben. Und dann würde ich gerne vom Paritätischen, den Schneider hören und so weiter und so fort. Und die sollten dann alle noch mal beschreiben, wie prekär Wohnen in Deutschland ist, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Beengte Räumlichkeiten und all das. Und dann hätte man dazu mal 15 substanzielle Minuten.
Genau. Und damit sehen wir, wir sollten uns nicht so sehr in den Inhalten aufhängen, denn diese Wohngeld-Anekdote ist eine, wo wir den beiden richtig vorwerfen, wieder Elitendiskurs zu führen und die Relevanz von so was zu übersehen und Brahms-Layla ist nun wirklich austauschbar. Beginnen wir also, wo das Buch auch beginnt. Und das ist auch herausragend gut darstellbar, weil das gleich eins der ganz großen Probleme im Kern tangiert. Wenn Precht heute einen Aufschlag macht und sagt, man kann nicht mehr alles, was man gerne sagen würde, öffentlich sagen. Zwei Mal dahingestellt, ob das früher mal anders war oder künftig anders werden sollte oder wie auch immer. Aber es gibt eine Einschränkung in der Meinungsfreiheit, in der gefühlten Meinungsfreiheit. Man traut sich selber weniger zu, man antizipiert so eine Art Zensur und dann macht man das schon mal. Dann bekommt ihr immer der Vorwurf, ach so, das sagt ja dann jemand, der selber eine mega mäßige Plattform hat und so weiter. Und das liest man ja von jedem. Selbst Minkma war sicher nicht zu blöde, bei Übermedien noch mal darüber zu schreiben und die Anmerkung zu machen, dass ja Precht gar nicht das Recht hat, diese Art der Kritik vorzubringen, weil er ja die größte Plattform hat, also überall alles sagen darf. Und da muss man ganz klar mal markieren. Dieses Buch beginnt damit, dass die beiden als Anwälte derjenigen auftreten, die auf Nachfrage sagen, ich traue mir nicht mehr alles zu, zu sagen. Sie reden also nicht über sich, sondern über ein Publikum, das Publikum der Medien, das an diesen Diskursen, wie sie stattfinden, nicht partizipiert. Diese Funktionsweisen kann man dann später irgendwie mit Elitendiskurs und so weiter. Es sind also gewisse Distanzen gegeben, aber die Zahlen sind ja trotzdem beeindruckend, denn die Alnsbach-Umfrage innerhalb von zehn Jahren ist die Zustimmung zu diesem, ich habe den Eindruck, ich kann nicht mehr alles sagen und so weiter, die Zustimmung ist von 26 auf 44 Prozent gewachsen. Also vorher nur jeder Vierte, jetzt ist es jeder Zweite so grob, der einfach sagt, ja das stimmt, ich fühle mich hier irgendwie so, ich kann es nicht genau beschreiben, unterdrückt. Ich habe zwar die Ahnung, mir würde nicht wirklich was passieren oder so, aber ich fühle mich unwohl, meine Meinung zu sagen und ich leide auch darunter, dass es anderen auch so geht. Und das muss man ja wahnsinnig ernst nehmen, weil das zum Beispiel auch mein Eindruck komplett spiegelt. Wenn ich als jemand, von dem man weiß, der macht sowas mit Podcasts und der guckt so ganz viel politischen Kram, wenn ich irgendwo bin, geht es nur darum, gerade Unterhörern, dass sie genau diesen Eindruck haben, dass sie nicht wissen, wie es weitergeht, wo man noch ordentlich diskutieren kann, was macht man jetzt mit unseren Sorgen und so weiter. Ich werde immer nur zugeballert mit irgendwelchen Informationen und traue mich dann selber nicht mehr aus der Deckung. Also sie greifen hier einen Gemütszustand und einen allgemeinen Zustand auf, der von wahnsinnig vielen, sage ich jetzt auf so einer qualitativen Ebene, gefühlte Empirie sozusagen, könnte man auch wieder kritisieren, geteilt wird, was ein echtes Problem in Deutschland ist.
Und das meine ich jetzt nicht, dass das absolut direkt so stimmt. Aber wenn man jetzt daraus einfach macht, gut, dann sind wohl die Hälfte der Bevölkerung total verblendet, dann muss man sagen, ja, aber wie will man jetzt noch in einem Land leben, wo man einfach sagt, ja, 50 Prozent kann man eh vollkommen abhaken. Genau. Und das ist ja etwas, was dann genau zu so einer Radikalisierung auch führt, dass man sagt, die haben mich abgehakt. Dann bin ich jetzt in der absoluten Anti-Haltung da. Und es ist richtig, dass du das nochmal hier betonst. Es geht also nicht darum, dass Wälzer sagt, ich kann kaum noch was sagen in den Medien. Und ich würde auch da schon mal gleich sagen, wir können empirisch nachweisen, dass es natürlich diesen und jenen Artikel gab und gibt, der zum Beispiel diese Forderungen nach schweren Waffen kritisiert. Aber Leitmedial, und damit meine ich jetzt zum Beispiel, was die großen, reichweitenstarken Journalisten von sich geben oder was in den Talkshows passiert, ist nicht so, dass diese Positionen auch in gleicher Weise abgebildet werden und schon gar nicht in dem Verhältnis, wie das offenbar an der Bevölkerung der Falle ist. Dann wäre man bei einer 50-50-Auflösung, sondern wir haben das ja schon alles mal vorgestellt. Du hast es im Fernsehpodcast auch mehrmals gezeigt. Es ist so, dass vier Gäste da sind und ein Antipode. Und dann würde ich dann noch mal auch herausstellen, wer wird eigentlich ausgewählt, um in diesen Talkshows dann über so was zu sitzen? Also wenn ich jetzt über den Ukraine-Krieg diskutieren will, über schwere Waffentiefungen, und ich setze dann als Antipoden zu dieser allgemeinen Haltung, man soll schwere Waffen liefern, Ulrike Gero, Sarah Wagenknecht oder Alice Weidel dahin, dann ist das Signal ja vollkommen klar. Nämlich an alle, die vielleicht sagen, ist das so eine gute Idee, könnten wir dadurch den Krieg selbst zum Eskalieren bringen. Wenn die diese drei Damen da sehen, dann sagen die sich, oh Gott, mit denen will ich aber nun wirklich nichts zu tun haben, also gehe ich lieber auf die andere Seite. Das heißt, man kann natürlich durch unseriöse Personen, und ich mache die jetzt auch mal hier wirklich in einem Abwasch alle drei, ich habe da jetzt, wir sind hier hinter der Paywall, keine Probleme mit, das mal so zu machen, auch wenn ich das noch mal differenzieren würde, und will jetzt nicht Weidel und Wagenknecht auf eine Stufe stellen, also eigentlich nicht. Aber wenn ich das in dieser Weise natürlich mache und führe die Diskussion so, dann habe ich zwar noch die andere Meinung abgebildet, aber von einem Vertreter lasse ich sie aussprechen, der so unseriös ist, dass es eigentlich schon besser wäre, man hätte die Meinung dann gar nicht platziert gehabt, als sie von so jemandem vortragen zu lassen. Und ich will heute ja auch ein bisschen über mich reden, nämlich will das gleich, aber man sieht, wie heißt das Thema ist, dass man direkt auf so vieles kommt. Aber das ist das große Problem, dass man dann sofort dieses Lagerdenken macht. Das heißt, wenn dann ein Argument kommt mit, ja, schwere Waffen liefern sind problematisch, ach, siehst du das etwa so wie Alice Weidel, was ja dann bis dahin ging, dass in manchen Zeitungen stand, New York Times teilt die Produkte, New York Times Editorial, unterstützt Wagenknecht Position. So als hätte das Editorial auf Wagenknecht reagiert. Nein, die haben nur ein Argument gemacht, das ähnlich auch von Sarah Wagenknecht gemacht wurde. Und ich hab das ja bei den Masken erlebt. Wenn ich sage, ich glaube, es ist nicht mehr sinnvoll, weiter bei Kulturveranstaltungen Masken zu tragen, dann werde ich in der Schwurplecke gestellt. Obwohl ich dreimal geimpft bin, obwohl ich mich noch zeitweise für eine Impfpflicht ausgesprochen habe, aber es ist dann alles weg. Sondern diese Gegenmasken, dann bist du eigentlich wie die Wildgewordene von BildTV oder so.
Genau, und das lässt sich alles wahnsinnig leicht abstrahieren. Denn, und sie kommen so ein bisschen drauf zu sprechen, ich hab das ja in Redaktionsschluss damals schon vor inzwischen sechs Jahren, ist viel strapazierter gemacht. Und viele Argumente, die sie heute machen, konnte man damals schon anbringen. Zum Beispiel Wolfgang Michals monothematischen Journalismus. Wir haben die Migrationskrise, Corona und Krieg. Alles Themen, die aufeinander folgten, wo immer wirklich ein Thema gegen das andere ausgetauscht wurde. Und wer oben mitspielen wollte im reichweiten Spiel, musste dieses Thema bespielen. Weil Sehgewohnheiten und so weiter, niemanden überraschen mit irgendwas, nur so kleine Nuancen. Man muss eigentlich wissen, worum es geht, ab dem ersten Wort des Textes, irgendwen neu einführen in irgendein Thema. Das ging ja alles gar nicht. Wir hatten ja gar keine Zeit. Wieso sollen wir irgendwas zum Wohngeld lesen, wenn doch Krieg ist in Europa? Wir müssen natürlich über den Krieg reden. Und das beschreiben sie ja gleich am Anfang. Und dieses Vertrauen in Leitmedien, auch Vertrauen, ist natürlich so ein Dauerbrenner-Thema. Und wir übersehen so ein bisschen, wie wichtig eigentlich dieses Personalisierungsargument ist. Auch die beiden haben das so ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, da hätte man noch ein bisschen mehr Theorie und so weiter hinterherliefern können, um wirklich zu verstehen, die Reichweite dieser Argumentation zu sagen. Die allgemeinpolitischen Diskussionen verlagert sich vom Parlament in die Talkshows. Was bedeutet, da saßen nicht mehr Stellvertreter von Fraktionen, die sich auch einer gewissen Disziplin innerlich unterworfen haben. Was eben bedeutet, innerlich auch ein bisschen flacher argumentieren, aber dann eben für viele, sondern wir haben diese Stellvertreterei, wie du sie beschreibst. Natürlich können die jetzt immer sagen, wir haben ja die Flasspöler eingeladen und die konnte ja auch eine Gegenmeinung sagen. Aber das Vorzeichen dieses Arguments ist ja genau umgedreht. Weil sie sie eingeladen haben, konnte sie als Person in den Mittelpunkt gestellt werden und Diffamierungsmechanismen konnten überhaupt erst greifen, was ja alles strapaziert hat. Es wäre ja viel besser gewesen, sie einfach nicht einzuladen und zu sagen, da reden jetzt vier Leute mit einer Meinung zu einem Thema und es wäre dann auch das ehrliche Abbild von dem gewesen, worüber sie eigentlich alle reden wollen. Und dann muss man das Gegenargument irgendwo anders platzieren. Das ging zum Beispiel früher, als es hieß Historikerstreit. Ja, dann kommt halt hier ein Aufschlag in der Zeit und die Antwort kommt dann Tage später in einer anderen Zeitung, worauf die Zeit gar keinen Zugriff hat beim Besetzen dieser Debatte. Sondern man muss halt warten, bis jemand reagiert, auf den man nicht zugreifen kann. Wenn Lanz dann einfach sagt, und das muss man dann wirklich ernst nehmen, dieses Argument, die Einladungspolitik war ja trotzdem die der Lanzredaktion. Und dieses Zugeständnis, aber wir haben ja jemanden eingeladen, gilt dann einfach nicht. Sondern man hat dann wirklich nur jemanden eingeladen, um die ganze Argumentation zu personalisieren auf eine Person, die man dann noch leicht diffamieren kann, sodass du dann völlig zurecht sagst, naja, wenn die Weidel und die Wagenknecht da sitzen, dann erzeugt das ja gerade nicht, dass wir einfach ein freies Argument mal hören und sagen, klingt irgendwie logisch, sondern wir sehen nur, ah, da sitzen Weidel und Wagenknecht. Na, den schließe ich mich nicht an. Also ich bin da nicht bescheuert. Ich gehe auf die Straße und sage, ich unterstütze die beiden, die haben echt gute Argumente gemacht. Sondern nein, das ist natürlich alles schon verbranntes Kursgelände in dem Moment, wo sowas dann medial noch mal strapaziert wird, so richtig manifestiert wird, was das eigentliche Problem ist. Und ich finde, sie haben diesen guten Einstieg. Sie kommen mit diesen Zahlen und dann noch mal mit dem Prinzip, ja, wir haben ein Problem mit dem Vertrauen in Leitmedien, sagen auch, sind wir schwierig, das abzufragen. Und da fehlt mir aber am Anfang so ein wirklich theoretischer Unterbau des Vertrauens, dass man Vertrauen wirklich als ganz harte Kategorie ernst nimmt und die Funktionsweise tatsächlich aufzeigt von Vertrauen. Und es ist nicht nur als so eine, ja, wäre schon schön, wenn wir da mehr Vertrauen hätten, weil dann funktionierte das auch alles besser mit der Verständigung. Nee, man kann ruhig ein bisschen härter über Vertrauen reden. Das ist richtiger Beton und wir reden hier über das Fundament und so.
Es ist essenziell und ich habe das ja glaube ich schon mal erwähnt mit den Impfungen. Du hast dir ja hier immer alle Mühe gegeben, das zu erklären, wie das ist mit dem Spike-Protein. Die Sache ist, ich habe keinerlei Ahnung davon und das, was du da erzählst, klingt irgendwie logisch. Aber wenn du mir das Gegenteil erzählt hättest, dass da irgendeine Zelle geteilt wird und dadurch wirkt das so besonders toll oder so, dann hätte ich auch gesagt, ja interessant, warum? Weil ich dir vertraue. Ich vertraue auch generell meinem Arzt und vertraue auch dem Gesundheitsministerium nicht absolut. Also, dass ich jetzt sagen würde, ich mache alles, was die sagen. Ich habe ja auch noch irgendwie eigene Mechanismen. Aber dieses Vertrauen in die Institution und in einzelne Personen, das ist so da, dass ich nicht mehr überprüfe. Also, dass ich nicht mehr sage, nachdem du mir was vom Protein, vom Spike Protein erzählst, ich google das jetzt noch mal nach. Sondern das Vertrauen, da vertraue ich einfach blind, wie ich in der Werkstatt ein Auto abhole und sage, ja, da sagt der Kfz-Mechaniker, läuft wieder. Und dann vertraue ich dem. Und kann auch selber gar nicht, ich könnte es ja auch gar nicht überprüfen. Und deswegen ist das Vertrauen eine ganz entscheidende Kategorie, wenn man überhaupt Gesellschaft gestalten will. Denn sonst muss man sagen, wenn man nicht mehr in diese Dinge vertraut, dann müsste man alles selbst überprüfen, was man nicht leisten kann. Und das führt ja genau dazu, dass viele dann sagen, es ist alles gelogen. Am Ende gibt es den Klimawandel nicht. Und wir werden von ganz anderen regiert.
Genau. Und im nächsten Zuge kommt vielleicht die wichtigste Einflugsschneise der beiden, die sie auch immer wieder versucht haben, selbst bei Lanz darzustellen. Aber sie saßen leider Robin Alexander gegenüber, der noch mal diesen alten Klaus-Kleberspruch sagte, nein, die Kanzlerin ruft nicht bei mir morgens an und diktiert mir, was ich schreiben soll. Denn den beiden geht es ja genau um das Gegenteil. Das ist nämlich die Kanzlerin morgens, und das wussten wir, das ist sozusagen die Geschichte der 16-Jahre Angela Merkel, dass sie ihr Fähnchen in den Wind hängt, dass sie sich genau anschaut, wie der Sing-Sang in den Leitmedien gerade ist, dann versucht, das noch mal zu unterfüttern mit eigener Marktforschung, die das Kanzleramt gemacht hat, um dann, die finden natürlich krasse Worte, um dann sozusagen voreilend die eigene politischen Programme zu zensieren, um sie für ein von den Medien vorbereitetes Publikumsgespräch bereit zu machen. Was bedeutet da? Keine Überraschung führen, sondern folgen, was die Leitwölfe der Leitmedien gerade... Und dann kann man sich überlegen, moralisch hyperventilieren wäre das Angebot, was die beiden hier machen.
Bei Merkel gibt es ja diesen einen Vorfall. Sie wollte ja noch stärker den sozialen Karlschlag. Das war ja das, wo sie angetreten war. Dann wurde sie auf dem Parteitag damals, bevor sie Kanzlerin war, attackiert von den noch Sozialdenkenden in der CDU. Und es gab dann in der Presse auch heftige, heftige Angriffe. Und seitdem hat sich Angela Merkel geschworen, so sagen das ja viele Biografen und Experten auch des deutschen Konservatismus. Das mache ich nie wieder. Also ich exponiere mich nicht mehr und gucke dann, ob es klappt, sondern ich reagiere auf das, was medial und was gewünscht ist. Und das erklärt auch dann, warum wir zum Beispiel dann eine Kanzlerin haben, die sich von Fukushima verabschiedet, also von der Atomkraft verabschiedet, weil sie das in der Zeitung gelesen hat, das können wir jetzt nicht mehr machen. Und die Bevölkerung sagt, das können wir nicht mehr machen. Und dann noch der große Leitartikel erschienen ist, das können wir nicht mehr machen. Dann sagt sie, ja, ja, gut, dann hören wir damit mal auf.
Und da konnte sie auch darauf vertrauen, dass eine Woche nach dieser Verkündung Schirrmacher, einen großen Aufmacher im Föhton schreibt, mit der Pointe, zu Recht sind wir aus der Atomkraft ausgestiegen, denn man muss irgendwann einsehen, das war ein Fehler. Und da hat Angela Merkel sozusagen vorauseilend, ja, das ist ein Fehler gewesen, ich als Physikerin und so weiter, hat alle Stimmen ihr bei. Und dann hat man einen Tomaßstieg geschafft. Die beiden schreiben, das ist eine Tendenz. Denn wir haben eine Medienlogik, die, ja, die Medien haben die Politik kolonialisiert. Wir haben eine unheilvolle Tendenz der Medialisierung, mehr Skandale, weniger Hemmschwellen. Man kann einfach immer mehr kommunizieren, muss auch immer mehr kommunizieren durch den ökonomischen Druck. Sie beschreiben ja sehr schön, wie Medien entweder abhängig sind vom Hofe oder vom Markt. Eins von beiden. Aber sie sind, sie ruhen nicht in sich selbst. Sie sind keine Kunst, die einfach so im Raum steht, sondern es braucht Grundlage und Publikumsarbeit. Und Precht macht ja einen wirklich wahnsinnigen guten Vorschlag für den Begriff. Denn ich habe ja in Redaktionsschluss damals auch überlegt, was ist genau der Unterschied? Sie kommen jetzt hier so mit Direktmedien statt sozialer Medien, weil es sind ja keine sozialen, sondern halt direkte Medien und so. Ich habe mich damals entschieden, es gibt eben die institutionellen Medien und dann einfach die Internetmedien oder die redaktionellen Medien und das große private Kommunizieren. Und Precht verwendet hier das Wort amtierende Medien. Und zwar ohne große Aufhebens. Er schreibt einfach so zwischendrin ja die amtierenden Medien. Aber ich sage, selten hat ein Begriff, der sich finden ließ zu einer Argumentation, die abläuft am Anfang des Textes, so gut gepasst. Denn ja, es sind in seinem Sicht amtierende Medien. Sie übernehmen die eigentliche Rolle der Politik und treiben die institutionelle Politik vor sich her. Und damit ist dieser Punkt gemacht, dass es nicht darum geht, dass die Merkel oder der Scholz irgendwo anrufen und sagen, schreib mal das und das, sondern genau umgedreht. Die informieren sich in den Medien, was Sachlage ist, und handeln dann danach.
Und so werden dann die Leitmedien, Vollzugsorgane, ihre eigenen Meinungsmacher?
Genau.
So ist es dann.
Es ist in deren Sicht ein gelungener Texteinstieg, muss ich schon sagen, auch wenn ich mir da mehr akademische Tiefe gewünscht hätte.
Ich meine, das ist das große Manko, das muss man ganz klar sagen. Es gibt so viel Theorie dazu und es gibt so viel, was man hätte doch auch als Grundlage nehmen können für Medienkritik. Also ob das jetzt die Kritik am Fernsehen von Baudieu ist, ob das Frankfurter Schule ist oder Simulationstheorien von Baudrillard, wo die sagen, ja das findet alles, wo er sagt, das findet alles nur noch medial statt, das findet nicht mehr wirklich statt. Also eigentlich das, was da Robin Alexander beschreibt, tagtäglich diese Kämpfe in den Parteien und so, das sind reine mediale Kämpfe und Baudrillard würde wahrscheinlich sagen, die gibt es in dem Sinne gar nicht, oder die gibt es nur in den Medien und dass das nicht auf so eine Ebene gehoben wird und damit meine ich jetzt nicht, das soll so ein intellektuelles Buch sein, dass es die meisten wieder nicht verstehen, sondern dass man nicht damit eine andere Grundlage gleich schafft, dass man auf einer anderen Höhe diskutiert und dadurch passiert es dann auch in diesem Buch, dass immer wieder solche Dinge unterlaufen, die auch nicht in sich konsistenzen. Also wir haben das jetzt gerade hier ausgeführt, welche These wir da vorfinden, also die Leitmedien als Vorzugsorgane ihrer eigenen Meinungsmache und dass die Politik sich daran orientiert. Und dann haben wir aber zugleich als Beispiel wird dann Donald Trump gebracht. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, aber Donald Trump ist ja jemand, der gerade von den Leitmedien niedergeschrieben wurde. Also die wollten ihn ja mit einer konzertierten Aktion verhindern und trotzdem schafft es Donald Trump dann über seine Kanäle und über seine durch seinen Meinungspluralismus, also dass der sagt, dann setze ich Taka Carlson für mich ein und irgendwelche Verschwörungstheoretiker oder sonst was, völlig egal. Der schafft es ja dann Präsident zu werden. Also ist nicht gerade Trump ein Beispiel, das die These widerlegt von Wälzer und Precht?
Sehr guter Punkt, kann man aber glaube ich ganz gut erklären, denn den beiden geht es ja darum, dass die Medien, später im Öffentlichkeitskapitel schreiben sie ja ganz klar, es geht nur um eine Teilöffentlichkeit. Die verwechseln sich aber mit der Öffentlichkeit und am Anfang sagen sie ja, es ist die Diskrepanz zwischen öffentlicher Meinung, die ja abfragbar ist, wurde ja auch beim Ukrainekrieg, es ist eben 50-50, sollen wir jetzt Waffen liefern, ja oder nein? Während in der veröffentlichten Meinung, also redaktionell organisiert und dann auch publiziert, gesagt wird, natürlich müssen wir, also da ist es 90-10 und nicht 50-50. So und wir haben es also mit einer Verwechslung, oder wir können ja die Schlusspointe gleich aufgreifen, die Redaktionen geben heute die falsche Antwort auf die Frage, warum es sie eigentlich gibt. Das ist ja so die Schlusspointe. Wir haben es also mit einer Degenerierung des Mediensystems zu tun, dass seine eigentlichen Aufgabe nicht mehr nachkommt. Und mit dem Trump-Kapitel wollen sie ja nur darstellen, dass auf die Degeneration der Medien die Degeneration der Politik folgt. Dass wir also um die Demokratie selbst und sorgen müssen, wenn am Anfang schon die Medien nicht mehr richtig adäquat funktionieren. Und das ist ja ihr Urteil, funktioniert nicht richtig. Und da würde ich sagen, es ist eben austauschbar, wo wir in einem historischen Prozess dieser Degeneration stehen oder wie sie abläuft. Und ein Beispiel wäre zu sagen, naja, Donald Trump ist ja Präsident geworden gegen die veröffentlichte Meinung. Was stimmt, was eben bedeutet? Da haben sich die Direktmedien schon durchgesetzt. In Deutschland sind wir noch nicht so weit, aber eben auch auf diesem Track. So habe ich es gelesen. Dass durchaus die Gefahr besteht oder eben nicht oder anders, bei Precht ist ja ein bisschen unklar. Der behauptet ja immer, die AfD wird der Demokratie in Deutschland nie gefährlich. Die wird nie diesen Einfluss haben. Wir sind in Deutschland durch diese Verfassung, die wir aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg heraus geboren haben, eben so ein bisschen geschützt vor diesen Direkteinflüssen. Wir wählen den Bundeskanzler nicht einfach so wie ein brasilianer Präsident, der dann einfach alles über den Tisch wirft und den ganzen Tisch umwirft, sondern bei uns läuft die Degeneration eben anders ab. Aber Donald Trump ist ein Beispiel für das Degenerieren der Politik, nachdem vorher die Medien mit ihrer Funktionsweise und sagt er ja hier auch, die Rolle, Funktionsweise und das Selbstverständnis der Late-Medien hat sich deutlich verändert durch Migrationskrise, Corona und Krieg. Und in Amerika hat sich auch ganz schön viel verändert. Wir hatten ja eine andere Medienrealität bis zu den 80ern und dann kam eben Ronald Reagan und man hat nur noch Hollywoodstars gewählt und dann ist man angekommen, wo man angekommen ist. Und diese Gefahr, dass sich irgendwas dann grundlegend ändert, wenn sich die Late-Medien in der Funktionsweise grundlegend ändert, droht dann in Deutschland auch. Also auf inhaltlicher Ebene, finde ich, funktioniert es nicht, aber wenn man eine Funktionalanalyse, also sich die Strukturmerkmale anschaut, würde ich sagen, ja, in Amerika kann man sehr gut sehen, wie die Politik kompletto degeneriert, wenn das Mediensystem einmal degeneriert und zum Beispiel der Switch komplett auf Direktmedien übergeht und dann auch Politiker und ihr Publikum direkt miteinander kommunizieren und das Mediensystem dazwischen gar keine Funktion mehr hat. Also gar keine Anlaufstelle, gar keine Adresse mehr für irgendjemanden ist und man da auch im Grunde nur noch so eine Selbstbespaßung, wo Journalisten wirklich nur noch für Journalisten arbeiten. Und wir kennen ja die Einschaltquoten von CNN. Also da gucken ja nicht Millionen zu, sondern sehr, findet ihr ja, in diesem 600.000, also ob da noch, ja, da bespielt man halt das Washington DC irgendwie den größeren Politikbetrieb, aber ansonsten findet ja keine Publikumsirritation noch statt.
Lass mich noch eine kritische Frage stellen. Wir haben jetzt gesagt, nur weil die in den Medien stattfinden und jetzt immer wieder gesagt wird, ihr findet doch in den Medien statt, da könnt ihr doch kein Buch darüber schreiben, dass Meinungen in den Medien nicht stattfinden. Das haben wir jetzt mal ausgeklammert. Denn du sagst so recht, die sind Anwälte auch von anderen Leuten, die sich nicht so trauen. Und man kann ja auch noch mal hinzufügen, Precht und Welzer sind so prominent und haben eine solche Reichweite, dass sie natürlich viel mutiger sein können. Also sie haben ja nicht das Problem, sich in der Redaktionskonferenz nachher was anhören zu müssen. Die bekommen keinen Twitter-Shitstorm mit, weil sie gar nicht da sind. Die haben nicht da 1000 Follower und müssen Angst haben, wenn sie jetzt da irgendwas kritisieren. Das heißt, sie sind ja aus der Gleichung schon deshalb rausgenommen, weil sie einfach selbst extrem mächtig sind. Das sind ja so Ein-Personen-Medien. Und damit komme ich aber zu dem Punkt. Müsste man, wenn man diese extreme Stellung, exponierte Stellung in den Medien hat, wie die beiden sie haben, und wenn man sich ihre Karrieren anseht, der eine hat mit einem populären Philosophiebuch plötzlich, es geschafft, Bestseller-Autor zu werden, der andere ist eigentlich Soziologe über Krieg und Gewalt und schreibt dann über smarte digitale Welten, über Postwachstum und all das. Und dann sind sie plötzlich als Gesichter bekannt. Also sie sind Prominente, die, egal zu was sie sich äußern, immer einen großen Widerhall erfahren. Also sind sie nicht gewissermaßen Teil des Problems, das sie dort in diesem Buch beschreiben. Insofern, als sie typisch sind für diese Personalisierung, wo es nicht darum geht, wer hat das bessere Argument, sondern man sagt einfach, Precht kennen wir. Der hat ein Buch über Bildung geschrieben. Jetzt erzählt er was darüber, dass wir bald von den Robotern nur noch die Arbeit erwarten können und wir alle arbeitslos werden. Und weil er Precht ist und bekannt ist, hören wir uns das auch an.
Das machen sie ja ganz explizit. Die Bandbreite einer Problembehandlung ist ja, dass man sich irgendwo vororten muss zwischen, man macht so eine Promotion im Mittelbau der Universitäten und schreibt was über die Öffis, das niemand liest außer der Prüfer. Oder man kommt aus den öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien, heißt Peter Hane und schreibt dann ein Buch wie, das Maß ist voll. In Krisenzeiten hilft keine Volksverdummung. Irgendwo dazwischen muss man sich ja vororten. Und da sind sie ja ganz explizit und sagen sowohl, wir sind die Autoren und auch das sind unsere Adressaten. Also zu, wir sind die Autoren, Zitat, dabei werden viele unserer Analysen und Politik unter Politik, Kommunikations- und Medienwissenschaftlern kaum als Neuigkeit gelten. Soweit so richtig. Wirkungsvoll jenseits von Fachdiskursen, aber wird die Erkenntnis vielleicht dann werden, wenn die Kritik von Autoren kommt, die selbst vielfach in den Leitmedien präsent sind, sogar gelegentlich Teil des Problems.
Ja, aber da bleibt es dann dabei. Also ich bin auch die Transparentmachung gut und es gibt dann noch einmal das Wälzer sagt, ich habe da auch damals auf den Wolf drauf gekloppt und hätte das nicht tun sollen. Aber ich finde schon, dass man noch, wenn man diese exponierte Stellung hat, das immer wieder rückspiegeln müsste. Also auch wenn es um diese Einladungspolitiken in Talkshows geht. Es gibt ja, es kann ja nicht in Richard David Precht glauben, dass das eine erkenntnisinteresse geleitete Sendung wird, wenn er auf Frank Thelen bei Lanz trifft. Das ist ja einfach nur irgendeine Show. Das ist ja wie zu sagen, Elene Fischer singt mit Andrea Berg. Da geht es auch nicht um Erkenntnisinteresse. Da sind die jetzt mal zusammen gegen Duett. Und das muss aber doch mal dann von Leuten, die eine solche Prominenz haben und die genau davon ja leben, muss das doch anders dargestellt werden. Denn sonst bekommt man tatsächlich den Eindruck, dass hier welche sind, die sich nach den alten Prinzipien etablieren konnten, die brauchen keinen Twitter natürlich. Wozu auch? Die haben ja ihr Publikum, dass sie alles erreichen. Aber die dann jetzt auf die mit Verachtung blicken, die sich eine Reichweite über Twitter aufbauen müssen, über irgendwelche Sachen. Und Precht ist ja selbst jemand, der mit ganz vielen Thesen in die Öffentlichkeit geht, wie zum Beispiel der Kanzler Kurz in Österreich wird ewig bleiben. Der wird Jahrzehnte regieren. Und man denkt ja, was sind das für Aussagen? Das ist ja genauso wie eine Aussage wie von Robin Alexander, die dann übermorgen sich schon erledigt hat. Und da würde ich schon erwarten, dass die Autoren mehr auf sich eingehen und ihre Rolle. Und inwieweit diese Art der Personalisierung vielleicht auch etwas ist, was gar nicht hintergebe ist. Denn natürlich spielt auch das Gesichtspiel, Personen spielt Show eine Rolle in einer medialen Welt. Denn was ja immer mal wieder so rauskommt, ist ja früher, da gab es die Artikel, da war unten nur so ein Autorenkürzel, niemand wusste eigentlich genau, wer ist der Journalist. Aber da muss man sagen, ja, aber davon seid ihr ja auch weit entfernt, die Wissenschaftler zu sein, von denen man kein Gesicht im Kopf hat, sondern die man nur liest, weil man ein tolles Argument haben möchte.
Ja, also ich komme ja in Altenrepublik auch auf dieses FAZ-Ekonomen-Ranking zu sprechen. Das ja nach drei Dimensionen aufschlüsselt, nämlich mediale Präsenz, politischer Einfluss und eben akademische Leistung. So, und dann ist er auf Platz 1 Ernst Fähr, der einfach 500 akademische Leistungspunkte bekommt. Und auf Platz 2 bis 10 kommen dann Clemens Fuest, Michael Hüther, Claudia Kempfert und so weiter, die alle vielleicht gerade so zweistellige Leistungspunkte in der Akademie bekommen, also sehr viel weniger als Ernst Fähr. Und dafür aber richtig abräumen beim politischen Einfluss und so weiter. Und das ist eben, finde ich, so diese Gemengelage. Man kann nur in dem einen Feld oder in dem anderen, schon alleine haben wir bei Drosten gesehen, weil es auch super schwierig ist, akademisch überhaupt auf Augenhöhe zu bleiben, wenn dann so viel Neid über die publizistische, also wenn Reputation und Prominenz sich da so im Wege stehen. Und da muss man sich halt irgendwann entscheiden. Und ich finde, klar kann man jetzt immer sagen, die haben das zu wenig reflektiert, sie haben es zumindest einmal expliziert. Kommen wir dann sogar nach, Precht macht ja einen Kapitel über den Unmarked Space, also blinde Flecken und so weiter. Er verwendet das allerdings ein bisschen komisch, nämlich gar nicht in dieser Theorie-Tradition des Konstruktivismus, sondern dieses ganz Explizite. Also der Unmarked Space ist sozusagen bewusst gewählt, dem nämlich die Zeitredaktion einfach sagt, ach so, der Jochen Bittner arbeitet auch in diesen Think Tanks mit, wo man so eine transatlantische politische Position erarbeitet und stellt sich dann gleichzeitig als politischer Redakteur noch mal als, also die supertolle, diese Position, ohne zu markieren, wir haben die miterarbeitet. Das sind natürlich alles diese schwierigen Sachverhalte, wo man sagen muss, ja, das ist ein echtes Problem, aber dahinter haben wir ja eigentlich, wie du sagtest, noch mal ein echtes Unmarked Space Problem, dass auch die beiden Autoren immer mitreflektieren müssten, wie sie selber gerade stehen. Und ich würde sagen, vielleicht lösen wir das.
Und auch einfach nicht um sich selbst da zu kritisieren, also das ist jetzt gar nicht mein Punkt, sondern um eine mediale Logik zu verstehen. Also man wird nicht ein Fernsehen ohne Gesichter machen können. Und ich weiß ja zum Beispiel auch, weil ich ja auch meine Rolle reflektieren kann, dass ich natürlich auch irgendwo eingeladen werde, weil das als Typ dann funktioniert. Das ist ja nicht so, dass ich der einzige Mensch bin, der sagen kann, dass die Schuldenbremse weggehört. Da würde ja vielleicht noch jemand auf die Idee kommen, vielleicht sogar jemand, der Ökonomie studiert hat. Aber es hängt natürlich auch dann damit zusammen, dass man sagt, der macht das gut oder der sieht so aus, dass er ins Fernsehen gehört oder der kann auch in der Kamera gucken. Ich sage auch gar nicht, dass das schlimm ist. Nur ich glaube, dass man dann immer sagen muss, also auf der medialen Ebene geht es nie allein um Informationsgewinnung oder Meinungsaustausch, wie so eine deliberative Demokratie von Habermas sich das vorstellt. Sondern du machst das Argument ja selbst immer sehr stark. Es geht auch um Show. Und da, wenn man sich da selbst mit verortet, dann glaube ich, wird die Argumentation als Ganzes eine cleverere, als wir sie im Buch finden.
Ja, also es ist wahnsinnig schwierig, diese Reflektion immer zu explizieren. Und ich hätte auch gedacht, sie finden einen spielerischen Umgang, denn es gibt ganz praktische und pragmatische Herangehensweisen an dieses Problem, die dann auch wieder einen kleinen Show-Effekt sind. Dass man zum Beispiel anstelle Welzer und Precht am Ende von so einer 60-Minuten-Talk-Sache bei Lanz hätte sagen können, seht ihr, das, was hier die letzte Stunde ablief, was wir hier vorgeführt haben, ist genau das Problem. Das Personalisieren von, irgendwer hat irgendwas gesagt, also stellen wir nur die Person im Mittelpunkt.
Was hier aber alle gemacht haben.
Genau.
Also dieser Ausschnitt war ja dann, also ich hab ja nur bei Twitter so Clips gesehen, dass Precht ja auch dann so ganz merkwürdig personalisiert. Und man versteht nicht, warum sie nicht, also erst mal sind sie ja beide vollkommen, jetzt bin ich auch in der Personalisierung, wie du merkst, sie sind ja beide vollkommen humorlos und ironiefrei. Das kann ich ja immer nicht verstehen.
Das ist das Problem.
Warum sie nicht mit ein bisschen Spaß mal da reingehen und sagen, also Alexander, ich weiß ja, wir drehten ihnen auf den Schlips, jetzt machen sie das mal und jetzt wollen wir aber mal zum Beispiel darüber reden, wie sich der Anzeigenmarkt entwickelt hat. Und dann kommt man ja gleich auf eine ökonomische Ebene und was bedeutet das für Zeitungen oder so. Und das bieten aber beide nicht an. Und ich fand es eigentlich, ich habe wirklich nur wahrscheinlich zweieinhalb Minuten insgesamt von dieser Sache gesehen und habe dann nur so gelesen, was Leute darüber sagen. Ich finde es erstaunlich, dass man zwei Medienprofis hat, die sich aber zugleich so unprofessionell verhalten, dass sie in so einem Reaktionsmodus sind und dann auch irgendwann pampig werden und nicht selbst was mitbringen. Also man geht doch nicht in eine Sendung und sagt mal gucken, was jetzt auf mich zukommt, sondern man bringt doch auch selbst was mit, man bietet was an. Und ich würde sagen, mit Selbstreflexion, Ironie, würde man da gleich ganz anders drüber reden können.
Ja, sie haben große Chancen verpasst. Ich fand das dann auch sehr schade, denn sie reden ja im Buch darüber, dass die Leitmedien als eins der Probleme haben, dass sie nicht mehr repräsentieren, dass sie die Bevölkerung nicht mehr abbilden, integrieren und so weiter. Da hat er dann so einen schönen Sing-Sang, wo er nochmal die Vorzüge redaktioneller Medien darstellt, integrierend, weltoffen und so weiter. Da finde ich gleich nochmal meine Notizen. Das lohnt sich nochmal vorzutragen. Und da hätte er durchaus am Ende der Land-Sendung sagen können, Frau Ammann, wir alle sitzen hier nur als Schiffre. Ich auch. Ich habe im Buch am Anfang den Punkt gemacht, dass ein Viertel mehr, also die Zahl der Menschen, die den Medien nicht mehr vertrauen, die einfach zustimmen der Aussage, ich traue mich nicht mehr alles zu sagen, die hat sich verdoppelt. Und dann haben wir im Buch das Angebot gemacht, ein Buch für diejenigen zu schreiben, die sich zum einen verstanden fühlen im Publikum. Und da müssen sie sagen, das sind ganz schön viele, Frau Ammann, denn die Zahlen sind, wie sie sind. Das hier gerade nicht anwesende Publikum ist ganz schön auf unserer Seite. Das müssen sie einfach anerkennen. Und es ist die Frage, für wen schreibt man denn das Buch? Also nicht nur für die, die sich verstanden und aufgehoben fühlen, dass Autoren dann endlich mal sagen, was das eigentliche Problem ist angeblich, sondern, und das fand ich echt einen guten Move, dass sie nämlich sagen, dieses Buch ist für die Medien und über die Medien, die sich, Zitat, bei realistischer Selbstbetrachtung angesprochen fühlen. Und wenn man gesehen hat, wie Ammann und Alexander in dieser Sendung agierten, muss man sagen, die wurden dann nicht nur eingeladen, sondern die wurden auch von dem Buch angesprochen. Und die gehören also dazu. Dieses Buch handelt von ihnen, weil sie so reagierten, wie sie reagierten. Nicht weil Precht und Welzer geschrieben haben, was sie geschrieben haben, sondern weil die beiden darauf so reagierten, wie sie reagierten. Und diesen Punkt hätte man einfach mal machen müssen, dass die beiden eben nicht unbeteiligt als Beobachter eines, ja wir haben das Buch auch gelesen, jetzt reden wir mal drüber, nein, sie wurden über diesen Move, der nur im Buch explizit steht und in der Sendung leider nicht nochmal stattfand. Wurden sie Protagonisten der Beobachtung? Sie haben sich selbst dafür entschieden, hier Protagonisten zu sein und taten dann immer so, als stünden sie neutral daneben und würden einfach nur ein Buch kritisieren. Aber nee, sie wurden tatsächlich wie in so einem Tintenherzbuch einfach reingesogen in das Buch. Das ist so eine unendliche Geschichte, weil das Aufschlägen zu lesen als Journalist ist plötzlich Teil der Geschichte. Und für die natürlich dann in Lanz wird sie ja weitergeschrieben in so einer Lanz-Sendung. Und das hätte man durchaus mal ganz clever irgendwie noch mit einbauen können. Aber dafür waren die Fronten vielleicht auch schon so verhärtet. Es war ein bisschen schade, weil dadurch, dass die beiden eben diese Prominenz mitbringen und die anderen beiden, also Amman und Alexander, dieser Einladung nicht ausweichen konnten, wurden sie einfach importiert in die Geschichte, von der das Buch handelt. Und es kam leider zu wenig zur Geltung. Stattdessen, das, was ich vorhin schon kritisiert habe, als wurde auf der Sachebene, dass dann Alexander einfach sagt, ja, aber der Stefan Aust hat doch geschrieben das und so weiter. Und genau darum ging es ja leider nicht. Und da hätte ich Precht für wirklich ausgebuffter gehalten. Dass er diese Chance noch mal nutzt, hat er dann leider nicht getan.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist, dass sie diesen Modus, aber wir wollen jetzt nicht über die Talkshow zu viel reden. Aber ich glaube, sie sind den Modus des Widerspruchs nicht unbedingt gewöhnt, sondern oft werden die beiden ja einzeln eingeladen als Verkünder von irgendetwas. So sieht die neue Arbeit aus, dass wir die Postwachstumsgesellschaft, so könnte ein Leben mit bessere Bildung aussehen. Und dann ist man einfach da und verkündet. Und alle staunen, meine Güte, was der alles weiß. Und jetzt sind sie plötzlich in dem Modus, wo sie in einen Streit sich eigentlich hineinbegeben müssen. Und dann können sie nicht nur verkünden. Und das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was ihnen etwas schwerfällt. Und das ist erstaunlich, aber dass man wirklich so zwei Debatten jetzt parallel hat. Also einmal diese Talkshow-Auftritte. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir dieses Buch. Und das Buch ist definitiv besser als diese Clips, die ich gesehen habe. Das möchte ich hier ausdrücklich sagen. Und dennoch werden wir noch an Punkte kommen, wo ich sagen würde, da ist das nicht besonders clever. Und dafür würde ich mal gleich einsteigen, weil wir es hier mit jemandem im Podcast zu tun haben, der ja ein Buch über Medien geschrieben hat, nämlich Redaktionsschluss. Und du schreibst in diesem Buch, wie sich die Zeitungen verändern, wie sich Redaktionen plötzlich anpassen. Es gibt da eine Stelle. Ich habe sie nicht noch mal nachgelesen. Ich rekapituliere aus dem Gedächtnis, dass Schirmacher, also der Herausgeber der FAZ fürs Vöetent verantwortlich, sich wundert, warum Artikel, die im Vöetent in der gedruckten Ausgabe groß sind, die Aufmacher und deswegen auf Seite eins stehen, beim Online-Auftritt der FAZ irgendwo unter ferner liefern laufen, während andere, kleinere Dinge, die vielleicht auf Seite vier des Vöetent standen, plötzlich als erstes dastehen. Dass also die digitale Auswahl sich nicht mit der redaktionellen im Print deckt. Und dann ruft er, so schilderst du das, die Leute zu sich und sagt, was ist hier los? Und dann bekommt er gesagt, naja, gut, also diese Rezension des Streichquartetts oder diese Philosophiebuch-Rezension, die wollten nur 50 Leute anklicken, während hier die Meldung zu, weiß ich nicht was, hat tausende Klicks. Und plötzlich ist die Redaktion entmachtet durch die Daten, die man hat, nämlich die Leserdaten, die einem sagen, das wollen die aber sehen. Und das ist ja etwas, was du beschreibst. Und dann gibt es noch das Buch deines ehemaligen Kollegen Stadelmeier, also des Theaterkritikers, der in Umbruch beschreibt, was war das damals herrlich, als wir noch kein Debattenvöjeton hatten, also das, was Schirmacher eingeführt hat, als es noch so war, dass auf Seite eins, montags im Vöjeton in der FAZ ganz groß die Theaterbesprechung war und dann noch mal unten ein Streichquartett besprochen wurde, das irgendwo gespielt hat, und dann auf Seite zwei vielleicht noch eine Oper und dann irgendwann kam vielleicht noch eine kleine Meldung zu brauchen wir ein Einheitsdenkmal. Aber sonst war das debattenfrei und das war die schöne Zeit. Und ich finde, dass man anhand einer solchen Sache sehr gut erst einmal beschreiben kann, wie sich die Zeitung gewandelt hat und wie plötzlich der Leser mit zum Redakteur auch damit wird. Und ich finde aber, dass das sehr, sehr dünn drüber ist, wie wir hier sagen, wie sie diesen mediengeschichtlichen Abriss liefern. Sie gehen mal ein bisschen aufs 19. Jahrhundert, auf 20. Jahrhundert, dann auf Zeitungsteikune und so. Aber ich finde, dass das zum Beispiel nicht die Schärfe und Präzision deines Buchs erreicht. Oder auch anderer Darstellungen von Mediengeschichten.
Genau. Es ist, was diese Verortung angeht, ganz klar im Buch, das Migrationskrise Corona illustrativ aufgreift, um dann anhand des Krieges, der gerade läuft, also eigentlich zu nah dran. Sie konnten ja dann noch bei Landesumme nur sagen, die quantitative Auswertung unserer Akademisation kommt ja erst im Dezember und so. Da war die Frage, warum warten sie nicht so lange? Na, weil die Realität drückt. Das war dann so das Argument, deswegen musste das Buch jetzt sein. Und ja, sie gehen deswegen auch eben nicht immer diese Etage tief in, und das hätte man durchaus machen können, weil das Buch verkauft sich auch dann noch gut, wenn man nochmal 50 Seiten ergänzt und jedes Kapitel mit 5-10 Seiten akademischem Unterbau. Einfach so ein bisschen wirklich Theorie, dass man Vertrauen mal richtig beschreibt. Oder auch diese Historie, das Schweinebuch-Debakel, Groupthink, was so in Redaktionen dann stattfindet. Jeder Journalist weiß, dass man morgens in der Redaktionskonferenz, gerade in den großen Zeitungen, erstmal da sitzt und sich darüber verständigt, was man heute morgen im Deutschlandfunk gehört hat. Also da beginnt es dann schon, dass man beim Zähneputzen so ein kleines Interview mitnimmt und dann denkt, oh ja, dann prägt das jetzt Deutschland. Dann schreiben wir sozusagen die Zeitung und holt dann so ein bisschen die Radio-Realität ein. Und auch wenn nur wenig Leute Radio hören, Deutschlandfunk morgens, verfestigt sich das in den Redaktionen und ist dann am nächsten Morgen schon Morgenlage in den politischen Büros. Also all diese Wege hätte man durchaus mal langstreiten können. Da ist dann auch wieder die Frage, wenn Amman sagt, ja, hätten sie doch mal in den Redaktionen recherchiert. Ich würde sagen, nee, seid mal froh, dass sie es nicht gemacht haben. Denn dann wäre es vielleicht wirklich ein gefährliches Buch gewesen für euch, wenn da noch drinstehende, wie wirklich der redaktionelle Tagesablauf ist. Aber ich finde, sie gehen trotzdem für diesen Moment, in dem wir jetzt gerade sind. Also wir müssen jetzt durch diesen Winter zum Beispiel irgendwie durch. Da wird politische Diskussionen mit sich bringen. Dafür ist es dann doch ein Buch, das so für den Moment gut funktioniert. Ob es dann in fünf Jahren immer noch so ist, kann ja dahingestellt bleiben. Aber wie wir hier gerade Themen abräumen. Sie kommen ja so inhaltlich. Es gibt diese neue Kriegslust, auch die Lust auf einen zögerten Kanzler einzuschlagen. Wandel durch Annäherung wurde wirklich der Irrtum unserer Zeit plötzlich. Das sind ja alles ganz interessante Logiken, die wir haben. Und dann, das ist eigentlich mehr Leitartikel als Buch, aber Schuldstolz. Haben wir es mit einem Problem zu tun, das vielleicht wie folgt aussieht? Und da nehmen sie sich direkt drauf in Alexander. Das finde ich auch ziemlich gut in dem Fall, weil das dann nicht nur Schiffre, sondern wirklich mal plakativ ist. Er ist der Posterboy für folgende Problemlage. Wir haben redaktionelle politische Journalisten, die über Jahre Angela Merkel ganz toll finden. So dass George Packer irgendwie herkommt und sagt, also die deutschen Journalisten drehen ja alle im Rat. Erstens, die würden alle Merkel wählen. Zweitens, die verlieren kein schlechtes Wort über sie. Und drittens, sie feiern die ganze Zeit öffentlich, dass sie jemanden wie Merkel haben. Also ich habe schon ein Denkmal gebaut, als sie gerade in der Mitte ihrer Kanzlerschaft war. Und es war auch allen klar, die bleibt noch zehn Jahre und so. Anders als in Amerika, wo man jeden Präsidenten erstmal abschießt und weiß, oh, in zwei Jahren ist Midterms, wir munitionieren uns schon mal auf. Nichts davon hat George Packer in Deutschland gesehen. Dann nach 16 Jahren Merkel stellt man plötzlich fest, hm, da war ganz schön viel Scheiße, die wir gar nicht ordentlich betrachtet haben. Ich fühle mich irgendwie schuldig. Ich scheine damit ein Schuldproblem zu haben. Also ich bin so mit Schuld an der Sachlage, dass wir uns diese russische Abhängigkeit gebracht haben. Und dann stellt man fest, wie gehe ich mir dieser Schuldscham um? Ah, ich mache eine Fremdscham draus. Ja, ich strapaziere noch meinen eigenen Schuldstolz, in den ich denjenigen, die dieses Gefühl nicht mit mir teilen, besonders krasse Vorwürfe machen. Denn jetzt muss man ja wirklich mal umdenken. Selbst ich, der große Robin Alexander, habe krass umgedacht. Du musst es jetzt auch. Und umso mehr ich das dir zum Vorwurf mache, dass du noch nicht mit umgedacht hast, umso mehr entlaste ich mich von meiner eigenen Selbstscham. So, und das mündet in dieser Olaf Scholz, verhält sich total falsch. Der hat es noch nicht ganz begriffen. Wir müssen jetzt uns aus dieser Abhängigkeit Russlands befreien, indem wir sie einfach webbongen. Wo sind die schweren Waffen, die die Zeitenwende wirklich untermauern? Die Rede hat ja gar nicht richtig funktioniert. Seitdem geht ja auch die öffentliche Meinung und sein Ansinnen total unten durch. Ich erkläre warum. Er hat seine eigene Rede nicht wirklich. Er muss genau den gleichen Schulzstolz fühlen wie wir auch. Er war ja immerhin beteiligt an der Regierung. Und da muss ich sagen, okay, das ist jetzt vielleicht kein mega akademisches oder überhaupt nur unterfütterbares Argument. Aber als Erklärungsfolie für das, was wir gerade erleben in den Reaktionen, ist es einfach wunderbar, so was zu lesen.
Wir können das Wort uns schon mal merken, Schulzstolz. Das wird in sechs, sieben Jahren werden wir das wieder aufgreifen. In den 29ern, dann wird Schulzstolz zelebriert in Bezug auf Saudi-Arabien oder Aserbaidschan. Das kann ich hier schon mal prophezeien. Das wird dann so sein. Und dann muss jeder sagen, dass man nie mehr mit der Familie Aliyev auch nur einen Ton reden wird. Und das muss auch dann jeder Sozialdemokrat oder wie auch immer gerade dann öffentlich verkünden. Das ist auch was, was Kipersbusch angesprochen hat in dem Podcast, wo er sagte, man muss jetzt als Politiker durch diesen brennenden Reifen springen und sagen, ich will, dass die Ukraine jetzt den Krieg gewinnt. Und wenn man die, man muss den Satz auch genau so sagen, der wird jetzt abverlangt. Wir können ja mal gerade eine Passage da lesen. Es heißt dann wirklich, suffliert wurde das Schuldstolz-Thema von politischen Journalisten wie dem stellvertretenden Weltchefredakteur Robin Alexander, der als Talkshow-Gast fortan jeden Sozialdemokraten mit scharfen Fragen zur blauäugigen ostpolitischen Vergangenheit konfrontierte und von inquisitorisch fragenden Talkmastern immer auf der dringenden Suche nach der scheinbar geheimen Antwort auf die Frage, wie man sich in Putin nur so hatte täuschen können. Die Leitmedien zogen aus, suchten und erkannten überall Schuldige und entlarvten dabei vorwiegend Sozialdemokraten als lebensgefährliche Illusionisten. Sogar der Bundespräsident, der formal höchste Hamstträger im Staat, wurde zum Schuldeingeständnis genötigt, die ehemaligen Bundeskanzlerinnen Gerhard Schröder und Angela Merkel sollten ebenfalls bekennen, verweigerten das aber. Dies alles vor dem Hintergrund, das im Detail nicht immer wirklich klar war, welche ganz konkreten Handlungen der Vorgängerregierungen nun diese Exkommunikation verdienten und ein öffentliches Schuldgelöbnis erforderten. Und damit kommt man dann zu einer, wie sie sagen, hegemonialen neuen Erzählung. Und da würde ich auch noch mal einhaken, da hätte man noch mal bei Gramsci über Hegemonie und so doch ein paar Sätze verlieren können. Was ist eigentlich hegemonial? Denn das sollen wir noch mal hier ganz deutlich herausstreichen. Das machen sie auch am Anfang. Übrigens, der erste Satz enthält ja einen Fehler. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie sowas passieren kann. Es fehlt einfach mal ein Wort in dem Buch. Aber sie sagen ja, Deutschland gehört zu den freiesten Ländern der Welt. Und es kann das alles gesagt werden. Aber worum es ihnen hier geht, ist das, was hegemonial wird. Also diese dominanten, medialen Narrative, von denen auch Körpersbusch gesprochen wird, diese kritisieren sie. Sie sagen nicht, wir leben in einer Meinungsdiktatur. Wenn man etwas Falsches sagt, wird man abgeführt oder wird bestraft oder irgendetwas. Das ist nicht der Fall. Man kann natürlich alles sagen, aber was findet hegemonial im Diskurs statt? Und das ist dann zum Beispiel dieses Schuldstolztheater.
Genau, und wir haben ein Zitat Massenfremdschäden der Besserwisser im Nachhinein, die eben dazu führt, dass wir eine totale Narrativüberladung der gegenwärtigen politischen und sindsdennpolitischen, ich sage ja ausdrücklich, nee, Krieg ist erstmal mal nicht Politik mit anderen Mitteln. Hört mal auf, genauso zu denken. Und ich finde es sehr mutig, dass Welzer doch ganz explizit einfach mal durchgeht. Der Systemstreit, der gerade angeblich läuft, also das System der Russen, gegen das wir ankämpfen, diese Putin-Boshaftigkeit, die Ukraine-Heroisierung und so weiter. Er traut sich einfach mal zu, das jetzt mal ganz explizit zu machen, denn da ist man einfach zu einhellig. Der Hegemon, der da so im Raume steht, inhaltlich ist einfach zu ein zu fantastisches Bild, als dass wir dem jetzt einfach folgen sollten. Und man möchte einfach jetzt auf der ungetrübt guten Seite der Geschichte stehen. Und das finde ich ist die richtige Nuanzierung. Denn die richtige Seite der Geschichte, da gibt es glaube ich kein Zweifel so ein bisschen. Wir haben uns aus Gründen für Demokratie entschieden und in Russland ist gerade keine Demokratie. Aber dieses ungetrübt Gute. Wir wollen nicht nur auf der richtigen Seite der Geschichte, sondern es muss die absolut richtige, in jeder Nuance verteidigbare, richtige Seite der Geschichte sein. Und da verfangen sie sich eben in ihrem Extremismus, in ihrem Narrativ Extremismus. Und da hätte ich auch gesagt, es bietet sich eigentlich an, damit auch ein bisschen humorvoller umzugehen, weil es so fantastisch und absurd ist, was wir da gerade dargelegt bekommen insgesamt. Angefangen bei dieser Verherrlichung schwerer Waffen oder leichter Waffen der Grünen Partei. Das verstehen wir ja gar nicht. Das ist eine Partei aus der Friedensbewegung und so weiter. Ein so historisches Ereignis trotz aller Geschichte mit Joschka Fischer und nie wieder aus Schwitzen und so was. Und dieser Europäische Krieg damals erleben wir das gerade, wie wir es erleben. Und das ist wirklich erstaunlich, weil auch daher das Argument geht, wie konnten denn die Grünen so krass dazu getrieben werden? Näher durch ein mediales Narrativ. Also auch da ursprünglich sind es wieder die Kräfte, die wir nicht verstehen in den Redaktionen.
Und da würde ich ja genau noch mal einschalten mit einer kritischen Nachfrage. Also ich glaube auch, dass die Dominanz des Journalismus stark ist. Aber wir haben zum Gleiche das ganz große andere Narrativ. Die Politiker werden ihre eigenen Sender. Die müssen gar nicht mehr so stark medial kommunizieren. Früher war es ja tatsächlich so, wenn man irgendwas machen wollte und die Bevölkerung sollte davon erfahren, dann ging das nur über die Medien. Das heißt, haben die nicht berichtet, hat es nicht stattgefunden. Heute können die Politiker mit ihren großen, reichweitenstarken Profilen die Themen ja auch setzen. Und da ist doch für mich die Frage, inwieweit diese These so stimmt. Und wenn wir jetzt gerade zum Beispiel die grüne, neue Außenpolitik ansehen und uns ansehen, wie sehr jetzt grüne Führwaffen sind, dann ist das sicherlich auch eine Reaktion auf die mediale Eintönigkeit, die da überall zu vernehmen ist. Aber zugleich haben wir ja auch Politiker, die sich reichweitenstark mit solchen Äußerungen hervortun, die, glaube ich, jetzt nicht erst da die Medien zu brauchen, sondern die dann selbst wiederum fast zu kleine Medien werden, bis hin zu auch Thinktanks, wie jetzt dieses Institut der Liberale Moderne von Marie-Louise Beck und Ralf Füchse, die dann staatlich zum Teil finanziert werden, sich dann noch im Bundesverdienstkreuz umhängen und sagen, wir machen hier mal Aufklärungen in Sachen Außenpolitik. Und da frage ich mich ja, also müsste man, also inwieweit wir, es ist ja sehr einseitig zu sagen, die Politik reagiert auf Medien und nicht mehr andersrum, aber inwieweit stimmt das, wo wir so viele Politiker haben, die selbst Sender geworden sind? Und es geht ja dann so weit auch, also wir haben ja auch ganz andere Szenen. Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel nicht nur die Getriebenen, sondern wir haben auch eine ProSieben-Sendung, bei der Annalena Baerbock interviewt wird und die Moderatoren fangen danach an zu klatschen und spenden ihr Applaus. Oder ich hatte ja diese Clips da von hinten, na wer wird dann Fußballweltmeister? Und ach schön, ist alles okay für sie. Das haben wir ja auch medial. Also eigentlich Journalisten, die sagen, oh ich mach mal einen Knicks, da kommt die Außenministerin.
Ja, also wir haben sehr medial erfolgreiche Politiker, wenn die Medien ihren Teil dazu tun. Diesen Ausspruch von Olaf Scholz letztens im Bundestag, diese ganze nicht auf Augenhöhe der Zeitschein mit den erneuerbaren Energien, das waren sie. Das war ja ein wahnsinnig viraler, man kam ja gar nicht drum herum, weil er eben in allen Medien so transportiert wurde. Olaf Scholz von sich heraus, wir haben ihn in den Wahlkampf damals beobachtet, er hat diese stundenlange Interviews gemacht, diese Tour durch Deutschland, wo er entweder physisch vor Ort oder Corona-bedingt nur zugeschaltet war.
Und du bist ja der einzige nach wie vor, der die gesehen hat online, ne?
Genau, also da war ja wirklich YouTube 17 Views mit Nils Annen über Außenpolitik reden und so. Oder auch das Triel. Noch bevor die Medien so ein großes, das erste Triel und so weiter, saßen Baerbock, Laschet und …Schollz.
Der Kanzler.
Die saßen ja schon bei Wolfgang Ischinger und haben Triel-Dingsda-Bums zum Thema Sicherheitspolitik, also Außenpolitik gemacht. Das hat niemanden interessiert in Deutschland. Wir vergessen das immer so schnell, dass die Politiker von sich aus gar nichts schaffen. Außenpolitik auch in den Medien. Die sind ja selber überrascht. Seit der Zwei-Politik liest niemand Berichte über die Ukraine, wer hätte denn das gelesen? Nein, es ist der Krieg selbst, den wir jetzt so krass ausblenden, was sie ja auch immer wieder betonen. Wir kommen ja auch auf Alexander Kluge zu sprechen, der dann mal sagt, ne, das ist auch der Krieg selbst, der die Kräuel mitbringt. Das ist nicht der Putin, das befiehlt ist es auch. Aber es ist vor allem der Krieg selbst, dass wir den Krieg selbst als großer Attraktor eines Themas einfach ausblenden.
Ja, hier nochmal ganz klar, im Westen nichts Neues. Also da kann man genau sehen, was Alexander Kluge so beschreibt. Also was auch Kräuel meint, dass dann am Ende gesagt wird, wir müssen noch mal ran und dann muss am Ende als Waffe auch noch der Klapspaten dienen und was das dann bedeutet.
Also auch wenn es für uns anders aussieht, Annalena Werbock, große YouTube-Starin oder Instagram-Account, oder was auch immer, mit Gnade der redaktionellen Medien, die haben diese Kraft von sich aus?
Außer bei den den Rechten, also AfD ist natürlich ein Ausnahmefall, weil diese Art der medialen Repräsentanz nicht so da ist, beziehungsweise, also zwar kommt die AfD laufend vor, aber es ist nicht im Sinne von hurra, wir haben sie zu Gast, wie schön und wir werden sie freundlich wandeln und deswegen müssen die jetzt sich eigene Kanäle errichten, wo sie nur nette Fragen und sowas gestellt bekommen und deswegen ist dann auch ist kein Zufall, dass die AfD bei YouTube viel früher ganz populär war und nach wie vor populärer ist als alle anderen Parteien zusammengenommen, glaube ich sogar, bei Facebook kann man ähnliches sagen und TikTok ist wieder dasselbe Phänomen. Also wir haben da diese reichweitenstarken Alis Weidel Videos, die noch nicht mal zum Teil von ihr selbst noch hochgeladen werden oder gar nicht, sondern irgendwelche User machen das und es geht viral.
Genau und da sieht man schon, da greift dann auch wieder das Trump-Argument. Sogar in Deutschland steht diese Gefahr im Raume. Du hast ja diesen einen Clip, da haben sich dann auch gleich wieder die Lehrer gemeldet und wollten diesen Clip mal haben von mir, um das auch im Unterricht mal kurz zu thematisieren. So, kennt ihr diesen Clip? Was sollte man dazu sagen? Und die beiden, und das ist eben ein ganz wichtiges Argument, sagen eben, die Medien moderieren nicht mehr, sondern sie schlagen sich auf eine Seite, die Zitat, vierte Gewalt hat keinen Verfassungsrang, aber sie regiert mit. Und das würde ich ganz ernst nehmen. Robin Alexander fühlt sich als Teil des politischen Systems und er agiert auch ganz offen so. Politik heißt nicht nur entscheiden, sondern auch Entscheidungen herbeiführen, Alternativen hinlegen, Beschlussvorlagen erarbeiten und da ist er Teil davon. Müssen wir rein funktional sehen und er sieht sich auch als Teil davon. Also seine Selbstbeschreibung in privaten Raume. Klar, er kriegt diese Anrufe, da findet das und das statt und dann fühlt er sich beauftragt, daran teilzunehmen, wenn politische Prozesse ablaufen. Und in der Hinsicht ist dieses zwar ganz amüsant mit diesem Würstchenstand und im Bundestag und so weiter, aber ja, die Debatte läuft noch, während er selbst die Öffentlichkeit damit bespielt und die Politiker wissen, dass es ja von der Öffentlichkeit abhängt, denn am Ende ist das der Zugang zu dem Publikum und der wird ganz hart geregelt über diese Medien.
Gerhard Stadelmeier, weil wir ihn heute schonmal erwähnt haben, wollen wir es nochmal tun, der Theaterkritiker der FAZ war in seiner ganzen Laufbahn niemals bei einer Premierenparty. Er hat dann sogar gesagt, er musste mal irgendwann dann, da war er glaube ich schon pensioniert, eine Regisseurin ehren und er wusste gar nicht, wie sie aussieht. Also er wusste gar nicht, wer das dann eigentlich ist, weil er die ja nie so privat gesehen hat. Also so und das finde ich so erstaunlich, dass man also da sagt, ich mache eine absolute Trennung, ich betrachte nur das Werk, rede darüber, aber ich habe keinerlei Seilschaften und sagen, ja, müssen wir mal ein bisschen gucken, dass wir hier den Intendanten in Frankfurt halten oder absägen. Es ist vollkommen voneinander getrennt und das ist aber etwas, was bei sehr vielen Hauptstadtjournalisten nicht der Fall ist, weil das auch gerade das Attraktive ist, denn ich würde auch nochmal betonen, die meisten Journalisten verdienen ja jetzt nicht übermäßig viel Geld, haben aber mit dieser Nähe zum Macht natürlich den Eindruck, dass sie auch eigentlich zu dieser ökonomischen Blase gehören und das ist auch eine falsche Selbstbeannehmung dann oft bei den Journalisten.
Stadelmeier kann ich eine Anekdote noch einflächten, hat damals von der Redaktion einen Auftrag bekommen, sie sind doch gerade in der Stadt, können sie mal den und den interviewen und seine einzelne Antwort war, ich interviewe niemanden, ich führe keine Interviews. Das war die Antwort der Redaktion, damit war das Ding gegessen. Ich rede nicht mit Leuten, ich gucke mir nur Sachen an, die sie machen. Das Werk steht im Mittelpunkt. Sie haben hier ein sehr gutes Kapitel über die Öffentlichkeit, finde ich. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie verspielt es ist, aber Precht ist der Meinung, wenn viele frei über das Gleiche reden, reden wir von Öffentlichkeit. Das finde ich irgendwie sympathisch, warum nicht? Habermas Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit erschien damals zu einer Zeit, eines damals noch nicht, also es war halt die Promotion, wie viel Renommee kann man vorher schon haben, aber hat halt eingeschlagen, war ein Text, der dem Mediensystem der Adenauer Zeit kritisch gegenüber stand, weil die Journalisten noch nicht so genau wussten, wie geht man jetzt in dieser Nachkriegszeit damit um. Also hat er die historisch-soziologischen Grundlagen gelegt und damit Hilfe zur Selbstständigkeit gegeben. Da würde ich sagen, okay, rückblickend betrachtet, ja, das kann man so labeln für heute im Sinne von, dass die beiden der Meinung sind, werdet doch mal wieder selbstständiger. Also schafft euch Distanz zur Politik, damit ihr mehr Nähe wieder zum Publikum erringt. Und ganz wichtig ist hier aber, dass wir es mit einer deliberativen Öffentlichkeit zu tun haben, in der die redaktionellen Medien nur ein Teil der Öffentlichkeit sind und nicht die Öffentlichkeit selbst. Also diese große, am Anfang, wo man sich denkt, ja, das kennt man so aus diesen rechten Diskursen, die öffentliche Meinung und die veröffentlichte Meinung, also diese gemachte, fabrizierte Fake-Meinung, die so gemacht wird von den rechtlichen Medien. Nein, das ist Grundbedingung des öffentlichen Daseins, dass wir neben der veröffentlichten Meinung auch noch eine Privatmeinung vielleicht sogar haben. Und wenn wir sie öffentlich äußern, dann noch nicht gleich eine veröffentlichte, sondern einfach eine öffentlich vorgetragene Meinung, was über Direktmedien heute natürlich eine größere Rolle noch spielt. Was eben auch die redaktionellen Medien immer in einen Reflektions- und Kontrollzusammenhang zwingt, den er gerade vermisst. Sie beobachten sich nicht mehr von außen, sondern die vierte Gewalt pervertiert kontrolllos dahin. Lehre des 20. Jahrhunderts. Die vierte Gewalt will sie sich nicht pervertieren, bedarf mindestens ebenso sehr der Kontrolle, wie sie ihrerseits die Kontrolle der anderen drei Gewalten für sich beansprucht. Die Gefährdung der Öffentlichkeit steht potenziell von allen Gewalten aus, auch von der vierten. Also wenn die Journalisten meinen, wir müssen jetzt mal ganz kritisch mit den Politikern umgehen, weil ansonsten gefährden die den Fortgang der Gesellschaft, dann sagen die beiden, wir als Öffentlichkeit sollten auch mal ganz kritisch mit den redaktionellen Medien umgehen, ansonsten gefährden sie nämlich den Fortgang unserer Gemeinsamkeit. Und das ist auf den Punkt so gut formuliert. Plus, sie ergänzen, die Öffis haben die Rundfunkräte und sind damit schon ziemlich nah dran an so einem formal idealtypischen, so könnte Kontrolle der Medien aussehen. Und es ist ein bisschen verrückt, dass dann Stefan Niggemeier auf Twitter so hart schießt gegen Precht, während er selbst über Medien, genau aus diesem Grund, wir sollten das mal kritisch beobachten, aber er ist ja mit der Kritik nicht einverstanden.
Obwohl er ja tatsächlich mit vielen Passagen des Buchs doch absolut d'accord gehen müsste. Also es geht ja zum Beispiel auch darum, dass sich dann aus diesem Gefühl heraus, man kann nicht mehr alles sagen, wieder neue Geschäftsmodelle entwickeln. Und da gehen sie ja beispielsweise auf BildTV Weltkulumnen ein oder die NZZ-Redaktion in Berlin, die jetzt so die Anti-Haltung zur Bundesregierung als Geschäftsmodell für sich entdeckt hat. Und das ist ja etwas, was man bei Übermedien regelmäßig lesen kann. Also da sind sie ja gerade zu Deckungsgleich in ihrem Urteil, würde ich sagen.
Ja, vor allem ich habe selber noch mal einen Redaktionsschluss nachgelesen, was Nigel Mayer mir damals als Gesprächspartner so sagte. Und unter anderem, ja, morgens als erstes mache ich den Laptop auf, lese nach, was so passiert und dann sagt er ganz ausdrücklich, die deutschen Medien beobachte ich nur noch, weil mich Fehler interessieren, die sie machen. Wenn ich was über die Welt erfahren will, lese ich Economist oder New York Times. Und das 2015 mir gesagt. Da muss man sagen, also dieses Problem hat sich jetzt auf jeden Fall strapaziert. Was haben wir für Probleme, hier im Salon Texte in deutscher Sprache zu finden? Da muss man dann schon Blätter und so weiter, weil Süddeutsche und FAZ nichts bieten, was man irgendwie mal so einflächten müsste, hat über den Monat hinaus Relevanz. Sondern wir haben eben dieses Medienteater, was halt so durchgeprügelt wird, irgendwelche Kommentare, Leitartikel und so weiter, daran mangelt es nicht, aber an Substanz mangelt es schon. Und das ist auch Niggemeiers Diagnose damals gewesen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass er sie heute revidieren würde. Also dass wir es irgendwie mit einem super funktionierenden, eigenständigen, selbstständigen und auch sich selbst kontrollierenden Mediensystem haben, das irgendwelche tollen Sachen nach vorne bringt. Die beiden kommen ja auf René Marčić zu sprechen, der dieses, die Leitmedien sind nur Teil der Öffentlichkeit, die sich gerade mal aufmacht, was eben bedeutet, irgendwer muss kontrollieren. Die Medien können genauso, wenn sie über Politik reden, auch über die politische Öffentlichkeit reden, ohne sich selbst zu meinen, also das Publikum, die Wählerschaft, einfach in Bezug setzen zu Realität. Und dann hat er diesen schönen Zitat, deliberativ, inklusiv, integrierend, vermittelnd, bürgernah, pluralistisch, demokratief fördernd. Dieses schwere Mobile-Lar, das Marčić damals in den Raum stellte, das sollten die redaktionellen Medien mal wieder für sich aufgreifen. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist mal so ein klarer normativer Appell, wo ich sagen würde, das stimmt. Also warum schreibt man nicht statt irgendwie, man machen uns mit keiner Sache gemein, auch nicht mit einer guten, warum schreibt man nicht einfach diese Adjektive mal oben an die Eingangspforte der Redaktion und sagt, prüft euch doch mal darauf. Ist das jetzt inklusiv, integrierend und vermittelnd, was wir hier gerade schreiben, oder wollen wir noch mal die Proante machen, die wir gestern schon gelesen haben? Und da würde man dann auch viele Texte wahrscheinlich anders schreiben.
Nur frage ich mich, kann man das Ganze als so eine Verfallsgeschichte erzählen, wenn man sogleich so viele Beispiele aus der Vergangenheit auch anbringt, wo das ähnlich verlaufen ist? Also es gibt ja zum Beispiel diesen Hearst, also diesen Medientaikun, der ja Vorbild war für den berühmten Film Citizen Kane. Und da heißt es dann, so versammelten die US-Amerikaner Joseph Pulitzer und William Hearst zu dieser Zeit. Also wir sind jetzt hier Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts, Anfang 20. Jahrhundert. Zu dieser Zeit eine zuvor beispiellose Zeitungsmacht um sich. Gemeinsam trieben sie die USA 1898 in den viermonatigen Krieg gegen Spanien und steigerten dabei ihre Auflagen in Millionenhöhe. Besonders Hearsts Vorgehen liest sich bis heute wie eine Regieanweisung für publizistischen Machtmissbrauch. Die rätselhafte Explosion des US-Kriegsschiffs Maine vor Cuba wurde von ihm kurzerhand zur Missetat der Spanier erklärt, obwohl die Umstände unklar waren. Und als Hearsts Reporter auf Cuba keine Belege für Kreueltaten der Spanier fand, wies ihn Hearsts an. Sie besorgen die Bilder, ich sorge für den Krieg. Dem einen oder anderen Leser heute bekannt als Ausspruch des Medienmoguls Elliott Carver in James Bond-Streifen, der morgen stirbt, nie. Wir reden jetzt die ganze Zeit über diese Konzentration, aber ich will es noch mal machen. Ja, du hast es jetzt eben mit Trump uns gesagt, das ist das Resultat dadurch, dass die Light-Medien dann nicht mehr so funktioniert haben. Aber können wir nicht auch eine Erfolgsgeschichte erzählen? Ich bin jemand, der durch Twitter klüger wird. Und es gibt ja diesen Satz, du hast ihn auch schon häufiger zitiert, ich weiß nicht, von wem er stammt, Fernsehen macht dumme Leute dümmer und kluge Leute klüger. Und bei Twitter würde ich sagen, gilt das auch. Und können wir nicht auch die Erfolgsgeschichte einer Pluralisierung erzählen, dass wir nicht mehr drei Medientaikune haben, dass wir auch nicht mehr es haben, dass eine Springerpresse es schafft, einen Friedrich Merz anfangs zum Vorsitzenden zu machen. Nachher ist das dann geworden, das lag aber dann bei der Union. Und es war nicht die ursprüngliche Wahl, war ja die zwischen AKK und Merz. Und da hatte ja AKK gewonnen, obwohl die Springerpresse ganz eindeutig sich auf Merz eingeschossen hatte, bzw. ihn protegiert hatte. Ist es nicht auch so eine gewisse Erzählung, die Habermas ja oft tut, jetzt wenn ich das sehe mit diesen wüsten Geräuschen, da möchte ich doch lieber wieder die alten Massenmedien zurück. Sind nicht die Podcasts ein großes Beispiel für eine Vertiefung im Diskurs? Jetzt kann man sagen, das ist noch Nische, aber wir sprechen ja sonst nicht über Zahlen, aber wir erreichen ja mit dem neuen 20er Podcast pro Folge 70.000, 80.000 Menschen. Das ist ja keine Nische mehr nur. Und kann man nicht sagen, dass gerade da, durch die vielen Blogs, durch das, was man finden kann, viel mehr Pluralität möglich ist, viel mehr Vertiefung. Das trifft dann nicht auf die ganz großen Massenmedialen Sachen zu, beziehungsweise auf das massenmediale Publikum. Aber eigentlich müsste man doch auch hier die ganze Zeit auch durchlaufen lassen, aber es gibt das andere. Also muss ich darauf warten, dass Robin Alexander mir mehr Pluralität bringt? Oder kann ich nicht zugleich sagen, na die Pluralität gibt es doch, du brauchst ja nicht Robin Alexander lesen.
Also in diesem Kapitel über Öffentlichkeit, wo sie darstellen, dass was Robin Alexander bespielt, nämlich Bundesliga-Politik, ist so ein Angebot unter vielen. Hätte man strapazieren müssen, in der Hinsicht, das ist auch schon wieder so ein Redaktionsschluss-Thema von damals, dass man sich von diesem, die singuläre Öffentlichkeit einfach verabschiedet. Das ist ja auch eins der Phänomene, die du jetzt nochmal bespielt hast über diese Influencer, dass man irgendwo jemanden einlädt und dann heißt es, oder wie dich im Presseclub, wir waren ja beide anwesend, als du ein sehr illustres Gespräch darüber führtest und dir gesagt wurde, sie sind ja sehr populär bei den jungen Leuten. Und diejenigen, die das feststellen, sagen, aber ich kenne sie nicht. Man nennt irgendwelche Influencer ein und stellt fest, krass, wir haben zu kleinen Saal gebucht, wir wussten gar nicht, wie populär der ist. Also dass man gar kein Gefühl mehr dafür hat für die sparten Öffentlichkeiten, die es ansonsten noch so gibt. Die ganze Gamers-Szene ist ja immer eine, die da immer wieder wahnsinnig überrascht. Zehnmal so groß wie Hollywood und so und schlägt sich auch wirklich nieder in Leuten auf der Straße, wenn man mal was anbraumt. Alle sind immer wieder überrascht und sagen aber gleichzeitig, ist zwar ganz schön groß, also viel Reichweite, aber wenig Relevanz. Und dann versucht man irgendwo so einen Mittelweg zu finden und dann sagt man einfach, ja, die Bundespolitik lesen nicht 80 Millionen Menschen, sondern nur so 5 Millionen Menschen, aber super relevant. Also haben wir so einen Quotienten irgendwie, der sagt, das ist es jetzt, das ist die Öffentlichkeit. Und da würde ich sagen, ne, wir müssen uns davon wirklich ganz radikal verabschieden. Und das würde für Redaktionen bedeuten. Wir nehmen jetzt nicht unsere Zeitung, die wir bisher teuer verkauft haben, und geben sie im Internet kostenlos raus, weil in der Relevanz Reichweiten-Quotienten-Rechnung dann Faktor 10 plötzlich eine Rolle spielt. 500.000 Abonnenten einer FAZ vor 10 Jahren, aber 5 Millionen Reichweite im Internet oder vielleicht sogar, wenn es gut läuft, mal 15 Millionen und so. Dann würden wir sagen, das sind ja dann 10 Mal so viele. Das spielen wir dann über Werbung aus. Dann stellen wir fest, alle haben Werbeplatz, nicht nur wir. Also bricht dieser Werbemarkt völlig weg und am Ende hat man gar nichts. Also Reichweite kann man nicht monetarisieren. Man spielt in so einem großen Feld und man hat weder Relevanz noch Reichweite, alles verloren. Und was wir als Podcasts ja feststellen, ist, anstatt dass wir den Publikumskreis, den wir haben –du hast die 70.000 genannt, die 70.000, 80.000 –das ist ja so aufsummiert. Spotify, YouTube und dann eben im Kern so diese Runterladsachen, wo wir feststellen, hat jemand runtergeladen, ob abgespielt, wissen wir nicht. Und dann wollen wir das vergrößern. Noch mal 10% drauf, dann sind wir schon bei 90.000. Oder wir sagen, ne, wir fokussieren uns mal auf den Salon. Wenn wir irgendwas haben, dann wird es erstmal im Salon gespielt. Also wenn wir Veranstaltungen planen und so weiter, dann wird der Termin dafür erstmal im Salon genannt. Eben nicht für 70.000, 80.000, die wäre ja total wichtig. Und das ist ja unsere Reichweite, sondern für die Relevanten, die uns bezahlen und so weiter. Und genau diesen Umschwung, Sie sagen es ja einmal ganz kompliziert, das, was die Medienhäuser noch mit sich führen, sind nur ihr Name, aber nicht ihre Funktionsweise. Die müssen Sie neu erfinden. Und das ist halt wahnsinnig schwer, weil die Verlagsabteilung, also der Vertrieb, regiert natürlich in die Redaktion rein. Wenn es dann heißt, du hast ja das Beispiel genannt, der Text läuft aber nicht besonders gut online. Hier müssen wir mal so ein bisschen, dass die Redaktion eigentlich die Blattlinie vorgibt. Darauf müssen wir jetzt mal verzichten. Wir sollten jetzt mal die Ökonomie hier walten lassen. Können Sie uns im Verlag mal eine ordentliche Auswertung geben, welche Texte hier gut laufen? Und zack, hat man es in der redaktionellen Logik drin, dass eben nicht mehr die Redaktion, sondern einfach die Vertriebler bestimmen, was geschieht. Und diese Logik ist so prägend, gerade wenn man feststellt, nein, liebe Journalisten, wir wissen, ihr hängt nicht mehr vom Hofer ab. Niemand, der König ruft euch nicht an und sagt, sondern ihr hängt vom Markte ab. Wenn man das wirklich ernst nimmt, dass es eins von beiden sein muss, dann hätte man sagen müssen, ja, in dem Buch fehlt einfach, dass man in der Redaktion auch nochmal mit ihnen zusammen trauert, dass es so ist, wie es ist. Nämlich, dass sie wirklich alle leiden, finanziell nicht mehr vorwärtskommen. Hospitanten, wenn überhaupt, bezahlen mit 400 € im Monat usw. und von denen aber extrem viel verlangen. Und das ist dann so ein bisschen schade, dass das Buch an dem Punkt so schwach ist. Einfach dieses, wir haben nicht mehr die eine Öffentlichkeit, also müssen wir mehrere bespielen, suchen uns eine aus. Aber dann geht das nur mit ökonomischem Fundament. Und dass sie da so verzweifeln und auch scheitern, ist ja eins dieser großen Probleme. Und ja, da hätte man zum einen in den Redaktionen noch mal eins mitgeben können, weil man dann auch wirklich Verbündete findet in den Redaktionen, die sagen, genau, das ist das Problem. Darüber könnte man gemeinsam...
Und das andere positiv verausstellen. Also ich habe bei den beiden jetzt so den Eindruck, sie ringen mit ihresgleichen dort. Also ab einer gewissen Gehaltsklasse kann man da mit in den Ring steigen. Und die werden dann auch angegriffen oder zitiert oder denen wird auch damit unter mal zugestimmt. Aber es geht jetzt nie darum, dass man wirklich sagt, man weitet wirklich mal den Blick auf das, was es medial noch so gibt. Und ich finde, man kann nicht im Jahr 2022 ein Buch schreiben über Medien. Und da kommen Podcasts nicht vor. Also das glaube ich, geht einfach nicht. Das ist nur, dass die jetzt mal Twitter für sich entdeckt haben. Also die werden ja auch jeden Tag auf Twitter rumhängen, zwar nicht mit ihren Profilen, sondern mit irgendwelchen Accounts. Und gucken sich da alles an, was da passiert. Und haben dann auch vielleicht irgendwann diese Deformation, dass sie glauben, das sei die Wirklichkeit. Also man kann ja auch wiederum sagen, ja, das ist dann natürlich sehr maßgebend für den Journalismus in Deutschland, weil er ganz stark darüber Leute akquiriert, zum Beispiel für Talkshows dann oder für Artikel. Aber zugleich kann man auch sagen, ja, da müsste man doch mal in die anderen Öffentlichkeiten hineinblicken. Zumal macht ja Precht selbst einen Podcast. Und dass man das aber dann überhaupt nicht mal mit einbringt in das Ganze, finde ich ein enormes Versäumnis. Also das darf eigentlich nicht unterlaufen.
Das stimmt. In der Hinsicht sind sie Opfer ihres eigenen Arguments geworden, nämlich, dass sie den Journalisten unterstellen, nur noch Helikopterperspektive einzunehmen. Und sie machen ja dieses tolle Argument, was ich wirklich inhaltlich völlig überzeugend finde. Flüchtlingskrise ohne Flüchtlinge, Pandemie ohne Patienten, Krieg ohne Kriegsopfer, sondern einfach nur, was macht das mit Merkel, was macht das mit Seehofer die ganze Zeit? Und das könnte man ja genauso einfach kopieren, das Argument. Und jetzt sich das Buch anschauen und sich fragen, hm, also nur noch Hauptstadtpresse und alles andere spielt keine Rolle, obwohl man doch eigentlich, der eigentliche Kern wären doch die Flüchtlinge, die Patienten und die Opfer des Krieges geworden, die Flüchtlinge wiederum. Und dann kopiert das Argument zu sagen, hätten wir nicht eigentlich ein Buch über das Publikum schreiben sollen, wenn wir am Anfang feststellen, 44 Prozent sagen, sie können ihre Meinung nicht mehr frei äußern. Warum reden, warum schreiben wir nicht über die und sagen dann, wie marginal da die Person Robin Alexander ist. Und selbst wenn sie dort eine Rolle spielt und auftritt, wird sie verstoßen, glaubt man ihr nicht. Ist sie nur ein Lakei des Systems. Ja, ein System legen, ein der da oben und so. Das wäre natürlich ein mega Angebot gewesen.
Ich würde auch noch mal differenzieren bei diesem Vertrauen den Medien nicht mehr. Also ich kenne jetzt diese genauen Untersuchungen nicht. Aber ich habe, glaube nicht, dass wenn man jetzt fragen würde, die regional-lokalen Nachrichten, trauen sie denen noch? Dann würden wahrscheinlich 95 Prozent sagen, ja natürlich traue ich denen. Also wenn ich weiß, genau im Rathaus ist das und das. Und das wurde jetzt gerade recherchiert. Oder hier geht es um eine Umgehungsstraße. Das ist ja eine ganz andere Vertrauensebene. Wenn es aber jetzt um so eine allgemeine Medienfrage geht, dann haben Leute nicht den Lokaljournalisten, der gut recherchiert vor Ort, vor Augen, sondern sie haben irgendjemanden, der in einer Talkshow sitzt und dann groß verkündet und sagt, jetzt ist die Zeitenwende da. Da wollen wir doch nicht mehr drum herum reden. Und sie haben solche Schwätze in meinen Augen im Kopf und sagen dann, den vertraue ich nicht mehr. Und diese Differenzierung muss man machen. Und ich glaube auch, dass man mehr Verbündete bekäme von Seiten der Journalisten, wenn man das machen würde. Aber wenn man jetzt eigentlich nur sich mit diesen Größen und an diesen Größen abarbeitet, dann hat das auch dann irgendwann den Effekt, dass zum Beispiel junge Journalisten, die idealistischer an die Sache rangehen und denen es wirklich um was geht und die nicht einfach nur im medialen Zirkus ein bisschen mitmischen wollen, dass die dann plötzlich auch sich enttäuscht von Welzer und Precht abwenden, wenn es dann doch wieder nur um so gekränkte Eitelkeiten geht, die da aufeinandertreffen.
Genau. Und deswegen kann ich jetzt, und das klingt ein bisschen komisch, aber als jemand, der über das Mediensystem und über Generationen in Deutschland ein Buch geschrieben hat jeweils, kann ich wirklich nur sagen, das ist die größte Baustelle überhaupt. Junge Menschen, also die zu fragen, hast du Vertrauen in redaktionelle Medien oder so, ist eine völlig quatschige Frage. Denn wir wissen, diese jungen Menschen fühlen sich gerade nirgendwo aufgehoben. Im Buch wird es ja ein bisschen thematisiert. Redaktionelle Medien sind ja nur eine Art von Organisation, der das Publikum verloren geht. Wir haben ja noch die Kirchen, die Gewerkschaften usw. Und die Art und Weise, wie die jungen Menschen gerade in der Luft hängen und nirgendwo noch eine Adresse für ihre Anliegen finden, weiß ich niemand, und zwar kein Journalist, kein Politiker und auch die Elterngeneration, die man so im Freundeskreis hat, nicht dafür interessieren, dass man gerade 1000 Euro für seine 30 qm das erste Mal in eine eigene Wohnung und man leidet von Anfang an. Und man genau weiß, so kann ich nie eine Familie gründen. Und so ist es auch wirklich schwer, mal einen Umzug zu machen dahin, wo Arbeit ist. Weil wenn ich jetzt nochmal einen neuen Mietvertrag unterschreibe, kostet er nochmal 30% mehr. Also dieses unaufgehobene Sein jüngerer Generation spielt in diesem, und das ist ein richtiger alten republikanischer Diskurs, den wir hier gerade besprechen. Also was Nachwuchs angeht und die Frage, haben wir noch Zuspruch für die Demokratie? Ganz gering. Also wir haben es gesehen, 25% der jungen Leute wählen die FDP, weil die irgendwas von Smartphone-Selbstermächtigungen, Bitcoin und so weiter erzählt. Das ist das Erfolgsrezept. Einfach unpolitisch. Dass Christian Lindner sagt, wenn wir das Thema so und so behandeln, droht es ja politisiert zu werden. Und damit entreißen wir es noch im Letzten der jungen Wählerschaft, die glaubt, mit ihrem Smartphone alles machen zu können, weil das sozusagen das letzte Rückzugs- und Refugium ist. Aber wir wissen, wie sehr das Smartphone eigentlich nicht die Lösung ist für all diese Probleme. Und in der Hinsicht haben wir es hier mit Babyboomer zu tun, die über Babyboomer schreiben, mit einem Babyboomer-Problem. Und wieder mal stehen die Jungen daneben und denken sich, bitte.
Und es ist ein sehr deutsches Problem. Der deutsche Sonderweg besteht vor allem darin, die ganze Zeit nur auf Deutschland zu blicken. Das ist ja auch, was sie noch mehr stark machen. Es kommen ja gar keine alternativen Medien vor, weil sie hin und wieder dann so böswillig in Schwurbler-Ecken gestellt werden. Auf wen beziehen sie sich zum Beispiel positiv? New York Times und Financial Times. Also ganz etablierte Leitmedien, wo sie aber sagen, da sah die Berichterstattung seit dem Ukraine-Krieg anders aus. Also natürlich, da stehen da keine Artikel drin, wo man jetzt grundsätzlich den Nationalstaaten und alles in Frage stellt. Aber dort spielen zum Beispiel auch andere Länder, Afrika, also afrikanische Länder, asiatische Länder, spielen dort eine Rolle. Und deren Bezug zum Krieg und deren Probleme vielleicht auch mit gewissen Sanktionen und so etwas. Und das ist ja etwas, was medial so wenig dargestellt wird in Deutschland. Und jetzt würde man immer sagen, ja, aber es gibt doch da Texte. Ja, die gibt es natürlich. Aber es ist ganz klar eine Dominanz dieser anderen Sachen. Und dann geht es wirklich um diese, diesen Bekenntnis, eine Bekenntnispolitik. Sagen Sie jetzt bitte auch, dass die Ukraine...
Im Grunde haben in dieser Land-Sendung noch mal vier Leute dargestellt, dass dieses mediale Feld, in dem sie arbeiten, super, super, super relevant ist. Und weil es so super relevant ist, muss es so hart umkämpft werden, bis hin zu einem, das ist eigentlich ein Krieg, den wir hier ausführen. Aber man muss wirklich sagen, es spielt für kaum einen eine Rolle. Wer liest denn schon morgens die Welt? Oder liest ein Prechtbuch? Und das ist ja wirklich im einstelligen Prozentbereich überhaupt, was jetzt im Vergleich zu 5 Stunden am Tag TikTok und so. In der Ansicht, ja, das ist natürlich ein mega blinder Fleck. Dafür, dass sie so viel über blinde Flecken erzählen, wird das dann ausgeblendet. Müssen wir irgendwas zu diesem Cursor-Journalismus, zur Cursor-Politik?
Ja, das finde ich schon. Und ich würde sogar sagen, das ist das stärkste Kapitel. Für mich ist das deshalb das stärkste Kapitel.
Also für mich war das so verlegenheitsmäßig, wir brauchen noch einen Begriff oder so.
Ja, ich finde den Begriff, mit dem kann ich jetzt auch nichts anfangen. Sie meinen, was wollen Sie eigentlich mir damit sagen? Man richtet sich immer nach dem aus, wo alle schon sind. Was ich an diesem Kapitel interessant finde, und ich vermute, das ist aus der Feder von Wälzer, dass man darauf eingeht, inwieweit es so einen Konformitätsdruck in den Medien gibt. Und sie gehen ja darauf ein, dass man verschiedene Experimente durchgeführt hat, um zu schauen, welche Gruppendynamiken entstehen, welches Wir entsteht, wie ein Wir entsteht. Und es ist ja ganz erstaunlich, dass sie das nochmal rückkoppeln an eine Corona-Erzählung. Sie sagen, Corona hat immer wieder Sündenböcke hervorgebracht. Da waren zum Beispiel die Karnevalisten in Heinsberg, diese Unverantwortlichen, die haben uns überhaupt das Virus angebracht, war eine Zeit lang eine Erzählung. Dann waren es die Jugendlichen, die in den Parks unerlaubterweise gefeiert haben, obwohl doch Ausgangssperre war. Kretschmann hat ja da groß nochmal die Jugendlichen ermahnt, die sollen das ja nicht mehr machen, die sollen ja nicht feiern, die sollen sich zurückhalten. Dann waren die schuld. Dann am 11.11. hat man Bilder gesehen, wurde dann vom Böhmermann und Co. geteilt bei Twitter. Das waren hier die Verursachen jetzt, dass die Viruszahlen wieder nach oben gehen. Also man hat immer wieder neue Schuldige ausgemacht und dann schließt sich so ein Wir darum. Und das Gute jetzt hier ist, dass sie wirklich versuchen, soziologisch mal nachzuprüfen, woher kommt eigentlich so eine Wirrzahlung. Weil das eine sind ja mediale Faktoren, ökonomische Faktoren, aber es gibt auch andere Gründe. Und dann geht es zum Beispiel, noch einen Moment, ich muss... Ach ja, Joshua Kimmich, dieser Fußballer, war auch der größte Sündenbock der Welt. Und wie dann aber auch das wechselt. Und dann sagen sie, irgendwann fing das an, dass Journalisten ganz häufig Wir gesagt haben. Und dann gehen sie darauf ein, dass das vielleicht zurückzuführen ist auf die Bild-Zeitung, die so den richtigen Riecher hatte, die irgendwann verkündete, wir sind Papst, als Benedikt gewählt wurde. Und was dann eigentlich passiert, ist Folgendes, sie sagen, sowohl bei der Pandemie wie beim Ukrainekrieg hatte und hat man es mit so vielen Unbekanntem, schwer Unüberschaubaren und kaum Einschätzbaren zu tun, dass eigentlich genau das Gegenteil naheliegend ist, sich in seinem Urteil zurückzuhalten. Die meisten Politikjournalisten hingegen waren sich ihrer Sache gleichwohl immer sehr sicher. Sie wussten nämlich, wo der Cursor war. Und alles, was sie zu tun hatten, war, dessen Position zu verstärken. Gemäß des neuen publizistischen Imperatives schreibe steht so, dass deine Meinung die Meinung der anderen Journalisten sein könnte. Also schreibe steht so, dass deine Meinung die Meinung der anderen Journalisten sein könnte. Auf diese Weise ersetzt der Cursor die idealtypischen habermaschen Voraussetzungen. Die sind Wahrheit, Richtigkeit und Wahrhaftigkeit. All dies ist nun dem Cursor-Journalismus untergeordnet. Und die mit Macht und Vehemenz vorgetragene Moral entspringt mitnichten der festen Haltung, die man vermeintlich einnimmt, sondern man moralisiert Opportunität. Und das ist für mich die entscheidende Beobachtung. Und damit können wir auch erklären, warum man jetzt gerade nicht moralistisch auf Aserbaidschan reagiert. Wir reagieren moralistisch auf den Ukraine-Krieg und sagen, die höchste Moral ist, jetzt schwere Waffen zu liefern. Warum? Nicht weil man diese unglaublich tolle moralische feste Haltung hat, sondern weil das opportun ist, das zu machen. Und man moralisiert diese Opportunität. Sagst du es auch, Stefan? Und wenn du es nicht sagst, dann bist du unmoralisch. Aber niemanden würde man jetzt gerade auffordern, auch ein solches moralisches Bekenntnis abzulegen in Bezug auf Aserbaidschan oder Saudi-Arabien. Das geht nicht, dass wir mit denen da Handel treiben. Denn das ist nicht gerade opportun. Und damit sind wir, glaube ich, schon an einem ganz entscheidenden Kern dieses Buchs angekommen. Und sie sagen dann noch weiter, die Berichterstattung zum Ukrainekrieg bietet sich vor allem deshalb als Anschauungsobjekt für den Körser Journalismus an, weil sie eben keinen etablierten Rechts-Links-Schema folgt und auch keinem fundamentalen Wertedesenz. Dass Russland für seinen Angriffskrieg auf das Schärfste zu verurteilen ist und dass der Westen dagegen Position beziehen muss, wird sowohl in der Öffentlichkeit wie im Journalismus einhellig gesehen. Und diese Beurteilung ist in der Sache völlig unabhängig davon, welche Partei man wählt, mal dann die entsprechenden Randerscheinungen ausgenommen. Aber entscheidend ist jetzt, dass man so eine Einhelligkeit auch haben möchte, bei dem, was gemacht wird. Die Meinungsgeschlossenheit der veröffentlichten Meinung zu den Waffendieferungen beruht demnach nicht auf unverrückbaren, weltanschaulichen Mustern. Zunächst, und das ist sehr verständlich, entstand sie aus Bestürzung und Empörung gegenüber Russland und aus Empathie mit der überfallenen Ukraine. Nur ging es in der Phase der ersten Empörung auch nicht um konkrete Forderungen und Handlungen der deutschen Regierung, sondern um die allgemein geteilte moralische Verurteilung des Angriffskrieges. Etwas anderes aber ist, dass die Leitmedien sämtliche Maßnahmen, die die Bundesregierung fordern ergriff, einhellig unterstützten und einen erheblichen Schritt weiter Bundeskanzler Scholz zu schnelleren und größeren Waffendieferungen nicht nur aufforderten, sondern mit aller vierten Gewalt trieben. Diese Einhelligkeit ist nun keineswegs mehr selbstverständlich, sondern als Grenzüberschreitung zum Selbstpolitik-Machen wohl nur durch den Cursor-Journalismus erklärbar. Man könnte es sich leicht machen und sagen, deutschlandspolitische Journalisten denken halt so. Aber erstens ist damit nicht erklärt, warum sie so asymmetrisch zur deutschen Bevölkerung denken und sich in einem solchen Ausmaß eilig sind, wo es die Deutschen ansonsten nicht sind. Und zweitens lässt sich mutmaßende Journalisten, die sich bei den Corona-Maßnahmen vom Cursor haben treiben lassen, dies bei der Frage nach der Lieferung von Waffen an die Ukraine auch tun werden. Und diese Beobachtung finde ich wirklich ganz entscheidend, denn das sorgt ja für eine Konformität, die uns in ein Problem hineinführt, dass man plötzlich mutig sein muss, wenn man von dem Cursor-Journalismus abweicht. Und diesen Mut können sich dann eigentlich auch nur Leute wie Precht und Welzer leisten, weil sie ohnehin wieder den nächsten Buchvertrag bekommen werden. Aber wer jetzt als Volontär irgendwo bei einer Zeitung ist und dann von diesem Cursor-Journalismus abweicht, der ja nicht aufoktruiert ist von, da ist jetzt einer, das hat der Chef mal angesagt, so müssen wir es machen, sondern man spürt das so, da muss ich mich verorten. Und diese Verortung findet sehr stark über Twitter statt, wenn da die entsprechenden Großprofile, inklusive Böhmermann und Levitt, sagen, so sehen wir das jetzt, dann weiß man schon, wo der Cursor steht und dann muss man sich daran orientieren. Das sorgt tatsächlich für eine ganz, ganz furchtbare, wie sie schreiben, von Wir-Loyalität. Und diese Wir-Loyalität sorgt dann auch dafür, dass man sich gegen eine Kritik, egal wie sinnvoll sie ist, egal wie klug sie vorgebracht ist, versucht zu immunisieren. Und ich finde auch sehr gut, was sie nochmal sagten mit diesen Beispielen dann aus der Empirie, dass sie auf dieses von Solomon Ash eingehen. Also der in den 50er Jahren macht ja so eine Untersuchung. Da werden, also um das kurz zu beschreiben, es gibt so Bilder, da sind Pixel drin und in dem einen sind mehr dunkle Pixel, in dem anderen weniger. Und dann kann man sagen, welches ist heller und welches ist dunkler. Und dann macht man solche Gruppenexperimente, dass man Gruppen da reinsetzt, hat Gruppen, lässt die es betrachten. Und dann setzt man in diese Gruppen ein paar falsche Probanden rein, die geprieft sind. Wenn ein Bild heller ist, eigentlich zu sagen, ne, es ist dunkler. Und wenn schon mal fünf Leute sich finden in der Gruppe, die sagen, ne, das ist dunkler, obwohl es heller ist, passen sich die anderen, obwohl sie eigentlich sagen müssten, ne, es ist aber doch heller, passen sich dem dann an, weil es diese Gruppendynamik gibt. Und das Interessante ist, dass es so weit geht, dass die immer weiter das schon antizipieren. Also was der andere denken könnte. Es geht noch nicht mal mehr, dass man abwartet, bis dahin, bis er gesagt hat, es ist heller. Und dann mache ich das auch und schließe mich dem an. Sondern man antizipiert irgendwann schon, dass er wohl sagen wird, dass es heller ist. Also sage ich auch schon mal im Vorhinein, dass es heller ist. Und wenn ich noch eine letzte, ich habe jetzt lange monologisiert, ich weiß, aber lass mich noch eine letzte Passage vorlesen. Da heißt es dann, die Versuchspersonen sahen den Reiz so, wie die Gruppe es vorgegeben hatte. Sie entschieden sich also nicht etwa bewusst, sich an eine eigentlich als falsch empfundene Gruppenmeinung anzuschließen. Die Neuropsychologen Christoph Herrmann und Sina Trautmann-Lengsfeld Herrmann und Lengsfeld, die werden wohl deutsche Namen haben, resümierten daher, dass Konformität bereits Wirkung auf den frühen visuellen Verarbeitungsprozess hat. Hier deutet sich also an, dass die soziale Situation, die individuellen Entscheidungen nicht nur im Sinne einer bewussten Anpassung beeinflusst, ich sehe es ja anders, aber wenn die alle meinen, sondern, dass schon die Wahrnehmung von vornherein der vorgegebenen Gruppenmeinung folgt. Man sieht die Welt so, wie man weiß, dass die anderen sie sehen.
Genau, es beginnt bei der Wahrnehmung solcher Argumentationen, die das Bewusstsein der einzelnen Menschen außen vor lassen. Finde ich ja immer hoch attraktiv, weil sie meistens funktionieren. Deswegen war mir auch in der alten Republik ganz wichtig zu betonen, wenn wir nach mehr Zusammenhalt, gerade jetzt unter so sozialem Druck und Stress zwischen den Generationen zum Beispiel oder wie auch immer, suchen, dann finden wir den erstmal nicht in der Kommunikation und auch nicht im Gerede. Und dann nützt auch nicht noch eine Buchmesse mit 10.000 Veranstaltungen und noch eine Annivilsendung, sondern dann müssen wir irgendwo bei den Gesten und bei der Berührung und sowas anfangen, wo einfach erstmal nur wahrgenommen wird, bevor überhaupt eine inhaltliche Ebene etabliert ist, um dann inhaltlich irgendwas auszubreiten. Und da finde ich es auch sehr gut, dass der Welzer hier alles in die Waagschale wirft, dass die Sozialpsychologie da im Angebot hat und dass die beiden sich dann auch trauen, es begrifflich auf den Punkt zu bringen. Gerade in diesen Kapiteln, wo du jetzt auch schon viel vorgelesen hast, wo ich auch finde, wenn sie eine Lesung machen, dann sollten sie den ersten Teil des Buches so aber sich darauf dann fokussieren. Und wie deutlich sie hier werden, also sie reden von Galapublizistik, das finde ich schon mal gut, weil das ist so dieses, das ist ja auch ein jahrelang, auch im Aufwarn-Podcast schon immer, es gibt eben diese RTL-Sendung für die Reichen und die Schön und dann die öffentlich-rechtlichen Sendung für die Mächtigen. Aber es ist genau der gleiche Aufarbeitung von Journalismus, dass man sich anschaut, was machen die Mächtigen gerade, und dann wird das Tagebuch des Olaf Scholz erzählen und so, aber eigentlich nur noch der Laufsteg für die nicht so schön. Genau, es ist ein Laufsteg für diejenigen, die halt innerlich arbeiten müssen, weil sie körperlich vielleicht Defizite haben und so. Also um es despektierlich zu sagen. Und wir haben es hier mit einer Zitat medioindigenen Vorzensierung politischer Programme zu tun, weil das Mediensystem um diese politischen Programme drum herum so gestrickt ist, wie es gestrickt ist. Und gerade dann in diesem Cursor-Kapitel, dass dann mit Auf den Cursor kommt es an, beginnt, dabei sein ist wichtiger als Unabhängigkeit. Das ist ja diese Losung. Journalisten möchten gerne dazugehören. Und das machen sie über inhaltliche Arbeit. Sie bekennen sich zu einem Zeitgeist, der schon da ist. Und so arbeiten sie im Windkanal des Zeitgeistes. Das ist eine ganz tolle Formulierung, finde ich. Denn egal welches Design man vorstellt für seine Arbeit, man schickt sie erstmal in den Windkanal, lässt einmal alles abschleifen, was abgeschliffen werden muss. Und dann, mein Leiterartikel ist fertig. Es war der gleiche Leiterartikel wie letzte Woche. So wie die Diskurse vom Parlament in die Talkshows gewandert sind, wo sie eben dann personalisiert, haben wir ja vorhin besprochen, behandelt werden, verwandeln sich ja die politische Arena, insbesondere Parteitage und so weiter, in hoch flexible Mitten. Jeder wollte nur noch in die Mitte, und die sollte so ganz flexibel und immer anpassbar. Also egal wie der Wind gerade weht, wir in der Mitte gehen jetzt in die Richtung. Und dann hat Merkel einfach gesagt, wir gehen jetzt in die Richtung. Und sich zu trauen, hier von Medio-Indogener Vorzensierung, antizipierendem Konformismus auf Seiten der Politik, weil man die Medien sieht, und auf Seiten der Medien, Windkanal des Zeitgeistes zu sprechen, finde ich sehr gut. Und es sind auch Formulierungen, die sollte man häufiger mal verwenden. Ich finde es schade, dass die selber das nicht machen, also im eigenen Textangebot, da nicht treu sind, einfach bei den kleinen Snippets, die sie jetzt so in Interviews raushauen. Aber hier sind auch einige Angebote da, um Kapieren kommt von Kopieren. Das ist doch ganz wunderbar auf den Punkt gebracht, irgendwie, was sie uns sagen wollten.
Und was auch noch sehr, sehr klug ist, sie gehen die ganze Zeit auf diese Krisen ein, also Krieg, Corona, Migration. Und man könnte ja sagen, aber warum sich so auf diese Punkte konzentrieren? Weil da die Konformität zeigen, diese empirischen Untersuchungen besonders hoch sind. Warum? Weil Krisen skriptlos verlaufen. Das heißt, wir haben bei den normalen Dingen, also ich will mal ein einfaches Beispiel machen, wenn wir uns jetzt verabreden in Frankfurt und sagen, wir treffen uns am Frankfurter Römer morgen um 15 Uhr, dann wissen alle in Frankfurt in etwa, wie man da hinkommt. Und das ist auch gar kein Problem. Da gibt es verschiedene Wege, die einen dann da hinführen. Wenn man aber in einer Krisensituation ist, wo man nicht in sich im normalen Zustand befindet, also nicht normal gehen kann und sagen kann, ich gehe immer daher oder daher, dann versucht man sich bei irgendjemanden zu orientieren, der schon vorausgeht oder der sagt, ich weiß es. Und das sind dann, wie sie das nennen, skriptlose Situationen. Und sie sagen, die Konformität steigt, je skriptloser die Situation ist. Corona, da hatten wir keinen Skript für. Man hat erst noch ein bisschen gedacht, ist das so wie BSE oder so? Nee, stellt sich dann heraus. Das hat alles gar nichts damit zu tun, mit dem, was wir bislang hatten. Wir haben da keinen Skript für. Und deswegen müssen wir schnell ein neues entwerfen. Und dann entsteht eine große Konformität. Genauso jetzt auch ein solcher Krieg, wie er jetzt da ist. Den haben wir Lebenden, fast alle, noch nie erlebt. Und deswegen fehlt uns das Skript. Und wir sind aber natürlich darauf angewiesen, uns irgendwie zu orientieren oder wollen uns orientieren. Und dann bietet es sich an, sich möglichst konform zu verhalten. Weil das immer getan wird in skriptlosen Situationen. Und sie gehen dann auf diese Beispiele an. Wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass es diese Zuschauersituationen gibt? Da wird jemandem Gewalt angetan und alle gaffen nur. Und das sind immer solche Konformitätsmomente auch deshalb. Weil man eigentlich jetzt eine Orientierung sucht, denn man hat keinen Skript dafür. Man kann nicht sagen, ja genau, immer wenn jemand angegriffen wird, mache ich ja das und das. Nee, das erlebt man ja gerade zum ersten Mal. Und das ist, finde ich, auch noch mal eine sehr gute Herleitung. Also ich finde gerade, wo man immer auf so eine wissenschaftlichere Ebene geht, also das tut, was sie einfordern, nämlich Vertiefung. Und das macht das Buch zu wenig. Da wird es aber dann gut, wenn sie es machen.
Ich finde, das, was du gerade beschrieben hast, ist auch eine super Hinleitung zu diesem letzten Punkt, der mir wichtig ist, weil es wirklich so ein schönes Argument ist. Es ist leicht verständlich. Es ist nach allem, was wir heute einschätzen können, auch absolut richtig und wichtig, es mal zu bringen. Im Rahmen dieser Erregungsökonomie, Verlust des Kontextes. Skriptlos heißt ja auch, über kommunale Politik, also was weiß ich, ein Zebrastreifen, ist so voraussetzungsvoll, da muss man nämlich genau wissen, wer da ist, was kostet der, welches Stadtparlament, welche Abteilung, welches Kremium, ist überhaupt zuständig, wissen wir alles nicht. Über Putin kann man einfach so dahin labern, weil der hat irgendwelche psychischen Dispositionen und dann rätselt man halt darüber. Und da läuft ja auch dieses, Skript ist das falsche Wort, aber diese Idee, über die Personen können wir immer noch mal reden. Die Strukturen sind immer kompliziert, aber über Personen, so tratsch, fällt uns einfach leicht. Und das fällt uns natürlich jetzt besonders auf die Füße, wenn wir es mit dieser neuen Medienrealität zu tun haben, indem wir eben anders als beim Historikerstreit nicht nur Argumente, sondern die Sprecher gegeneinander aufwiegen oder auch bei der Friedenspreisrede von Martin Walser eben nicht mehr die Rede kritisieren, sondern nur noch Martin Walser, weil ein Tweet gar nicht mehr Platz hergibt, als zu sagen, Martin Walser ist doof. Und so wurden ja auch Alexander Kluge und Reinhard Merkel und Jürgen Habermas abgeschossen.
Das Zwei-, dass das Walser-Beispiel nicht besonders gut gewählt wird, sie gehen da noch auf krass ein, denn beide krass wie Walser würden immer sagen, wir wurden damals furchtbar verletzt und persönlich angegriffen. Ich weiß nicht, ob da die Debatte, die sie eingefordert, wie sie hier eingefordert wird, tatsächlich da war. Es gab natürlich große Debatten. Schömmacher hat ja auch eine Bubis-Walser-Debatte geführt. Da gibt es einen dicken Band, wo man das alles nachlesen kann. Aber die Verwerfungen und die persönlichen Angriffe von beiden Seiten waren schon sehr massiv. Also das ist wieder meine Frage, ob nicht eine Vergangenheit, und das ist sicherlich auch ein Boomer-Problem, eine Vergangenheit idealisiert wird. Zwar läuft es jetzt auf neuen Kanälen, aber ob sich das immer alles so stark verändert hat, ich bin mir da wirklich unsicher. Also ich würde sagen, ja, es gibt diesen Twitter-Effekt. Aber zugleich haben wir wieder so große Konstanten in den Medien auch. Also gerade wenn wir uns den Hurra-Patriotismus von 1914 ansehen, dann kann man sagen, ja, aber das war ja da auch.
Ich sag mal so, als er Martin Walz als Friedenspreisrede nannte, dachte ich so in meinem Kopf, ja, vielleicht war das so der letzte Moment, wo man noch mehr auf das Argument und die Rede als auf Martin Walzer einschlug. So im Sinne von...
Aber bei Gras war das doch als Gras-Israel-Gedicht. Das war ja eine, wo er sich beleidigt fühlte, wo andere sich gegenseitig beleidigten, weil der eine diese, der andere jene Position hatte. Es gab von Rolf Hochrud einen Artikel, ich glaube, er erschien in der Welt, wo er sagte, also anlässlich dieses Gedichts, Günther, du bleibst, was du warst, ein Mann der Waffen-SS. Also solche Äußerungen gab es schon.
Ja, aber das wird ja noch von Leuten, die die Person kennen. Das Phänomen, was wir heute haben, ist ja, dass man jemanden überhaupt nicht kennt, sondern ist allererster Mal über die Verfehlung überhaupt Kontakt oder Kenntnis von einer Person erlangt und sie sofort als Person verurteilt, weil man die Verfehlung komplett auf sie... Und das ist dieses Twitter-Phänomen. Und dieser Verlust von Kontext. Also wir reißen alle Kontexte raus und machen damit Argumente anschlussfähig. Sehr über Personalisierung, aber auch einfach so, weil sie moralisch und so weiter verwerflich sind. Sie sagen ja auch, umso weniger Fundament hat man hat, umso höher muss das moralische Haus dann sein, dass man darauf baut. Oder umso höher kann es sein. Und dann machen sie ja diesen Punkt. Diese Diskurskultur von heute läuft über Bewertung. Und damit vererbt sich eine Kommunikationslogik, die wir in vielen Bereichen haben, heute auch auf mediale Diskurse. Also wir bewerten natürlich unsere Ebay-Käufe und unsere Amazon-Käufe und unsere Filme, die wir sehen. Alles wird bewertet. Und damit bewerten wir automatisch natürlich auch, warum sollten wir die ausdrücklich nicht bewerten, Menschen, die an Kommunikation teilnehmen, egal welcher. Also es läuft irgendwo in Argumentation. Und wir fragen uns sofort, kann ich nicht auch den Sprecher bewerten jetzt? Also es ist so ein Automatismus, der einfach dadurch mitläuft, auch dass wir natürlich häufiger Personen einfach sehen, wenn sie bei Land sitzen, so richtig als ich bin. Und jetzt wird man eingeladen zu bewerten. Und diese Art der Bewertung ist gerade von denjenigen, die ja besonders häufig moralisch aufgeladen bewerten, eigentlich ein in die Falletappen einer ökonomischen Funktionsweise. Nämlich, dass wir natürlich nur bewerten, um Sachen miteinander zu ranken und dann Wert zu vergeben. Also ökonomischen Wert.
Und dann kommt ein Preisschild dran.
Genau, da kommt ein Preisschild dran. Wer ist eigentlich der beste Uber-Fahrer und wer ist der beste Händler bei Ebay und so weiter. Das zahlt sich am Ende alles ökonomisch aus. Eine moralische Bewertung von Personen im politischen Diskurs zahlt sich nicht ökonomisch für irgendwen aus, sondern man kann ja höchstens da noch ein bisschen Prominenz oder so und dann vielleicht, keine Ahnung, Buchkäufe oder so. Aber für uns ist ja völlig egal. Also wir kommen gar nicht aus der Logik des Bewertens raus, auch wenn sie da gar keinen Sinn macht oder vielleicht sogar extrem dysfunktional ist. Was haben wir davon? Alle nochmal diese Tweets über, den finde ich aber echt blöde. Und dann auch wieder sagen, aber eigentlich mit der Bewertung, mit meiner expliziten Bewertung einer Person mache ich auch ein Angebot, mich zu bewerten. Also Jan Böhmermann sieht irgendwo etwas Twitter darüber und heimst damit wieder Bewertungen von anderen ein, die ihn als, ah ja, der sieht es so und so. Hier Sternchen, Sternchen, Sternchen für diese Bewertung der anderen. Sie haben so eine Bewertungskaskade, die am Ende nur Sinn macht in einer ökonomischen Logik, die es aber hier gar nicht gibt. Also wir sind in so eine Falle gestolpert, weil wir alles ökonomisiert und finanzialisiert haben. Und damit diese Logik auch dem politischen Diskurs einfach überstülpen und zwar völlig ohne Sinn. Es hat gar keinen Sinn, so viel zu bewerten, es sei denn, wir verstehen die ganzen Twitter-Fuffs und Facebook-Likes wirklich als Bewertung unserer Person. Was natürlich so ist heutzutage. Und was es besonders attraktiv macht, sich noch mal moralisch irgendwie reinzuwerfen irgendwo und irgendeinen Kommentar abzuliefern, um dann selber wieder das Reputationskonto so ein bisschen aufzuladen. Und das finde ich einen sehr guten Punkt, dass gerade diejenigen, die besonders häufig sehr moralisch unterwegs sind in ihrem Handeln, eigentlich einer ökonomischen Logik sich ausgeliefert haben. Also gerade einer nicht-moralischen, sondern sehr ökonomischen, was genau das Gegenteil davon ist. Und denen das noch mal vorzuhalten so als Spiegel, finde ich gut.
Was auch damit zusammenhängt, dass der Journalismus so prekär ist, auch so schlecht bezahlt wird. Auch da gibt es ja Ideen, wie man das lösen könnte. Brauchen wir mehr öffentlich-rechtliche Medien? Brauchen wir da mehr im Internet? Warum nicht auf europäischer Ebene? Das sind ja auch Gedanken, die hier aufgebracht werden, die keineswegs neu sind. Aber es zeigt wieder, dass in den letzten zehn Jahren kaum diskutiert worden sind. Zugleich glaube ich, dass wir nicht die große mediale Revolution erleben, wenn wir jetzt ein europäisches, öffentlich-rechtliches bekommen. Und ja, man kann darüber nachdenken, wie könnte eine Infrastruktur aussehen? Ich bin da überhaupt nicht dagegen. Ich glaube nur, dass solche Lösungsvorschläge, die da am Ende gemacht werden, so ein bisschen aus dieser Verlegenheit heraus sind. Man schreibt ein Sachbuch und bekommt gesagt, ja, aber sie müssen ja noch ein paar Lösungswege aufzeigen. Und ich würde sagen, nein, das ist eigentlich ein Missverständnis, denn das ist jetzt ein Einwurf, was gerade schief läuft oder von dem die Autoren meinen, was gerade schief läuft. Und dann, wenn wir wirklich mal bei diesem Habermaschen-Ideal bleiben, ist es ja so, dass die Öffentlichkeit wieder darauf reagiert. In Form von Ausdifferenzierung, in Form von Widerspruch, in Form momentan leider von Häme und Spott. Und das ist natürlich eine Reaktion, die dazu führt, dass so ein Buch einfach verpufft und nie eine vernünftige Debatte darüber entsteht. Ich will auch noch mal hier unterstreichen, es gibt sehr viel klügere Medienkritiken. Und ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, ihr müsst alle dieses Buch lesen. Ich würde immer sagen, wir amüsieren uns zur Tode von Postman. Lest das Buch über das Fernsehen von Bourdieu. Und dann würde ich irgendwann auch sagen, man kann auch den Welzer und Precht noch dazu nehmen. Und man kann ein paar gute Beobachtungen dort auch finden und auch paar schöne Formulierungen, die du uns vorgetragen hast. Aber was wir hier nochmal deutlich unterstreichen sollten, ist, wenn die Reaktion darauf nur Spott und Häme ist, dann dichtet man sich ab. Und es wird sich eigentlich der Effekt, der hier im Buch beschrieben ist, noch verstärken. Beziehungsweise die überspitzten Zuschreibungen, die hier stattfinden im Buch, sind dann irgendwann nicht mehr überspitzt, weil sie einfach der Realität entsprechen. Und das ist das ganz, ganz große Problem, das wir haben, wenn wir so eine Diskursverschließung eigentlich haben, dass man sich gar nicht mehr darauf einlassen will und dass man gar nicht mehr groß darüber streitet. Und das ist meine Sorge eigentlich, dass man jetzt, sobald man eine mediale Kritik äußert, oft dann noch in die Ecke gestellt wird, ach, so bist du auch so wie Precht und Welzer oder was? Und die und Precht und Welzer sind ja wie die, die und die, und dann wissen wir, mit denen wollen wir aber wirklich nicht. Und diese große Gefahr sehe ich jetzt eigentlich. Und deswegen würde ich mir eine Intellektualisierung und eine Vertiefung des Diskurses wünschen. Und der kann aber nur öffentlich stattfinden. Also das ist eigentlich das Buch, ist der Einwurf. Und alles andere muss jetzt ausgehandelt werden. Machen wir jetzt hier gerade. Werden Leute machen im privaten Kreise. Werden es vielleicht aber auch aufgreifen, wenn sie in Redaktionen sind, werden sich vielleicht immer mal die Frage stellen, mache ich hier auch gerade eine Konformitätsbewegung, obwohl ich nicht so ganz davon überzeugt bin? Oder was antizipiere ich eigentlich schon, was man mir sagen wird? Und niemand wird sich davon vollkommen frei machen können. Also ich ja auch nicht und du auch nicht. Und man denkt natürlich sehr viel auch mit. Und gerade da, wo man skriptloser agiert. Also wenn ich einen Film bespreche von einem Regisseur, wo ich schon fünf Mal darüber gesprochen habe, dann habe ich in gewisser Weise auch schon so einen Rahmen. Aber wie begegne ich dem ganz Neuen? Da wird die Angst plötzlich groß und dann schaut man. Und das ist, glaube ich, etwas, wo man eigentlich diese Debatte hinführen müsste, damit sie klüger wird.
Ja, das ist der Punkt. Es ist einfach nicht klug, wie es gerade läuft. Die beiden nehmen sich da auch nichts raus. Sie spielen auch damit, dass sie gewisse Freiheiten haben. Hier fallen ja wirklich Sätze wie, es wird gerade viel Anschauungsmaterial für Schüler hergestellt, wo man im Unterricht nochmal darüber reden kann, wie sich als liberal und demokratisch selbst missverstehende Journalisten zu vierte Gewalttätern wurden. Das sind so die verspielten Sachen. Auf der anderen Seite, ja, es hat natürlich ein konstruktives Ende, wenn auch aus Verlegenheit, indem man sagt, liebe Journalisten, interessiert euch doch nochmal für das Neue, die Wunder des Alltags, für die Wirksamkeit von Handeln, statt einfach nur Bundespolitik abzubilden, weil man selbst Bundesliga spielen möchte. Ich finde es trotzdem am Ende sehr gut, dass sie nochmal darstellen, dass es bei aller Personalisierung, die sie kritisieren, eine Person hat damals den Unterschied gemacht. Das war Frank Schirmacher. Genau. Er hat das, was als Erbe zu verteidigen galt, damals aufgebaut. Das Erbe wurde nicht angetreten. Sie sagen ausdrücklich, ich pflichte dem komplett bei Jürgen Kauber, Schirmachers Lebenswerk, bin in weniger Monate annulliert. Genau so ist es gekommen. Daher steht am Ende dieser große Appell im Raum. Erinnert euch an die Frage, auf die ihr eine Antwort sein wolltet. Das ist super pathetisch, aber für so ein Buch angemessen. Jetzt müssen die Journalisten klarkommen, was hier als Textangebot vorliegt, von dem sie wissen, das lesen ganz schön viele im Publikum. Oder reden zumindest mit jemandem, der es vielleicht ein bisschen gelesen hat. Warum die beiden sich selbst gerade mit ins Getümmel werfen, verstehe ich nicht ganz. Aber auf der anderen Seite, es macht ja auch Spaß. Ich hoffe, sie haben auch Spaß dabei, zu lanzen und so weiterzugehen.
Ich glaube, sie sind auch Teil des Problems. Das meine ich jetzt so ganz, ganz, ganz wortwörtlich. Sie zitieren hier Schirmacher, der schrieb, was wir jetzt erleben, das ist eine industrielle Revolution. Also es geht darum, dass eigentlich bei den intellektuellen Schriftstellen, Professoren immer alles gleich war. Man hat halt Bücher gelesen, hat publiziert, geschrieben. Da hat sich nicht viel verändert. Jetzt aber durch die digitale Revolution erleben wir eine industrielle Revolution. Und zwar nicht mehr nur von Aufschreibsystemen, sondern von geistiger Arbeit überhaupt. Und das ist, was Schirmacher ja so hervorragend erkannt hat und dann im Föjeton verhandelt hat und noch ein Journalist wird ja ganz positiv herausgehoben, Claudius Seidel, nämlich auch, F. Föjeton-Chef damals gewesen. Und der hat sich zum Relotius-Skandal geäußert. Und ich glaube, das würde ich nochmal jetzt zum Schluss von meiner Seite stark machen. Aus dem Relotius-Skandal haben wir nichts gelernt. Und ich habe gerade den Film über Relotius jetzt über diesen Skandal gesehen. Der heißt der Borghenius. Das ist mit Elias M. Barik in der Hauptrolle. Michael Bulli habe ich als verfilmt. Und es wird das Entscheidende, und das lese ich jetzt gleich vor, was das Entscheidende ist, diesem Film überhaupt nicht vorhanden. Da geht es darum, ja, man muss mal die Fakten checken und was stimmt dann und so weiter. Und Seide hat damals einen Artikel zu diesem Relotius-Skandal veröffentlicht. Und kommt dann dazu, dass man ja erst einmal, als dieser Name Relotius fiel, dachte, wer soll das sein? Ich kannte ganz viele Journalisten und mich eingeschlossen, die den Namen noch nie gehört hatten. Du glaub ich auch nicht, oder? Ich auch nicht. Das war aber dann irgendwie dieser Star. Und dann dachte man, ach, das ist ja interessant, dass man diesen Star gar nicht kennt. Aber in dieser Reporter-Szene war er dann ein Star. Also in dieser Reportageszene. Und Seidel schrieb dann, genau so bringen das auch andere hochdekorierte Reportage-Preisträger in Seminaren und Workshops den jungen Kollegen bei. Also es geht darum, dass man ja bei Reportagen, ich muss den ganzen Absatz vorlesen, also den überraschendsten Kommentar zum Relotius-Skandal verfasste in dieser Zeit Claudius Seidel, damals Vöhtorn-Chef der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung. Zeitung Seidel stimmte nicht in den Gesang der Empörten ein, sondern hielt die Empörung der Spiegelredaktion für wohlfeil. Schließlich habe Relotius als Superstreber durchnur gemacht, was in Reportageseminaren gelehrt werde, unter anderem von besagten Chefredakteur selbst, dass die Reportagen nach dem Erzählmuster sind. hast. Und genau so bringen das auch andere hochdekorierte Reportage-Preisträger in Seminaren und Workshops den jungen Kollegen bei, dass es bei der Reportage um Casting und Dramaturgie gehe, dass wer in diesen schnellen Zeiten noch gelesen werden will, sich an der Erzähltechnik von Spielfilmen orientieren soll. Nun, exakt das, Zitat Ende, habe Relotius gemacht und sei in perfekter Redundanz gerade dafür mit Reporterpreisen ausgezeichnet worden. Und weiter heißt es dann noch, weil Seidel das Erstaunliche viele von denen, die sich sehr fürs geistige und politische Leben interessieren, Zeitungen lesen und auf die Namen der Autoren achten, von Claas Relotius noch nie gehört hatten, und wenn man Themen und Titel nannte zugeben musste, dass sie über den dritten Absatz nicht hinausgekommen seien, zu bekannt, zu berechenbar, lieber weitergeplättert zum Wissenschaftsresort. Man darf solche Momentaufnahmen sicher nicht allzu ernst nehmen. Aber es scheint doch Anlass zur Hoffnung zu geben, dass Zeitungsleser sich nicht einen Gefühlsverstärker wünschen, dass sie sich lieber herausfordern als einlullen lassen. Journalismus ist halt im Kern die Verbreitung von Neuigkeiten, nicht von Altbekanntem. Und wir haben diese Kritik der journalistischen Erzählung, des Reportagehaften, die haben wir kaum in den Mittelpunkt gerückt. Diese Storytelling-Ideologie, wir haben über Fakten gesprochen, dann über Haltungsjournalismus, all das. Und wir haben das verpuffen lassen. Wir haben jetzt wieder einen medialen Aufschrei um dieses Buch. Und ich habe die große Sorge, dass das jetzt auch wieder nicht dazu führt, dass man anfängt, klüger, selbstreflexiver, damit medial umzugehen. Und man könnte es ja auch mal in einer Talkshow machen, wo man die beiden dann gar nicht einlädt, sondern man vielleicht mal Leute in einer Talkshow das verhandeln lässt, die Journalisten sind und die das bestätigen können, aber jetzt nicht so auch wieder irgendwelche Lautsprecher einladen, sondern Leute, die sagen, ja, eigentlich komme ich mit meinen Themen kaum mal auf eine vordere Seite, weil immer gerade irgendwo in Berlin wieder eine Sau durchs Dorf getrieben wird.
Der Brunnen, in den das Kind schon gefallen ist, ist eben viel tiefer, als wir glauben. Das haben wir hier wieder mal zu sehen bekommen. Die Journalisten sollen froh sein, dass überhaupt noch jemand sie relevant und ernst nimmt, so wie die beiden, denn das große Publikum tut es eben nicht mehr.
Wir müssen bei diesem Buch die Autoren von ihrem Werk trennen. Und dann sehen wir auch, dieses Werk ist nicht skandalös. Das Werk enthält einige gute Thesen, um zu verstehen, wie sich die mediale Welt entwickelt hat. Es enthält aber vielleicht zu wenig Selbstreflexion und es enthält gewiss zu wenig theoretische Grundlage. Dennoch ist es ein Debattenbeitrag, den man sehr ernst nehmen müsste.
Und wer sich jetzt fragt, Precht oder Welzer, haben sie Recht? Haben sie beide Recht oder nicht? Diese Frage kann man wirklich dahingestellt lassen. Wir sagen, das Buch kommt zu Recht in dieser Zeit. Es ist ein Buch für diesen Winter. Und wer darüber hinaus noch was erfahren möchte, lese bitte. Stefan Schulz, Redaktionsschluss von 2016. Ein Buch, das auch heute noch aktuell ist, weil es damals genau mit diesem Anliegen geschrieben wurde. Und ich bin einmal mehr froh zu sehen, dass man noch so schreiben kann.
Dann springen wir erst mal zu den Influencern. Machen wir mal etwas leichtes jetzt. Und wir bleiben aber zugleich bei der Personalisierung. Und zwar einfach mal ein paar Zahlen. Und zwar sind die aus dem Magazin für Kommunikation. Da hat Judith Henke mal aufgeschrieben, wie groß das Influencer-Business inzwischen ist. Und da geht es erst einmal um Ronaldo. Wie viel bekommt Ronaldo für einen Werbepost bei Instagram?
Cristiano Ronaldo.
Also dann sind wir bestimmt schon im siebenstelligen Bereich. Eine Million Euro.
2,4 Millionen Dollar bekommt er für einen einzigen Post. Dann gibt es die Zwillinge Lisa und Lena. Die kennst du vielleicht. Die machen auch bei TikTok so ein Kram.
10 Millionen Follower.
Wenn die bei Instagram etwas posten, also pro Post, so wird geschätzt von Hopper HQ. Die haben so eine Liste, Instagram Richlist veröffentlicht. Also die scheinen pro Post 72.000 Dollar zu bekommen. Also ist auch schon ordentlich. Es ist so, dass von den Internet-Nutzern, den Jungen, die befragt wurden, 24% angeben, schon mal ein Produkt gekauft zu haben oder mehrere Produkte gekauft zu haben, die von Influencern auf YouTube beworben wurden. Instagram wird wichtiger, da gibt es einen Zuwachs, aber TikTok holt natürlich auch auf. Die Kunden ziehen, so sagt dann der Geschäftsführer von Faktenkontor, die Kunden ziehen es vor, personalisierte Werbung zu erhalten, die sich nach ihren Bedürfnissen richtet, was ich erstmal nicht so verwunderlich finde. Das geht mir ja auch so, dass ich sagen würde, wenn schon Werbung sein muss, dann wenigstens was Sinnvolles, zeigt mir nicht laufend irgendwas, was ich garantiert niemals kaufen würde. Also ich bekomme ja immer so Turnschuhwerbung oder so was angezeigt. Ja, aber ich bekomme immer Turnschuhwerbung angezeigt und dann müsste diesem Algorithmus mal irgendwie zu verstehen geben, dass ich keine Turnschuhe trage. Ich weiß dann nicht, wie diese, wie diese Algorithmus auf die Idee kommt.
Das ist ein psychologisches Element, der will dich noch erziehen, Weiße.
Möglicherweise. Wie viel geben deutsche Firmen für Influencer Marketing aus? Schätzung zufolge sind das 476 Millionen Euro pro Jahr. Also das ist schon ganz ordentlich. Und wir reden ja jetzt hier immer nur von der Werbung, die Influencer machen. Wir reden jetzt hier nicht von den eigenen Produkten der Influencer. Dann wären wir ja direkt bei einem Milliarden-Business, also so eine Pamela Reif oder so. Wenn die da zehn Millionen mal ihren Müsli-Regel verkauft, da sind wir ja an ganz anderen Höhen angelangt. Also es geht hier wirklich um diese klassische Influencer-Werbung. Und die durchschnittliche Wachstumsrate zwischen 2019 und 2024 schätzt der Datendienst. Also das ist jetzt wieder ein anderer Datendienst, der da frequentiert wurde. Auf 23% weltweit gaben Unternehmen 2021 laut Zahlen von Influencer Marketing Hub fast 14 Milliarden US-Dollar für Influencer-Werbung aus. Dem Bundesverband Digitale Wirtschaft zufolge gaben 2021 in einer Befragung 14% der Unternehmen an, pro Jahr mehr als 100.000 Euro ihres Budgets für Influencer einzupflanzen. Also wir sprechen jetzt hier von deutschen Unternehmen. 11% geben sogar über 250.000 Euro für Influencer Marketing aus. Ja, YouTube ist immer noch wichtig, TikTok wird wichtiger. Dann zeigt sich das bei der Generation Z, die TikTok inzwischen gleich auf ist mit Instagram. Ich glaube, das wird uns nicht verwundern. Dann wird hier Philip Martin von Reachbird zitiert, im Schnitt verdienen Influencer circa 25 Euro pro 1000 Abonnenten, wenn man Instagram als Referenz betrachtet. Also es ist ein tausender Kontaktpreis von 25 Euro. Allerdings ist es bei Mikro-Influencern, das heißt also Influencer mit 20, 30 Tausender Reichweite, oft ein höherer Betrag, weil die eine Nische ansprechen und man damit dann gezielter werben kann. Und damit ist der Kontaktpreis dann auch höher. Influencer, die von einer Agentur vertreten werden, schreibt Henke, würden in der Regel 15 bis 20 Prozent ihres Honorars an diese abgeben. Wer über 50.000 Follower habe, könne theoretisch vom Influenzen alleine leben. Laut einer Studie der KI-Analystenplattform Hype Auditor liegt der Durchschnittsverdienst eines Influencers bei 2.970 US-Dollar im Monat. Influencer, denen über eine Million Fans folgen, verdienen im Schnitt 15.000 Dollar monatlich. Gut, das ist jetzt also nur dann auf die Werbung bezogen. Doch anders als sie können die meisten Influencer nicht allein von ihren Werbejobs leben. Nur vier Prozent aller Influencer erreichen dieses Ziel. Also da haben wir wieder diese ganz, ganz spitz zu laufende Pyramide, die wir auch im Buch beschrieben haben. Man hat Einzelne, die es wirklich geschafft haben und eine extreme finanzielle Unabhängigkeit erleben. Aber für die anderen Influencer, die sich jetzt so ein bisschen umtun und da und dort mal eine Werbekooperation haben, ist es überhaupt nicht denkbar, dass sie da ganz aussteigen können und dass sie finanziell unabhängig mit dem Influencer-Business sind. Also nur für ganz wenige gilt das natürlich. Und wichtig ist dann auch die Interaktionsrate natürlich. Also man rechnet, sagt hier dann ein Marketing-Experte, wenn die Likes bei zwei bis drei Prozent der Followerzahl liegen, ist das eine solide Interaktionsrate. Also dann kann man sehen, da wird auch noch mit der Community kommuniziert oder die Community interessiert sich auch noch wirklich für die Inhalte. Ja, das waren jetzt mal so ein paar Zahlen. Und ich finde es doch ganz erstaunlich, noch mal so zu hören, nur vier Prozent aller Influencer erreichen das Ziel, finanziell unabhängig zu sein. Also was das doch für eine Illusion ist, dieses Aufstiegsversprechen, Influencertum. Und das sind eigentlich die Zahlen, die muss man mit in den Unterricht nehmen, weil du eben ja auch das angesprochen hast, da im Lehrer nachgefahren, das sind so Zahlen, die braucht man, um mal zu sagen, ja vier Prozent von denen, die schon Influencer sind. Und da sind ja noch nicht die eingerechnet, die mal so ein bisschen probiert haben und nur auf 500 Follower hochgekommen sind. Also eigentlich ganz traurig, wie sehr suggeriert wird, dass es alles schaffen können und wie wenig es dann in der Tat sind.
Jo, bleiben wir mal bei Zahlen, aber auf der anderen Seite des Spektrums. Menschen, die nicht so richtig vorwärtskommen. Der Kinder- und Jugendreport 2022, der DAK, da ist er zumindest veröffentlicht.
Ach, du hast den auch mitgebracht. Du hast den auch mitgebracht?
Ja, ich habe vorhin schon gedacht.
Dann haben wir den ja beide, das ist doch praktisch.
Ich wollte ihn eigentlich im Podcast schon im August thematisieren. Aber nur als Aufhänger, denn es gibt einen Autor in der Frankfurter Rundschau. Ich nenne nur die Zahlen. Diese Referenzjahr 2019, jetzt springen wir drei Jahre nach vorne, nehmen Corona mit und stellen fest, 54% plus diagnostizierte Essstörungen bei Mädchen, das hast du ja vorhin auch schon genannt, 15- bis 17-Jährige, 23% mehr neue Diagnostizidepression, auch wieder bei Mädchen, und 24% mehr diagnostizierte Angststörungen bei Mädchen. Also die Prävalenz ist da erstaunlich hoch. 15% mehr Adipositas-Fälle bei Jungen. Und das sind diese ökonomischen Plus, die Ernährungssachen plus gekoppelt. 62% erhöhtes Risiko auf Adipositas bei Jungen mit einem niedrigen sozioökonomischen Status. Und das ist mir hier wichtig. Das wäre also eine Verkopplung. Wir haben auch heute Morgen wieder Nachrichten bekommen, zumindest habe ich es auf Twitter gelesen, dass die schweren Corona-Fälle im Kindesalter, vor allem in sozioökonomisch schwachen Familien, also bedürftigen Familien stattfinden. Also dass wir hier eine totale Verkopplung von Armut und Lebensqualität haben. Was ja bedeutet jetzt, wenn wir so eine politisch induzierte Armut noch mal oben drauf haben, durch Inflation und auch diese Unsicherheit mit dem Krieg usw. Wie geht man jetzt eigentlich die Zukunft um? Haben wir es mit armutsbedingter Mangelernährung zu tun, um die sich der Autor Martin Rückert der Frankfurter Rundschau kümmert? Die Inflation rückt ein fast vergessenes Problem ins Licht. Mangelernährung und Hunger in Deutschland von Armutbetroffenen formieren sich zu einer Protestbewegung. Also es spiegelt sich wieder zurück. Wir erwarten natürlich auch diese Proteste. Und er greift hier Tweets eines Ilian Feuerbringer auf. Für eine gesunde Ernährung mit regelmäßig Obst und Gemüse bräuchte er 65 Euro pro Woche. Die hat er nicht. Feuerbringer, Mitte 20, aufgrund einer Behinderung arbeitsunfähig, lebt von Grundsicherung. Das sind 449 Euro im Monat für Lebensmittel und alkoholfreie Getränke. Sind davon etwas mehr als 5 Euro am Tag vorgesehen. Also rund 36 Euro die Woche. Theoretisch. Feuerbringer bedient sich vor allem bei Lebensmitteln, die kurz vor dem Ablauf stehen und zum Sonderpreis verkauft werden. In den Wochen, in denen Butter dabei ist, kaufe ich Kartoffeln dazu und habe drei bis vier abende warme Mahlzeit damit abgedeckt. Muss er Waschmittel nachkaufen, reicht es nur für Nudeln. Manchmal nimmt er eine Tüte Chips für unter 1 Euro. Die ersetzt mir zwei Mahlzeiten, wenn es sein muss. Wir haben diese Ausweichbewegung. Ich fand das damals in diesem Arbeitsfreibuch auch schon erstaunlich. Frank-Rieger und Constanze Kurz sind aus dem ehemaligen Agrarsektor, der nur noch 1% der Beschäftigten da arbeiten müssen, um uns alle zu versorgen. Krasse Automatisierung, was aber auch bedeutet, dass die da genau wissen, wir sind die Grundlage von allem. Nicht nur industriell, sondern auch in der Versorgung der Bevölkerung. Wenn irgendwo Armut droht, müssen wir darauf achten, dass die Aufbackbrötchen auch roh essbar und verdaubar sind. Weil sehr viele Leute die dann einfach für 35 Cent kaufen und sie nicht aufbacken, weil sie keinen Zugang zum Backofen haben. Und dann werden die so gegessen. Und dieser Martin Rückert hat hier auf seiner eigenen Seite, martinrückert.com, ein Interview geführt mit dem Ernährungsmediziner Hans-Conrad Bisalsky, ein emeritierter Professor der Universität Hohenheim, der sehr viel zu Mangelernährung bei Kindern in Entwicklungsländern geforscht hat. Und jetzt mal nach Deutschland schaut. Frage. Im reichen Deutschland gibt es armutsbedingte Mangelernährung und teils auch Hunger. So stellte es der wissenschaftliche Beirat des Bundesregierungen, also des Bundesernährungsministeriums, dessen Mitglied sie damals, nämlich 2020, waren in einem Gutachten fest. Was hat sich seither getan? Und dann die Antwort. Es gibt Schätzungen, dass jedes vierte Kind in Deutschland von Ernährungsarmut bedroht ist. Die Eltern also zu wenig Geld für eine gesunde Ernährung haben. Genaue Daten fehlen. Fest steht aber, Corona hat das Problem vergrößert. Und weil noch mehr alleinerziehende Mütter in Armut gerutscht sind, jetzt verschärfen Preissteigerungen die Situation weiter. Sie kommen dann so auf die Sozialpolitik und so weiter zu sprechen. Er redet über seinen Report, dass er das damals aufgeschlüsselt hat, während Corona. Dann kriegt er die Frage, wie haben verantwortliche Politiker auf den Befund zur Ernährungsarmut im Gutachten von 2020 reagiert? Jetzt machen wir alle eine Denkerpause und die Antwort lautet gar nicht.
Medial kommt es auch so gut wie nicht vor. Wir hatten ja den paritätischen, der von der Armut gesprochen hat, verrückte Zahlen vorlegte bzw. erschreckende Zahlen vorlegte. Ich sagte ja damals, das ist jetzt das Video hier von Phoenix, 10.000-mal noch nicht mal geklickt. Bei YouTube, Tilo war auch da. Hans hat noch eine Frage gestellt und noch eine Journalistin. Mehr Journalisten waren auch gar nicht da. Es waren nur zwei im Raum oder drei. Und auch da nur 8.000 oder 7.000 Aufrufe. wenn wir... Und das ist vielleicht auch was, was ich noch mal rückblickend Precht und Welzer ankreiden will. Man hätte auch mal so ein paar andere Themen noch außer diese drei Krisenthemen aufmachen können, wie wenig das so vorkommt. Und da gibt es auch ja noch mal Statistiken, die man heranführen kann, Auswertungen. Und dann muss man einfach sagen, ja, genau das, was du jetzt alles beschrieben hast, ist medial radikal unterrepräsentiert. Was nicht heißt, dass es verheimlicht wird, sondern es findet halt nicht statt, wenn man sagt, lass uns lieber heute Abend noch mal so einen kleinen Kladiatorenkampf veranstalten.
Genau, Folklore machen. Also der Bisalski sagt ja ganz klar, kostenloses Essen in Kita und Schulen, wie in Schweden, wäre absolut Pflicht. Und ja, Familien brauchen mehr Geld. Denn was machen sie als erstes? Da, wo sie ganz unflexibel umgehen, sie kaufen sich Essen. Deswegen wäre so eine Direktfinanzierung da dringend angeraten, vor allem jetzt, wo man so krass aufs Geld schauen muss. Also ein ganz schwieriges Thema, in dem in Deutschland unglaublich viel zu tun ist, würde man es nur entsprechend mal thematisieren.
Dann bleiben wir bei der DAK-Studie, denn etwas hat mich wirklich überrascht, das wusste ich überhaupt nicht. Da steht der Satz, über die Hälfte aller psychischen Erkrankungen entstehen bereits vor dem 19. Lebensjahr. Das war mir überhaupt nicht klar, wie entscheidend diese Phase ist. Und was das dann auch bedeutet, wenn wir diese Lockdowns hatten, und was das bedeutet, dass das Leid von Jugendlichen medial kaum richtig thematisiert wurde. Und ja, es sind einige Krankheiten während der Pandemie zurückgegangen. Das wird hier aufgetröset. Also zum Beispiel Atemwegserkrankungen sind natürlich gesunken in den Jahren. Klar, weil es diese Lockdowns, Masken und so weiter gab. Aber wir haben es zugleich dann mit Phänomenen zu tun, wie der von dir schon angesprochenen Depression. Und das Erstaunliche ist, wie stark das bei Mädchen zugenommen hat. Also erstmal kann man festhalten, insgesamt neben Kinder und Jugendliche das Gesundheitssystem während der Pandemie selten an Anspruch. Dies kann sowohl auf weniger Krankheitslast, als auch auf ein verändertes Nachfrageverhalten zurückzuführen sein. Das heißt, hier ist die DAK einfach unwissend darüber, warum sind die jungen Menschen weniger zum Arzt und sonst wo hin gegangen. Vielleicht hätten sie also gemusst, aber sind nicht gegangen, weil man sagte, gerade Pandemie ist gerade schlecht. Das haben wir bei Alten thematisiert, dass da Leute nicht ins Krankenhaus für Vorsorgeuntersuchungen oder so gingen, weil sie Angst hatten vor Corona. Und das kann aber bei jungen Leuten natürlich auch der Fall sein. Und diese Entwicklung der Essstörungen, also man hat das hier sich dann angeguckt von 2019 bis 2021, da gibt es eine Steigerung von 33 Prozent. Adipositas bei Jungen 30 Prozent. Anzahl der Depressionen bei Mädchen plus 11 Prozent. Angststörungen plus 21 Prozent. Also es ist extrem, wie stark Mädchen davon betroffen sind, sie beschreiben in dieser Studie nicht, warum das ist, sie versuchen das nicht zu interpretieren. Ich kann darüber auch nur spekulieren. Ich könnte mir zum einen vorstellen, dass der mediale Druck gestiegen ist auf Mädchen durch diese ganzen TikTok, Instagram und sonst was, also mit Schönheitsidealen und so etwas, dass dadurch, dass man nicht in der Schule ist, dass man mit anderen nicht so viel zusammen ist, der Abgleich nicht mehr mit der besten Freundin, die auch ihre Problemzone, sage ich mal, hat stattfindet, sondern der Abgleich vorwiegend über idealisierte Influencer und Stars stattfindet und man das zurückbindet. Das erklärt aber ja noch nicht, warum das nicht bei Jungs ganz genau so ist. Ich glaube, dass Jungs eigene Welten im Internet sich aufbauen, wo sie so Jungs-Safe-Spaces sich arrangieren. Also ich glaube, Twitch ist da so ein klassisches Beispiel, wo sie ihre Montana Black und ihre anderen Leute haben und sich darüber dann abdichten und bestärken, was auch wieder eigene, andere Probleme mit sich bringt. Ich glaube, diese Art der Community-Bildung bei Mädchen, ich bin mir unsicher, ich habe ja keine Kinder, die scheint da nicht in dieser Weise so stattzufinden. Und ich könnte mir aber noch was anderes vorstellen. Also wir haben natürlich auch noch in der Gesellschaft patriarchale Strukturen, die ja dann immer wieder erstarken, wenn ein Krisenmoment auftritt. Und das war ja zu sehen bei Frauen, dass die dann eine größere Belastung durch Corona hatten. Und dass man das auch vielleicht dann hat in der Familie, wenn jetzt plötzlich aufgepasst werden muss, irgendwelche Arbeiten übernommen werden müssen, dass dann vielleicht den Mädchen mehr aufgebürdet wird als den Jungs, weil man wieder sagt, ach ja, das ist ja hier so eine Frau, die vertritt jetzt eher die Mutterrolle, also passt die jetzt auf die Geschwister auf, als man das jetzt vielleicht dem Bruder zumutet. Das wäre jetzt meine einzige Spekulation, die ich da anstellen kann. Aber warum es tatsächlich so ist und so massiv zugenommen hat, ist natürlich unklar.
Also Essstörungen sind ja sehr häufig so ein Verlegenheits- und Vermeidungsding. Gerade bei Trost. Ich hatte noch einen so einen Text. Adipositas ist vor allem in Österreich zum Beispiel auch ein großes Problem. Und dann gab es ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es amüsant, aber es ist irgendwie so ironisch. Der Falter hatte oder der Standard hatte über einen Fall berichtet, die Hälfte aller Österreicher wiegt inzwischen zu viel. Und sie haben dann einen Text über eine 53-jährige, 1,70 m große, 86 kg schwere Krankenschwester, die beruflich adipöse Patienten auf ihrer Abnehmreise betreut, selbst aber von sich sagt, das Essen entspannt mich. Das ist ein extremer Leidensdruck, weil ich das Gefühl habe, ich kann mich nicht kontrollieren. Und mit Essen zu kompensieren, was man sich ansonsten gerne wünscht, vor allem Geselligkeit, ist ein ganz großes Problem. Oder auch Trost und Lob. Also das in Kindheitstagen alle guten Ereignisse immer damit gekürt werden, dass man sich jetzt aber was verdient hat. Und dann haut man sich in irgendwelche Süßigkeiten rein oder so oder verwende das eben auch wirklich so als das lobende Element, was den Körper auf die falsche Spur führt, weil man dann diese etwas zufriedenen Momente immer mit Essen verknüpft. Und genau dasselbe sehen wir ja auch bei diesen, oder was heißt dasselbe, aber so ein Äquivalent, wenn Geselligkeit ausfällt, gerade während Corona und so weiter, greift man zu seinem Smartphone und nutzt diese parasozialen Gelegenheiten, die sich da bieten. Also man folgt irgendwelchen Streams, guckt irgendwie ihm zu, scrollt so durch YouTube, Instagram und merkt gar nicht, dass man sein Gehirn gerade veralbert, dass es keine echte Sozialität ist, dass Oxyzuzin aussortiert und Dopamin einsortiert wurde. Und dann baut sich das einfach als psychische Schieflage auf, die dann hoffentlich irgendwann auch als solche diagnostiziert wird, was ja wieder dazu führt, nicht nur, wenn man dann stationär aufgegriffen wird, in harten Fällen, sondern dass auch in ambulanten Therapiesituationen als allerersteres Mal das Smartphone aus dem Leben aussortiert wird. Also ganz konkret, stationäre Aufnahme, deutschlandweit, Smartphone weg. Man kriegt es noch für eine Viertelstunde am Tag, aber das ist dann erstmal weg. Und da muss man erstmal mit sich selber wieder klarkommen und findet dann viel schneller wieder kommunikativen Anschluss. Was auch heißt, das muss man dann erstmal lernen, mit jemandem zu tun zu haben, der doppelte Kontingenz bedeutet. Man weiß nicht genau, was der andere mitbringt in die Situation. Und man kann nicht einfach weiterscrollen. Diese Konfrontation mit Sozialität ist das allererste, was man da wieder lernt. In der Ansicht würde ich sagen, bei solchen psychischen Auffälligkeiten fehlt als allererstes Mal ein Mitmensch oder irgendeine soziale Umgebung, die wirklich einen relevanten Unterschied macht in der Wahrnehmung, im Denken und so weiter. In der Ansicht sind das ganz große Einsamkeitswerte, die man über Bande bei solchen Zahlen kriegt.
Ganz kurz noch will ich darauf hinweisen, das waren jetzt Zahlen aus NRW. Da ist diese Studie durchgeführt worden. Aber zum Teil gibt es dann auch Vergleiche mit Zahlen aus dem Bund. Und die sehen dann sehr ähnlich aus. Da heißt es beispielsweise, Angststörungen zeigen sowohl im Bundesdurchschnitt als auch in NRW einen hinsichtlich Depressions- Neudiagnosen vergleichbaren Trend. Die Zahlen sind für Jungen leicht rückläufig. Bei Mädchen zeigen sich wiederum während der Pandemie konstante bis leicht steigende Neuerkrankungsraten und dann auch entsprechend stärkere Neuerkrankungsrate bei den schon beschriebenen Phänomenen wie Essstörungen. Also da heißt es zum Beispiel, die Häufigkeit der ärztlich diagnostizierter behandelter Essstörung ist während der Pandemie in NRW gestiegen. Gegenüber 2019 wurden in 2021 20% mehr Jugendliche im Alter von 15 bis 17 Jahren erstmalig aufgrund von Anorexie oder Bulimie ärztlich behandelt. Bei Kindern im Alter von 10 bis 14 Jahren sind 12% mehr neu diagnostizierte Fälle in 2021 gegenüber 2019 dokumentiert. Und da sprechen wir von noch ganz jungen Menschen, also 10 bis 14 Jahren. Eine Studie, die nochmal zeigt, wie dramatisch die Lage bei den Jugendlichen ist und eigentlich dazu aufruft, dass dies mehr repräsentiert sein müsste.
Ja, Nordrhein-Westfalen ist ja nicht nur eine Stichprobe, sondern für sich schon eine Grundgesamtheit.
Genau.
In deren Sicht sind das ganz drastische Werte. Viel schlimmer, was große Zahlen und Probleme angeht. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, dass wir so wenig darüber informiert werden. Aber in den Blättern wurden vier Seiten über Pakistan gesprochen. Von vier Autoren und Autorinnen. Amira Adil, Barira Hanif, Hama Yun Khan. Das klingt schon sehr pakistanisch. Und Nils Hegewisch, vielleicht noch jemand, der da beigesteuert hat. Sie beginnen mit einem Zitat. Ich lese es vor und wir können alle kurz rätseln. Wer hat es gesagt? Ein Klima gemetzelt, dieses Ausmaß habe ich noch nie gesehen. Es ist von Antonio Guterres, also unserem UN-Generalsekretär. Er war in Pakistan Mitte September und hat sich um internationale Unterstützung gekümmert. Das wahre Ausmaß der Katastrophe, schreiben die Autoren, wird erst in wenigen Wochen bekannt sein. Aber rund ein Drittel des Landes steht nach Angaben der pakistanischen Katastrophenschutzbehörde seit Wochen unter Wasser. Satellitenbilder zeigen einen gigantischen Binnensee, der sich infolge der Überflutung im Süden Pakistans gebildet hat und dessen Pegel nur langsam sinkt. Mehr als 1400 Menschen sind bislang in den Fluten gestorben. 17 Millionen Häuser wurden zerstört. Und mindestens 35 Millionen der 230 Millionen Einwohner Pakistan sind direkt betroffen. Also das ist wirklich biblisches Ausmaß. Es ist unglaublich. Insbesondere ist ein Gebiet betroffen, das Sint heißt, wo auch sehr viel Landwirtschaft und so weiter stattfindet. Und die Orte kommen einfach wieder nicht zurück zur Realität, weil zum einen ist das Wasser noch da und zum anderen hat es die Hilfe nicht besonders leicht dahin. Man hat es jetzt schon mit Mückenschwärmen zu tun und natürlich auch mit verschmutztem Wasser. Ein Drittel der pakistanischen Lebensmittel werden da in Sint produziert. Es fällt also für 70 Millionen oder so oder 230 Millionen Menschen Ernährung aus. Sollte das Wasser nicht bis zur wichtigen Herbst-Aussaat von Weizen abgeflossen sein, wäre die Ernährungssicherheit des ganzen Landes bedroht. Die Hälfte der Baumwollernte ist verloren gegangen. Die Verluste an Vieh wird in Millionen Stückzahlen gemessen. 12.000 km Straße sind zerstört, 390 Brücken. Wir haben es also mit einer Katastrophe zu tun, die obendrein zur Unzeit kommt. Denn die Regierung ist da kurz, also ist erst neu, liegt im Dauerklinch mit der Opposition. Und auch diese wichtige Stelle des Armee-Chefs wird turnusmäßig demnächst neu besetzt. Also hier haben wir ganz viele Unsicherheiten. Was bedeutet, wir haben es mit einer Naturkatastrophe zu tun und kulturell mit Populismus und schmutzigen Tricks. Niemand kann sich auf irgendwas verlassen. Die Regierung geht derzeit von 30 Milliarden Dollar Schaden aus. Da denken wir so ein bisschen, da ist ja gerade mal ein A-Tal. Aber nee, das sind halt so im Pakistanischen Rahmen. Deutschland möchte 25 Millionen bei Steuern, also nicht mal ein Promille. Das ist so lächerlich, ich verstehe sowas überhaupt nicht. Geld allein wird aber die Zukunfts-Pakistans nicht sichern. Laut dem IPCC-Bericht von 2021 ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines extremen Niederschlagsereignisses in Pakistan mittlerweile 1,3 Mal höher und dabei 6,7% intensiver als im Jahr 1900. Denken wir, das klingt aber nicht sehr viel. 6,7% intensiver und 1,3 Mal höher in der Wahrscheinlichkeit. Aber das, was jetzt passierte, fand im Rahmen dieser Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung statt. Und wenn man dann in die Zukunft schaut, sollten die durchschnittlichen globalen Temperaturen wirklich um 4 Grad ansteigen, werden solche Ereignisse mit einer 2,7 Mal höheren Wahrscheinlichkeit, also nicht nur 1,3, sondern 2,7, und statt 6,7% intensiver 30% intensiver. Also diese Art von Hochwasser nur im Faktor 3 nochmal obendrauf. Droht da jetzt einfach. Und man weiß nicht genau wann. Irgendwann bis Ende des Jahrhunderts ist es halt so ein flächendeckendes Phänomen. Wir haben es also beim Klimawandel, beim Blick auf Pakistan, mit einem Bedrohungs-Multiplikator zu tun, der nachdem die Natur des Landes einmal umgeworfen wurde, wirklich komplette kulturellen Kahlschlag nach sich zieht, bis hin zu nicht mehr politisch handlungsfähig und das bei NATO macht. Also in deren Sicht auch ganz viel in Dimension. Armut wird die neue Normalität, auf die man sich jetzt schon einstellen sollte. Und bei der Bekämpfung des Klimawandels sagen die Autoren, ne, wir haben es jetzt wirklich nur noch mit der Bewältigung seiner Folgen zu tun. Seit April ist die neue Regierung im Amt. Sie wird von der Opposition mit Vorwürfen überzogen. Man kriegt gerade gar nichts hin. Dort alle werden im Stich gelassen. In der aktuellen Katastrophe sind es daher vor allem die zahllos freiwilligen Helfer vor Ort, ziel- gewässer- schliche Organisation und die großen Hilfsgemeinschaften in der Bevölkerung, die die Not zumindest einiger Betroffener lindert. Also es ist quasi nur noch Zivilgesellschaft vor Ort übrig geblieben. Diesen Bemühungen mangelt es aber, oh Wunder, an Koordination. Jetzt müsste man einiges machen. Wieder Aufforstungen, Einrichtungen von Überschwemmungsgebieten. Als ich das so las, dachte ich mir, man bräuchte jetzt hier so ein niederländisches Programm der letzten Jahrhunderte, aber innerhalb von wenigen Jahren, um dann irgendwie die nächste Flut dazu verhindern, was natürlich nicht gelingen wird. Und der größte Handlungsbedarf liegt in der Landwirtschaft. Nun ist es so, im Ranking des German Marshall Funds ist Pakistan bei den, ist von Klimawandelfolgen betroffen, auf Platz acht. Und wir wissen, Deutschland und so liegt da auf Top drei. Wir haben es also hier mit einem Land zu tun, in dem einfach passiert, was auch hierzulande passiert, Atal und so, nur die können halt mit den Folgen nicht umgehen. Während wir halt noch irgendwie, es dauert auch ewig, wir sehen das ja, wir haben auch keine Handwerker, die es leisten können. Und die Gelder werden auch bis heute nicht so richtig ausgezahlt. Wir sind noch ein reiches Land, aber das haben wir doch alle Länder jetzt damit zu tun. Und das will ich nochmal spiegeln mit einem anderen Text, den hat David Wallace Wells auf Twitter geteilt. Wir kennen ihn als Autor der unbewohnbaren Erde. Es geht um eine volkswirtschaftliche Klimaänderungsabschätzung für Kanada. Und jetzt nochmal nur die Zahlen. 2025 erwartet man einen volkswirtschaftlichen Verlust von 25 Milliarden Dollar, was bedeutet, 50% des erwarteten Wachstums geht einfach verloren. Also wirklich die Halbierung des Wirtschaftswachstums bei 25 Milliarden. Für die Jahre danach erwartet man jährlich 78 bis 101 Milliarden, die einfach rausgerechnet werden bis Mitte des Jahrhunderts. Und Ende des Jahrhunderts wird hier projiziert 391 bis 865 Milliarden Dollar.
Kannst du das nochmal sagen?
Also jetzt wird mit 25 Milliarden aktuell gerechnet, was eine Halbierung des Wirtschaftswachstums bedeutet. Und die höchsten Prognosen für Ende des Jahrhunderts sind 865. Statt 25. Also wir haben es mit einer absoluten Katastrophe, mit einer vorausgesagten Zerstörung der kanadischen Volkswirtschaft zu tun durch Klimawandel. Und es betrifft alle Länder der Welt. Man muss es nur mal ausrechnen, was die Projektionen wirklich sind.
Also es ist unglaublich. 2023 können wir dann wieder, nachdem alle Krisen beseitigt und besiegt sind, zur Schuldenbremse zurück.
Wir brauchen so eine Rechnung mal für Deutschland. Ich glaube, einige würden hier aus allen Wolken fallen.
Das haben wir ja im Ahrtal gesehen. Ich meine, wenn da lauter Häuser stehen, die eine halbe Million wert sind, dann wird halt sehr viel Wert sehr schnell vernichtet.
Wird einfach vernichtet, genau. Und wenn der Wert von Grund und Boden nicht vorhanden ist, also wenn die Verbriefung des Eigentums und die Umwindung in Geld auf der Ebene scheitert, kann man darauf nichts aufbauen. Da gibt es dann keine Innovation, Industrie, irgendwas mit, ja, wir haben ja noch Maschinenbau oder sowas. Nee, ist dann einfach nicht mehr, sondern das ist alles gekoppelt. Deswegen auch diese ganz wichtige Argumentation, wenn hier mal ein Atomkraftwert explodiert, ist es vorbei. Dann ist nicht nur das Grund- und Boden-Land einfach nichts mehr wert, sondern dann kann auch darauf nichts mehr aufgebaut werden. Dann braucht die Volkswirtschaft ein neues Fundament und das finden wir so schnell nicht. Der in Sicht ganz dramatische Zahlen.
Blicken wir nach China. Das ist jetzt ein Text von, der veröffentlicht wurde, bei Substack von einer Person, die unter Pseudonym schreibt, offenbar sehr gute Verbindungen zur chinesischen KP hat oder zumindest an Informationen rankommt. Ich habe aber nachgeprüft, es gibt diese Person wohl tatsächlich, also die Washington Post hat sich wohl auch mit dieser Person mal getroffen, aber es gibt jedenfalls einen Text von N.S.Lions und da geht es um China und das China besessen ist von Essen, von Lagerungen und zwar heißt es da, China ist besessen von der Ernährungssicherheit. Vielleicht ist Ihnen gar nicht klar, wie besessen China davon ist. Es wird erwartet, dass China mit seinen 20% der Weltbevölkerung bis Ende des Jahres etwa 65% des weltweiten Mais und 53% des weltweiten Weizens angehäuft und eingelagert haben wird. Das ist ja erstmal sehr eigenartig und natürlich will der Autor wissen, was passiert da. Für die chinesische Führung ist es nicht ausreichend. Im Juni erließ der chinesische Staatsrat sofort Maßnahmen, um die Nahrungsmittelversorgung weiter zu sichern und die Preise zu senken. Er versprach umfangreiche Agrarsubventionen und massive Investitionen in die Logistik und drängte die lokalen Regierungen noch größere staatliche Getreidereserven anzulegen. Premierminister Li Keqiang, Chinas Nummer 2, gab zu Protokoll, dass jede Regierungsebene daran arbeiten müsse, die landwirtschaftlichen Erträge in diesem Jahr zu maximieren und dass die Beamten, die dies nicht tun, zur Verantwortung gezogen werden. Man hat bei Xi 2020 schon ganz klar diesen Shift hin zum Thema Nahrung erleben können. Er nannte das im August Operation Leere Teller. Er sagte, da müssen wir immer aufpassen. Man muss immer für Lebensmittelsicherheit sorgen. Die Lebensmittelsicherheit sei die Voraussetzung für die nationale Sicherheit. Die Schutzmaßnahmen zur strikten Einhaltung einer roten Linie von 120 Millionen Hektar Mindestanbaufläche wurden dann auch verstärkt. Es gab im Zuge der Xi-Regierung einige Maßnahmen, womit klargemacht werden sollte, dass man zu einer gewissen Nahrungssouveränität kommt. Im Dezember 2021 startete China, so heißt es hier, ehrgeizige Pläne, um Ackerflächen für den Anbau von Sojabohnen zur Verfügung zu stellen. Eine Kulturpflanze, die das Land nach dem Beitritt zur WTO 2001 fast vollständig aufgegeben hatte, mit dem Ziel, die Produktion in den nächsten Jahren vier Jahre um 40 Prozent zu steigern, unter anderem durch den erstmaligen Einsatz von im Inland gentechnisch veränderten Pflanzen. Xi sagte, die Reisschüssel des chinesischen Volkes muss jederzeit fest in den eigenen Händen gehalten werden. Diese Reisschüssel muss hauptsächlich chinesisches Getreide enthalten. Die chinesische Regierung ist deshalb auch immer bemüht, die Preise stabil zu halten. Da mischt sich der Staat ja ganz stark in Preise ein. Die Ökonomin Isabella Weber hat ja hergeleitet, wie lange diese Tradition der Preiskontrollen schon existiert. Und da gehen wir wirklich ins antike China zurück, um das nachzuvollziehen. Aber warum jetzt all diese Maßnahmen? Und in dem Text heißt es jetzt, ein Anhaltspunkt ist ein Bericht der chinesischen Geheimdienste des Ministeriums für öffentliche Sicherheit und des Ministeriums für Staatssicherheit, der nach Angaben der japanischen Zeitung Nikkei im April Schockwellen durch den Staatsrat das chinesische Kabinett schickte. Der Bericht, in dem Sanktionen, Blockaden und andere Maßnahmen analysiert wurden, die die Vereinigten Staaten und ihre Verbündeten als Reaktion auf eine chinesische Invasion in Taiwan ergreifen könnten, kam zu dem Schluss, dass China zumindest einen kritischen nationalen Schwachpunkt hat. Es besteht ein hohes Risiko, dass es zu einer Lebensmittelkrise kommt, warnte der Bericht. Und dadurch wurde man offenbar aufgeschreckt und versucht jetzt, diese Nahrungssouveränität zu erreichen. Man macht Flächenausbau. Chinas Weißenproduktion pro Hektar ist 50% höher als die in den Vereinigten Staaten. Man erreicht aber jetzt natürlich nicht die Effizienz, wie z.B. die Niederlanden es geschafft haben. Dennoch ist China stark auf Importe angewiesen, um den Nahrungsmittelbedarf zu decken. Trotz all den Maßnahmen. Das Defizit von 5% macht China immer noch zu einem der größten Weizen-Importeure der Welt. Und obwohl China nur 10% seines Maisbedarfs importiert, ist es immer noch der größte Mais-Importeur der Welt. Also das ist eigentlich logisch, aber wenn man es nochmal so hört, nur 10%… Ja, genau. Da merkt man dann, was das eigentlich für geopolitische Verwerfungen sind. Also die brauchen nur 10% des Maisbedarfs zu importieren. Da würde man sagen, ja, das ist doch prima. Und da sagt man aber klar, wenn die ja über eine Milliarde sind, dann ist das immer noch so, dass China der größte Mais-Importeur ist. Am wichtigsten ist, dass China heißt es hier, jährlich fast 120 Millionen Tonnen Soja-Bohnen verbraucht. Fast so viele wie die gesamte US-Soja-Bohnen-Ernte. Davon aber mehr als 100 Millionen Tonnen importieren muss, was etwa 62% aller international gehandelten Soja-Bohnen entspricht. Etwa 30% dieser Importe kommen aus, die Vereinigten Staaten. Das ist für China die wichtigste, wie sie heißt, Proteinquelle. Es heißt dann so schön im Vergleich mit Russland, China ist in gewisser Weise das Gegenteil von Russland. Es ist ein riesiger Importeur von Energie, Lebensmitteln und anderen Rohstoffen, der all diese Ressourcen aufnimmt und einen Großteil der Industrieprodukte der Welt aus dem Land presst. Dadurch ist das Land weit weniger autark. Obwohl es für die Weltwirtschaft sehr viel wichtiger ist. Kurz gesagt, wenn China wegen Taiwan oder einer anderen Frage in einen Krieg mit den USA eintreten würde, wären Millionen von Chinesen in kürzester Zeit vom Hungertod bedroht. Ungeachtet des Schadens, den eine Abtrennung Chinas von der Weltwirtschaft auch für seine Feinde bedeuten würde. Peking muss dieses Problem lösen, bevor es solche Abenteuer wagen kann. Das heißt, man versucht jetzt erst einmal, eine Sicherheit herzustellen. Man wird sich wahrscheinlich jetzt auch sehr genau angucken, was passiert eigentlich mit den Sanktionsregimen und wie könnte das aussehen? Und was ist, wenn wir dann quasi ausgehungert werden? Aber bis dahin kann man sagen, wird vermutlich nicht so viel passieren. Er geht dann noch darauf ein, dass die Ernährungssicherheit auch im Westen wichtiger wird. Das heißt, die chinesische Führung scheint also schon vor einigen Jahren die gleiche harte Wahrheit erkannt zu haben, die auch den europäischen Politikern erst jetzt bewusst wird. Also wie problematisch diese Abhängigkeit an den Märkten ist. Es wird dann noch Macron zitiert. Vielleicht hat er recht, das Zeitalter des Überflusses und des leichten Lebens ist wahrscheinlich vorbei, zumindest für ein oder drei Jahrzehnte. China sieht das jedenfalls so und ist entschlossen, sich auf ein Leben in dieser neuen Welt einzustellen. Unruhigend ist, dass so viele unserer führenden Politiker im Westen dies offensichtlich immer noch nicht sind. Ja, damit endet dieser Text, der uns doch mal einige große Zahlen an die Hand gibt, mit denen man auch Geopolitik betrachten kann.
Also ich meine, Missernten, die dieses Jahr erwartet werden, Spanien, Olivenernte, schwerste Dürre ever, die man da registriert, Pakistan, Flutkatastrophe, wie eben angesprochen, und der Yangtzeh, tiefster Pegelstand seit 150 Jahren. Diese ganzen Reisbauflächen funktionieren alle gerade gar nicht mehr und fallen erwartbar aus. Es gibt hier ein sehr gutes Textangebot von Philipp Kollhöfer, dachte ich, der hat nämlich bald hier online über. Darum wird es nichts mit Putins, mit Russlands Imperium geschrieben. Es geht um Überbevölkerung und ja, ist es denn Überbevölkerung, also in Anführungszeichen, und die Wirklichkeit und die Menschheit und so weiter. Und dann, das wird auch Vladimir Putin zum Problem. Dann behandelt der Text das aber gar nicht, sondern macht so einen ganz groben Blick über die alten Republik, wie die demografische Lage so ist, und kommt dann nur ganz kurz darauf zu sprechen. Ich nenne aber mal die Zahlen. In Russland wurden in den 15 Jahren 76 bis 91, also die letzten 15 Jahre Sowjetherrschaft, 36 Millionen Kinder geboren. Danach, Jahre 92 bis 2007, nur noch 22,3. Also von jetzt auf gleich, von 36 auf 22. Was eben bedeutet, die Kinderzahl pro Frau ist von 2,01 auf 1,5 abgerutscht. Was bedeutet, 2007 ist ja auch schon wieder eine Weile her. Die sind ja schon fast im Soldatenalter, nämlich gerade 15 und noch drei Jahre, dann können sie auch schon mitkämpfen. Es fehlen hier Kämpfer. Also Putin führt jedenfalls keinen Krieg gerade um Lebensraum für irgendwen, sondern es ist genau das Gegenteil und vielleicht auch erstmalig. Im Zeitraum von 1990 bis 2014 hat die Bevölkerung des Riesenlandes um 3,7 Millionen Menschen abgenommen, obwohl im gleichen Zeitraum 9 Millionen Menschen eingewandert sind. Also da sieht man, das ist ein bisschen wie in Deutschland. Wir denken so, wenn man gerade vom Statistischen Bundesamt wieder gehört, erstmalig in Deutschland 84 Millionen Menschen. Wie kann denn das sein? Das sind halt diese Migrationsströme, die dann noch gibt. Also wir haben es hier mit einer Schieflage zu tun. Und dann zum gleichen Thema ein viel besseres Textangebot im Standard von Ivan Krastev. Der schreibt so ein bisschen normativ. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht wurde es auch so ein bisschen appellativ übersetzt im Tonfall oder so.
Aber der ist ja auch, glaube ich, das ist schon seine normative Art.
Also genau, man muss so ein bisschen runterdimmen, glaube ich, wenn man ihn referiert. Osteuropa-Experte, Gastkommentar, na gut, da lässt man das so ein bisschen durchgehen. Putins Obsession in Sachen Demografie lassen uns am besten verstehen, warum dieser Schritt ein Zeichen der Schwäche ist und warum der russische Präsident so lange damit zögerte. Nämlich mit der Mobilmachung, zu der er sich jetzt durchgerogen hat. Die Ukraine bringt nicht genügend mitlamentärische Stärke mit. Man denkt sich so, klar, Precht hat gedacht, die Russen schaffen das schon. Aber sie schaffen es nicht. Und jetzt müssen sie diese Mobilmachung machen. Was ja für die demografische Schieflage bedeutet. Putin treibt ja auch den eigenen Nachwuchs aus dem Land. Wir haben ja bei der New York Times ganz viele Beispiele gehört im The Daily, dass die Leute hören, es gibt eine Mobilmachung. Dann steige ich jetzt ins Auto und fahre nicht nach Hause, sondern direkt aus dem Land raus. Also Leute haben dann einfach den kürzesten Weg zur Flucht gesucht. Wir diskutieren jetzt, ob wir sie aufnehmen oder nicht. Natürlich müssen wir sie aufnehmen. Und es stellt sich die Frage, warum sich der Kreml weiterhin gegen die Mobilmachung so sträubte, sehend, dass sie so den Krieg verlieren. Und jetzt geht Putin nämlich gerade die härteste Wette überhaupt ein, ob man es denn mit der Mobilmachung schafft. Denn alle demografischen Kalkulationen, die dazu ablaufen, man versteht das ja gar nicht. Das ist ja wirklich, ich sage auch immer, das ist alles für alle Pionierarbeit. Aber in deren Sicht ist diese Art der Kriegsorganisation auch wirkliche Pionierarbeit jetzt für Putin. Da geht jetzt einfach Wetten ein, dass es irgendwie hinhaut.
Das ist ja auch wieder sowas, dass wir bei Kriegen eigentlich immer über Demografie reden müssen. Das ist bei diesem Film im Westen nichts Neues. Da ist dann ein von David Striesow gespielter General, der immer noch an den Sieg glaubt und der dann aber gesagt bekommt, es sterben jetzt Zehntausende täglich hier auf den verletzten Deutschen. Wir haben bald keine Leute mehr. Und dann kommt von ihm der Satz, ja, wir müssen nur noch bis nächstes Jahr durchhalten. Dann kommt der neue Jahrgang. Also dann hat man wieder neue, die man verschleißen kann.
Genau. Und das diskutieren wir hier nach Corona, wo Russland eine Übersterblichkeit von einer Million verzeichnete. Insofern kämpft Russland wahrscheinlich zum ersten Mal in seiner Militärgeschichte als demografisch gefährdete Nation, die es sich nicht leisten kann, Soldaten zu verlieren, weil man einfach keinen Ersatz mehr findet. Dass die Angst vor dem demografischen Niedergang eine Obsession des russischen Präsidenten ist, wissen wir schon seit Längerem. Er hat in einem Video vom 21. September 2021 eine Prognose wiederholt, die damals abgegeben wurde des russischen Chemikers Dimitri Mendeliev, wer auch immer das ist. Das nämlich bis zum Jahr 2001 mehr als 500 Millionen Einwohner auf russischem Gebiet leben. Wir wissen heute, es sind weniger als 150 Millionen geworden. Darin liegt eine ganz enttäuschende Diskrepanz. Die Schuld dafür gibt der zornige Putin, wie er steht, der bolschewistischen Revolution. Also es steckt in seinem Kopf auch als Ideologie irgendwo drinnen, was wir schon längst ausgetrieben haben. Bei uns, da will man ja gar nicht mehr über sowas reden, spätestens seit Euthanasieprogramm und so, was einfach Anzahl an Bevölkerungen und so weiter angibt. Der eklatante Bedarf an Menschen ist ein plausibler Grund dafür, dass Russland im Krieg in der Ukraine in großem Umfang Kinder, insbesondere Waisen, verschleppt hat. Im Juli dieses Jahres hat US-Außenminister Antony Blinken Russland vorgeworfen, es habe schätzungsweise 900.000 mit 1,6 Millionen ukrainische Bürger, darunter 260.000 Kinder, gewaltsam aus ihrer Heimat nach Russland deportiert. Als Putin also dieses, wir geben euch sichere Korridore, die führen aber nicht nach Westen, wo ihr hin wollt, sondern wenn schon, dann nur zu uns ins Land. Es gab also ganz große Bemühungen schon, die Ukraine einfach demografisch auszuplündern. Hab ich bisher noch nie so gelesen, hier wurden diese Zahlen genannt. Und wenn Antony Blinken das zum Thema macht, ist also klar, auch die amerikanische Politik weiß darüber Bescheid. Naja, jetzt ist also die Frage, diese Mobilmachung verliert er jetzt eine ganze Generation, einfach auch als politische Wählerschaft sozusagen, Anhängerschaft, die eben dieses Theater nicht mehr mitmacht. Und ich würde sagen, ja, vielleicht sollten wir auch in der Versachlichung der Debatte mal mehr auf solche Kettenziffern achten, um dann auch einzuschätzen, was da so entschieden und diskutiert wird im politischen Russland, soweit wir das mitbekommen. Es ist jedenfalls ein ganz großes Drama auf allen Ebenen.
Obwohl das auch die Welt nicht unbedingt sicherer machen muss, denn Putin kann ja dann gerade auf solche Waffen zurückgreifen, für die man nicht besonders viele Leute braucht.
Das ist auch wieder ein großes Thema. Ich wollte jetzt nicht diesen einen Text mitbringen, wo dieses russische U-Boot beschrieben wird, das 180 Meter Länge vorne alles rausgenommen, was irgendwie Platz braucht, um diese Poseidon-Atomraketen einzubauen. Mit denen man beispielsweise, darüber lachen die dann auch in russischen Fernsehsendern, Atomraketen in den Erdboden vor einer Küste schießt und damit eine nuklear verstrahlte Flutwelle auslöst, die ganz England überschwappen könnte. Also solche Doomsday-Waffen und so, wie man es ansonsten nur aus Filmen kennt. Das sind ganz gruselige Sachen. Da muss man ehrlich sagen, ist dein Hinweis nicht ganz verkehrt. Was ist, wenn ihm die Soldaten ausgehen, aber er noch ganz schön viele so krasse Waffen zur Verfügung hat? Hört der Krieg dann einfach auf, weil keine Soldaten mehr da sind? Oder wird anders gekämpft? In der Hinsicht ist das alles ziemlich heikel.
Ja, und deswegen ist es auch berechtigt, wenn Leute Angst haben und diese auch formulieren. Also, dass man jetzt wieder diesen Zirkus, gut, wir kommen bald schon wieder zu Aufbrechen und Weltsdruck, aber dass man jetzt wieder diesen Zirkus abfährt und alle desavoieren will, die Angst haben vor der nuklearen Bedrohung, da muss ich wirklich sagen, wenn man auf diesem Niveau angekommen ist, dann muss man aber generell schon fragen, ob einem überhaupt noch was gelegen ist an der Welt oder ob man jetzt einfach nur noch am Ende Recht behalten möchte. Nun blicken wir zu etwas ebenso Unerfreulichem. Blicken wir nach Brasilien. Wir erleben da ja Wahlen, aber wir wollen jetzt gar nicht auf die konkreten Ergebnisse so was eingehen, sondern ich will einen Text vorstellen von Alex Rochuli, der heißt The Self-Help-Guru Who Conquered Brazil. Und in diesem Text heißt es, Brasilien hat sich immer weiter von seinen ausländischen Klischees entfernt. Von Samba und Bossa Nova, sinnlichen Küstenstätten, Katholizismus, Herzlichkeit und Kollektivismus. Das Brasilien, das den Bolsonaroismus hervorgebracht hat, ist ein individualisiertes Land, in dem das evangelische Christentum, also das evangelikale Christentum, das populäre Unternehmertum und die Flucht aus der Gesellschaft einige der bestimmenden Merkmale sind. Wenn man Brasilien verstehen will, sagt er, dann muss man sich nicht Lula ansehen und Jair Bolsonaro. Das führt uns nicht weiter. Er sagt, der beste Weg, das neue Brasilien zu verstehen und die Funktionsweise der brasilianischen Politik zu beleuchten, könnte daran bestehen, Bolsonaro und Lula beiseite zu lassen und einen anderen Kandidaten zu untersuchen. Einen Lebensberater und selbsternannten Theologen, der aufgrund von Parteiverwicklung keine legale Kandidatur hat. Pablo Marçal, 35, hat 4 Millionen Follower in den sozialen Medien, verkauft einen umstrittenen Live-Coaching-Kurs mit dem Titel Das schlimmste Jahr deines Lebens und ist vor allem dafür bekannt, dass er eine Gruppe einer schlecht vorbereiteten Tracking-Tour im Dienste der mentalen Entblockierung fast in den Tod geführt hat. In diesem Jahr schlägt der Marketing- und Politikunternehmer vor, die Nation zu entblockieren. Und zwar weder von rechts noch von links, sondern von oben. Und dieser Marçal ist einer, der gegen beide Kandidaten wettert. Und er sagt ganz klar, so eine Wahl, das ist wie eine Wahl eines Produkts. Also ist da auch in so einem Friedmenschen Modell drin und sagt, gut, ihr könnt ein Fiat haben, das ist Lula, oder ihr könnt einen VW haben, das ist Bolsonaro. Aber geht doch mal weiter, ich biete euch hier, nicht nur ein Mercedes oder BMW, sondern gleich einen McLaren für drei Millionen an, das bin ich. Und das solltet ihr auch erkennen, dass ihr euch das gönnen müsst. Es ist diese Mischung aus Opportunismus, Individualismus und Angeberei, sagt Hotshuli, die so erfolgreich ist. Er ist ein Geschäftsmann, der Millionen besitzt. Er ist jemand, der mit diesem Life-Coaching sehr, sehr viel Geld verdient. Und dazu heißt es, dass er so eine Methode entwickelt hat, die die emotionale Intelligenz stärken soll. Dann wird das auf Grundlage von neurolinguistischem Programmieren gemacht. Also wie man über Sprache versucht, andere Leute zu manipulieren. Das geht ja bis hin in diese Pick-up-Art-Szene hinein. Es soll darum gehen, das Gehirn frei zu setzen, eine Identitätsaktivierung, Klärung der Ziele. Hier nochmal die Empfehlung. Aktuell läuft der Film Don't Worry, Darling im Kino. Da kann man das auch dann nochmal als Dystopie vorgeführt bekommen. Dazu mischt er eine Prise evangelikales Christentum. Seine Sitzungen zum mentalen Entriegeln haben Momente, die einem Exorzismus ähneln, allerdings im Dienste des beruflichen Fortkommens. Zitat, die Leute werden sie kritisieren. Sagen sie ihnen im Namen Jesu, dass sie sich selbst ficken können. Dröhnt er, als er eingeladen wurde, in der Glaubensgemeinschaft zu sprechen. Er wurde mit einer Mischung aus Schock, Heiterkeit und Applaus empfangen. Also das ist ja so ein Modell, das wir auch von deutschen Coaches kennen, dass sie ganz drastisch auftreten, eigentlich zu laut, zu vulgär sind, aber irgendwie sagt man, naja gut, also wenn die so überzeugt sind und das so aus sich herausschreien, da muss schon was dran sein. In gewisser Weise schließt sich mit all dem, also dieser, äh, Ziehung der emotionalen Register, mit der Verbindung des neokarismatischen Christentums, da schließt sich in gewisser Maße, sagt, oh, Schuli, ein Kreis. Die Neopfingsbewegung ist aus den New-Age-Milieus der 60er Jahre hervorgegangen. Das Gleiche gilt für die Lebensberatung. Laut Silas Guierro, Professor an der Perpsischen Katholischen Universität in Sao Paulo, ist das Live-Coaching aus einer New-Age-Vision entstanden, in der persönliche Autonomie durch die Entwicklung individueller Spiritualität erreicht werden kann.
Jetzt machen sich Evangelikale in Brasilien, aber auch, die Techniken und Stile des Live-Coachings für ihre Arbeit zu eigen. Sie verbinden Seelsorge, persönliche Beratung und Psychotherapie mit charismatischem Christentum, um ihren Anhängern zu helfen, sowohl mit religiösen Anforderungen, als auch mit den Herausforderungen des heutigen Lebens umzugehen. Die Gesamtzahl der Evangelikalen steigt. Der Bevölkerungsanteil der Evangelikalen, das war noch 1980 bei 7%. Inzwischen sind wir bei 31%. Und die Schätzung ist, dass bis 2030 die Katholiken in Brasilien in einer Minderheit sein werden. Und hier wieder Wirtschaftsleistung. Brasilianische Forscher haben herausgefunden, dass für jeden Rückgang des BIP des Landes um 1% die Zahl der Evangelikalen um 0,8% steigt. Also je schlechter es dem Land geht, desto mehr Evangelikale kommen. Wir werden also dann bald ein postkatholisches Brasilien erleben. Diese Evangelikalen interessieren sich natürlich nicht für Grundlagentexte der evangelischen Kirchen. Einer wird dann hier zitiert, der sagt, diese Leute lesen nicht Luther, sondern Biografien von Elon Musk. Vor dem Hintergrund eines weit verbreiteten und tiefen Misstrauens gegenüber Institutionen lehnen die neupfingstlichen Kirchen auch traditionelle Autoritäten ab, seien es Priester oder Politiker, also nur wer dann jeweils über das Charisma verfügt, der ist dann der entscheidende. Der Marsal, um nochmal auf den zurückzukommen, hält dann große Reden, sagt dann, stellen sie sich vor, sie wären ein Baby, das aus einer königlichen Familie im Schloss weggenommen und in eine arme Familie gegeben wird. Aber wenn du heranwächst, siehst du zum Schloss hinauf und denkst, da gehöre ich hin. Dieses Gefühl will er vermitteln und die Sache ist jetzt, der wird jetzt wohl nicht Präsident, aber die anderen haben es alle längst übernommen. Also, Marcel sagt, jeder Brasilianer ist ein Gouverneur und inzwischen ist es aber auch bei, hat er es auch geschafft, dieser Marcel, dass er andocken kann an Konservative, an andere Politiker, auch weil er zum Beispiel einen Stogen hat wie, jede Familie eine Nation. Also, man hat so eine ganz merkwürdige Verehrung der Familie und einen individualistischen Kult und eine Abwendung von der Gesellschaft. Und das ist eigentlich jetzt die neue Entwicklung, die in Brasilien ist und die dann in Bolsonaro auch aufzugreifen weiß, wenn sich der Marcel noch nicht selbst durchsetzen kann. Schließlich heißt es hier, das Schwinden der Tradition und des Katholizismus mit seiner eher kollektiven Ausrichtung sollte eine Öffnung für eine progressive, säkulare Politik ermöglichen. Doch für viele stellt dies in Ermangelung einer großen neuen Idee, die die Lehre des Sinns füllen könnte, auch eine scheinbar existenzielle Bedrohung dar. Und jetzt ist da einfach nur ein Platz vakant geworden. Und jetzt springen diese Coaching-Typen da rein.
Tja, das ist mal Lifestyle-Politik, würde ich sagen. Ja. Die dann auch bald bei uns ankommt, so wie die ganzen Brazilian Buttlifts und so weiter. Da sind sie ja gute Vorreiter, was Lifestyle angeht. Ja. Mein letzter Text behandelt die große Frage, was machen wir denn jetzt mit dieser ganzen Unzufriedenheit, die sich aufbaut, wenn wir zuhören zum Thema Brasilien und so weiter. Die eine Antwort ist, wir flüchten uns in die Literatur. Matthias Kalle hat in der Zeit darüber geschrieben, ich habe diesen Text leider nicht in meinem großen Berg Zeittexte gefunden. Und habe aber keinen Zugang zu online. Also ich weiß nicht genau, ob ich gerade diesen ganzen Text von Matthias Kalle vor mir habe oder doch nur so einen halben, weil er endet einfach nach recht viel Zeit mit wählen Sie Ihren Zugang und lesen Sie weiter. Aber ist in dem Fall auch egal. Denn die Pointe lässt sich sehr gut transportieren, indem man auch beispielsweise nur 80 Prozent des Textes liest. Wenn mir früher jemand die Frage stellte, was ich denn gerade lesen würde, dann habe ich immer gelogen, ist der erste Satz. Denn was liest man natürlich, wenn man gefragt wird, was lesen Sie eigentlich gerade? Natürlich Philip Roth oder JM. Götzi, keine Ahnung, wer das ist.
Koizide in der Literatur Nobelpreisträger. Lohnt sich auch, den zu lesen.
Und ich habe ihn wirklich gelesen. Sehr gut, wie auch immer, Didion.
Ja, französische Schriftstellerin.
Scheint auch jemand von Format zu sein. Virginia Woolf, Max Frisch oder Annie Proulx. Kennen die auch wieder nicht?
Proulx.
Proulx, ohne X damit. Okay, gut, das waren die typischen Antworten, für die sich Max Kalle heute schämt, denn er hätte doch wirklich gleich sagen sollen. Nee, ich lese Stephen King. Lesen, wirkliches Lesen. Dieses sich über Kopf in ein Buch stürzen, untertauchen und erst wieder hochkommen, wenn man keine Luft mehr bekommt. Atmen, wieder untertauchen, bis man den Boden erreicht. Das passiert mir nur mit Büchern von Stephen King. Er ist der Beste. Der größte Schriftsteller der Gegenwart, lautet hier das Urteil. Er wurde also am 21. September 1975 und hat so Pi mal Daumen 75 Bücher geschrieben. Zum einen diesen jüngsten Roman, Fairytale oder eben 74, sein erstes Ding, Carrie. Ich bin 1975 erschienen und habe es noch nicht einmal geschafft, alle Bücher von Stephen King zu lesen. Denn ich fand erst spät zu King, die Gründe dafür sind Dummheit, Ignoranz und Vorurteile. Und da geht es nicht nur um seine eigenen. Denn nachdem zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Bücher, die in Deutschland dann Misery heißen, er hat dann Sie und Es und dachte, gibt es hier noch irgendwo ein Er und so. Also große Verwirrung. Aber ein anderer Grund war, dass Stephen King als Horror-Autor vermarktet wurde und seine Bücher als Grüselschocker. Und dann erst als ich anfing, Stephen King zu lesen, wusste ich, dass ich überhaupt nichts verstanden hatte. Sein erstes Buch war dann Es. Er hat es gelesen, er war begeistert. Ich behielt für mich, dass ich beim Lesen eines Buches noch nie so glücklich und ängstlich und traurig war. Manchmal alles während einer Seite. Hä? Geht es in Es nicht um so einen verrückten Clown? Vergessen Sie mal den Clown! Und dann erklärt er so, worum es für ihn in Es geht. Wo ich denke, ich habe es mir schon gekauft, ich werde es direkt mal lesen. Wer Es gelesen hat, wird danach ein anderer sein. Ich war vor allem stinksauer, nachdem ich Es gelesen hatte. Warum hat mir niemand die Wahrheit über dieses Buch gesagt? Über Stephen King? Es ist eine kleine Abhandlung, die hier folgt, über die Literaturkritik. Denn haben wir es nicht mit einem Literaturbetrieb zu tun, der sagt, jemand, der so viel schreibt, und dem das auch gar keine Arbeit macht, zu schreiben. Der gar nicht dieses Ding, ich leide so beim Schreiben, aber dafür verwirkliche ich mich komplett. Sondern der sagt, ich gehe morgens an den Schreibtisch, schreibe euch ein Buch, dann ist es fertig. Das können wir nicht als Literatur ansehen.
Ich bin ein bisschen erstaunt, dass jetzt hier von Kalle als eine neue These etabliert wird. Denn es ist doch so, dass es schon Ausgaben gab, z.B. von Druck Frisch mit Dennis Scheck, der für Stephen King Werbung machte. Ich erinnere mich sogar an eine Episode, wo er auf Martin Walzer in einer Buchhandlung trifft und Walzer ihm erklärt, was das Besondere an Stephen King ist. Und dass er aber auch erst brauchte, das herauszufinden, dass King diesen Moment, wo man fast tot ist, so hervorragend beschreiben kann. Und dass es da einen sehr guten Essayband wiederum zu gibt. Also diese King-Exegese wird ja schon von einigen Literaturkritikern betrieben.
Ja, also ich kann mir das auch gut vorstellen, dass in Druck Frisch mal 5 Minuten zu King so vorkam. Aber mich hat das hier komplett abgeholt, weil das war auch mein Blick auf King. Und so wie das hier beschrieben wird, scheint er ein ganz anderer Stephen King zu sein als der Horror-Autor, der uns immer dargelegt wird, dessen Bücher dann auch so mal so verfilmt werden und so. Er schreibt hier so über sein Gläserlebnis. Blablabla. Ich stelle mir vor, dass King nichts, was er schreibt, auch nur annähernd so gut findet wie alles, was er in S geschrieben hat. Weil in diesem Buch alles drin ist, was in King steckt, seine ganzen Ängste, seine ganzen Hoffnungen, sein ganzer Glaube, seine ganze Liebe. Also es erschien 1986. Jetzt gibt es eine Luxusausgabe mit einem super schlauen Nachwort von Dietmar Daert. Das lockt mich natürlich nochmal umso mehr. Und es ist ein ganz wunderbarer Umgang mit seiner Vermutung, wie King, von dem wir wissen, wie industriell er schreibt, wie er wohl mit seinen eigenen Texten so umgeht. Weil der Autor, also der Kalle hier gar nicht glauben kann, dass überhaupt ein Mensch in der Lage ist, so zu schreiben, wie der King schreibt. King schreibt aber auch schlechte Bücher. Also es gibt durchaus diesen Kontrast, die die guten Bücher dann nochmal besonders hervorheben. Und ich habe das wahnsinnig amüsiert hier gelesen. Vor allem wusste ich auch nicht, 350 Millionen Bücher. Also verkaufen, indem man einfach jeden Tag sagt, auf die Frage, wie schreiben sie eigentlich ihre Bücher? Ein Satz nach dem anderen. Und dann geht er morgens an den Schreibtisch und sagt, ich schreibe jetzt 2000 Wörter. Dafür brauche ich vier bis sechs Stunden. Und das war dann mein Arbeitstag. Und dann rutschen da halt diese Bücher so raus. Und dann schreibt Kalle, Ich glaube, die Literaturkritik verhält sich gegenüber Stephen King mitunter wie ich mit 13. Sie begegnet ihm mit der gleichen Mischung aus Dummheit, Ignoranz und Vorurteil. Für die Literaturkritik bleibt King ein Horrorautor, gefangen in seinem Genre. Und wer Genre schreibt, der kann keine Literatur herstellen. Und das ist auch mein ganz, ich hab nicht viel mitbekommen, aber das ist das.
Ich glaube, hier wird aber doch schon was gegen was gekämpft, also in gewisser Weise eine offene Tür eingerannt. Ich kann das jetzt bei Stephen King, übrigens Didion ist natürlich Amerikanerin, keine Französin. Ich hab das bei King selbst nie nachvollziehen können, warum so viele dann doch begeistert sind von King. Also ich habe es gelesen und ich bin sehr gespannt, was du dazu sagen wirst. Ich finde, dass er eine Qualität hat, und zwar in Milieubeschreibungen. Also ich würde auch sagen, zu vernachlässigen sind eigentlich die Horrorelemente, da würde ich zustimmen. Aber diese Milieubeschreibungen sind gut und dann gibt es aber endlos literarisch vollkommen uninteressante Dialoge, die sich in diesen Romanen entspinnen. Solche Clip-Clap-Dialoge immer noch mal weiter, weiter, weiter. Irgendwann bekommt man noch eine Info, die man braucht. Und dann entsteht aber kein gutes Gespräch oder so, dass man sagt, das kann ich genießen, sodass ich immer sagen muss, bei vielen Seiten, die ich von Stephen King lese, arbeitet mein Kopf schneller, als ich lesen kann. Und deswegen bin ich dann wiederum davon gelangweilt. Das ist ein Vorwurf, den ich mache. Ich würde sagen, dass Cary, vielleicht weil er in Kürzhauermann der bessere ist, aber viel mehr habe ich auch von Stephen King nicht gelesen. Ich würde aber sagen, ja, früher gab es das ganz stark, dass man sagte, die Autoren, die im Genre sind, die sind halt Genreautoren, aber keine richtigen Autoren. Also die Hochliteratur ist was anderes, die Autoren, die er eben genannt hat. Und doch gibt es ja zum Beispiel auch eine ganz große Patricia Heismas-Renaissance, die nur Kriminalromanen geschrieben hat. Und dann gab es aber schon früh so Leute wie Peter Handke, die sagten, sie sei eigentlich so die Größte des 20. Und dann ist man verblüfft, dass das ausgerechnet von einem Handke kommt, der ja überhaupt keinen Genre schreibt. Und dann liest man Patricia Heismas und sagt, ja stimmt, das ist ja nicht einfach hier ein spannender Krimi. Da geht es ja um sehr viel mehr. Und deswegen glaube ich auch, sich mit dem Genre neu auseinanderzusetzen ist gut. Bei Stephen King bin ich doch so inzwischen, dass ich sage, das sind mir dann zu viele Seiten für zu wenig Ertrag. Aber ich bin gespannt, was du zuerst sagen wirst. Ich kann sagen, es ist auf jeden Fall besser als das, was verfilmt wurde.
Also ich hole mir auf jeden Fall, eins habe ich schon und das zweite nenne ich gleich, Bücher auf Papier, um sie auch wirklich da zu haben und also sichtbar einfach im Raum liegen zu haben und dann zu lesen. Denn zwei Sachen, zum einen, ja, du hast natürlich wahrscheinlich Recht. Ich nehme aber an diesem Diskurs so nicht teil, also Druck, Frischwände, irgendwann massiven King-Thema, aber ich weiß sowas nicht mehr und habe es wahrscheinlich auch nie gesehen. Und zum anderen für unsere Hörer, die jetzt mehr an, also so auf meiner Wellenlänge sind und sich fragen, Stephen King, sollte ich echt mal ein Buch von Stephen King wenigstens lesen? Das sollte man machen, ja. Und welche beiden, das ist ja jetzt interessant, ja, 75 Bücher sind im Angebot, welche beiden sollte man jetzt lesen? Also es haben wir schon genannt, 1986 oder 83 oder so. Und dann kommt eben 46 Jahre später jetzt aktuell ein nächstes, von dem der Autor wie folgt spricht und er leitet erst mal ein, die vergangenen zehn Jahre waren nicht seine besten als Schriftsteller. Er ist auch ständig auf Twitter, hat sich mit Donald Trump angelegt und schaut viel Fernsehserien. Würde er noch einmal zur alten Form zurückkehren können? Die Antwort ist ja, er würde. Fairytale, also das Aktuelle, ist ein Geschenk an seine Leser zu seinem 75. Geburtstag. Und was das für ein Buch geworden ist. Ausrufezeichen, Satz für Satz, Absatz für Absatz. Fairytale ist ein gewaltiges Märchen, ein Triumph der Erzählkunst. Und dann vielleicht war Stephen King noch nie verschwenderischer mit seiner Fantasie als auf diesen knapp 900 Seiten.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade überlegen, aber 900 Seiten Stephen King.
Also S 1300 mit Dietmar Datenachwort finde ich natürlich sehr einladend.
Man liest es natürlich sehr schnell. Man kann es richtig schnell lesen.
Und ja, dann Fairytale gleich hinterher. 900 Seiten nochmal. Ich denke mir, ich vertraue jetzt Kalle. Kann natürlich immer sein, dass wir hier einem Autor und seiner eigenen Perspektive zum Opfer fallen. Ich glaube es nicht. Am Ende wird die Auswahl gut sein. Es und Fairytale. Und ich lade doch alle ein, mit mir das jetzt zu lesen. Ich verspreche dann auch, es wird eine Reflektion geben, sobald ich vorankomme oder fertig bin, je nachdem.
Wir sind gespannt. Und es ist jedenfalls sinnvoller, King zu lesen, als das zu tun, was die Autorin Monika Shin gemacht hat. Die hat sich nämlich ein Tamagotchi gekauft, das nicht dieses übliche Tamagotchi ist, sondern in diesem Tamagotchi-Ei wohnt ein Sänger von BTS. Sie ist ein großer K-Pop-Fan. Sie nimmt das Angebot mal wahr und schreibt dann zugleich auch noch in The Verge einen Artikel darüber. In The Verge hat sie das gemacht. Das ist ja nun die Adresse, wo man über technische Neuerungen schreiben kann. Es ist ein ganz amüsanter Text. Sie schreibt dann auch, dieser Mann ist jetzt mein Mündel. Also Jimin oder so heißt der. Den hat sie sich dann ausgesucht als Tamagotchi. Und wie sieht das jetzt nun aus? Seit ich diesen professionellen Sänger unter meinen Treuen und halbwegs aufmerksam Pfittiche genommen habe, weckt mich das Tamagotchi jeden Morgen um 8 Uhr. Jimin, wenn du das hier liest, ich liebe dich, aber 8 Uhr ist zu früh, beschäftige dich wenigstens bis 8.30 Uhr. Ich habe das Gerät drei Zimmer weiter weg aufgestellt und sein Gesang weckt mich immer noch auf. Was euch eine Vorstellung davon geben sollte, wie absurd laut dieses Ding ist. Es gibt zwei Dinge, die sie mit dem Miniatur-BTS-Mitglied tun können. Man kann es füttern und man kann mit ihm spielen, damit ihm nicht langweilig wird. Und das ist natürlich wie bei so einem Tamagotchi-Ei von früher nicht besonders aufregend. Das ist mit großen Pixel und ein paar Tasten A und B kann man hin und her klicken. Sie schreibt, ich habe Jimin jeden Morgen gefüttert und mit ihm gespielt und bin dann zur Arbeit gegangen. Das Tamagotchi piepte und piepste den ganzen Tag über, immer wieder, um zu signalisieren, dass es Zeit war, Jimin Aufmerksamkeit zu schenken. Nämlich darum geht es, dass man möglichst viel Zeit mit Jimin verbringt und dass man eine enge Bindung auf diese Weise zu ihm aufbaut. Das ist dann noch mal die Fan-Liebe in intensivierter Form. Das erinnert mich jetzt auch gerade so ein bisschen an Präsidentie. Da ist es doch so, dass man sich jeden Tag seine Reden auf dem Smartphone anhören muss. Man kann auch nicht einfach irgendwas wegscrollen oder so, sondern man muss einfach dadurch und soll jetzt diese Aufmerksamkeit ihm schenken. Ähnlich ist das auch hier angelegt. Nun ist es so, dass man ihn füttern muss und dann denkt man schon, was ist, wenn man ihn jetzt nicht füttert? Naja, dann wird er krank. Und es steht dann auch in der Gebrauchsanweisung. Was passiert, wenn dein BTS-Mitglied lange genug krank ist? Laut Gebrauchsanweisung geht er zurück zur Tür. Und damit ist gemeint, also er kommt aus so einer Tür raus, wenn du das Ei kaufst und dann damit beginnst. Und wenn er dann wieder zurückgeht, heißt es, also dann stirbt er und unter ihrer Aufsicht sei er mehrmals krank geworden, aber nie ernsthaft krank. Und man muss dann eben wieder neue Aufmerksamkeit diesem Sänger zukommen lassen. Ich habe philosophisch mit der Frage gerungen, ob ich es gut heiße, dass der Konzern auf diese Weise profitiert, Kindern einzureden, dass ihr Idol eine reale Person, die sie lieben und um die sie sich sorgen, durch ihre Hand sterben wird, wenn sie nicht oft genug auf einen winzigen Knopf drücken. Das sieht eigentlich, schreibt die Autorin nach, so einer Black-Mirror-Folge aus. Fairerweise muss man sagen, dass die Manipulation von Menschen, einschließlich Kindern, damit sie sich für fiktive Dinge interessieren, das Grundprinzip der modernen Unterhaltung ist. Um The Witcher 3 zu spielen, nehme ich ein Stück Plastik in die Hand und drücke winzige Knöpfe. Und wenn ich sie nicht richtig drücke, passieren Gerald und seinen Freunden schlimme Dinge. Man könnte argumentieren, dass dies ein unerlässlicher Bestandteil eines gut konzipierten Spiels ist. Ein cleverer Weg, um das Publikum zu fesseln und das Erlebnis real erscheinen zu lassen. Diese Gefahr sorgt für einen gewissen Einsatz. Ich strenge mich an, die Monster zu besiegen vor den wütenden Dorfbewohnern und so weiter. Aber sie sagt dann auch, PC-Spiele sind nicht das wahre Leben. Ich verkörper da eine fiktive Figur. Hier haben wir es mit etwas anderem zu tun. Hier haben wir es mit einer Figur zu tun, die zwar auch nur digital da existiert. Der ist ja nicht wirklich da drin, aber es verknüpft mit einem realen Menschen. Es wird durch dieses Tamagotchi-Ei keine Geschichte erzählt. Es überzeugt dich davon, dass du, du selbst und dein wirkliches Leben die Geschichte sind. Sie werden nicht Zeuge einer Beziehung mit Jimin, sondern sie selbst sind in einer Beziehung mit Jimin. Das ist dann diese problematische parasoziale Beziehung. Denn man verhält sich dann doch gerade, obwohl man weiß, dass es nicht so ist, dass dieser Jimin da wirklich drin ist, verhält man sich doch ein bisschen so und fängt an, so eine Nähe aufzubauen. Sie schreibt vor einigen Jahren, hatte ich den Aibo, den Roboterhund von Sony getestet. Er war niedlich, anhänglich und charmant, ohne dass er die Möbel zerkratzte und auf den Teppich pinkelte, wie es echte Welten tun. Ich habe ihn geliebt, aber diese Liebe hatte auch eine Schattenseite. Ich vermisste ihn, wenn ich weg war. Neulich habe ich mir ein paar Videos angesehen, die ich von ihm aufgenommen hatte. Jahre später vermisse ich ihn immer noch irgendwie. Und sie sagt dann auch, es spielt keine Rolle, ob ein Kind rational weiß, dass es sich um ein Spiel handelt. Der Teil ihres Verstandes, der sie immer wieder dazu bringt, diese Knöpfe zu drücken, ist derselbe Teil, der sich aufregen wird, wenn ihre Nachlässigkeit dazu führt, dass Jimin krank wird. Der Teil von ihr, wie winzig auch immer, der davon überzeugt ist, dass Jimin tatsächlich da drin ist. Und was dieses Spiel dann eigentlich produziert ist, bei den Kindern ein Pflichtgefühl, dass sie danach streben müssen, Jimin-Aufmerksamkeit zu schenken, ohne dass sie wirklich etwas bekommen dafür, also weder echte Liebe, noch eigentlich ein großes spielerisches Erlebnis. Eigentlich werden sie nur zu einer Pflicht zur Fan-Liebe erzogen.
Sehr gute Diagnose, passt natürlich genau in die Zeit.
Und damit enden wir für dieses Mal, nach einem sehr langen Salon diesmal. Wir schauen, was wir als nächstes lesen, ob es dann wieder so kontrovers wird. Wir schauen mal, dann sehen wir uns jedenfalls Ende des Monats wieder zur regulären Folge.
Richtig, haut rein und vergesst nicht, euch zu begegnen. Bis dann.